FISCAL REVIEW SUB COMMITTEE R.
ONE TO ORDER. AND I HAVE A FEW
OF OUR RULES ABOUT- BAR CODED
AND PARTICIPATION TO GO THROUGH.
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERED HANDED
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY IN THE CAPITAL- SO
MEMBERS COULD PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY TODAY ALL OF THE
SENATORS WILL BE HERE ON JOINED
ALREADY BY SENATOR MEN. OF THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY OR PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. BYPASS THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FUTURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A
POP UP WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING
YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON
MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE
BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK MAKE SURE
THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER- D. WE HAVE
HEARD THAT TWO DIFFERENT SUBJECT
MATTER AREAS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT'S
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND WHY
ARE YOU CAN SEE IT AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
THREE SIX TWO EIGHT THREE TWO.
THAT IS. SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT. THREE WHEN WE GET THAT
RIGHT. THREE THREE SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
USE TO TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
FOR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LONG
NUMBER. YOU'LL BE WHITE IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME HE
WILL BE ON MUTED AND YOU'LL BE
READY TO ADDRESS TO COMMITTEE.
ARE WE WILL DECIDE WHEN WE GET
TO THAT POINT IN THE PROGRAM. IT
FOR EARLY OR LATE IF WE HAVE TO
LIMIT TO A CERTAIN LEVEL TO
EITHER THE TOTAL PUBLIC COMMENT
TOWARD THE INDIVIDUAL TIME FOR
COMMENTS. WILL BASE THAT
JUDGMENT ON WHERE WE- UNDER WILL
BE CHARGED AT NOON TODAY SO WE
HAVE TO GET. THE HEARING DONE IN
THE PUBLIC COMMENT DONE BY NOW.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEAST FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTION SPEED.
OUR THIS IS THE FIRST OF TEN
HEARINGS OVER THE NEXT MONTH IN
A REGULAR SUB COMMITTEE PROCESS
WE WILL HEAR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS AND OTHER
RELATED PROPOSALS WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF SUB COMMITTEE
ONE FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE AND
HIGHER EDUCATION ISSUES WE ALSO
HAVE SOME SMALLER ASSIGNMENTS
LIKE THE STATE LIBRARY. ALL
THOSE WILL BE IN OUR
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING PROCESS IN
THE TEN HEARINGS THESE HEARINGS
AT THIS STAGE IN THE PROCESS
WILL LARGELY BE INFORMATIONAL
DESIGNED TO ALLOW FOR DISCUSSION
OF THE ISSUES AND TAKE FEEDBACK
TO INFORM ACTIONS WILL BE TAKEN
LATER ON. IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
. ALTHOUGH WILL DELIBERATE AND
DISCUSS POTENTIAL INVESTMENTS
AND AGREEMENTS FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO BUDGET ACT. WE WILL
ALSO LOOK BACK CAN DISCUSS
NUMEROUS INVESTMENTS IN
INITIATIVES THAT WERE INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. WE THEREFORE ANTICIPATE
THAT THE SUB COMMITTEE WILL HAVE
OVERSIGHT ITEMS FOR SEGMENTS AND
DEPARTMENTS INCORPORATED IN OUR
HEARINGS OVER THE NEXT FIVE
WEEKS. FOR THE ACCOUNTS STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS CSU AND FOR
THE CALIFORNIA. A STUDENT AID
COMMISSION SI SAX SUCH ITEMS
WILL BE PART OF THE FEBRUARY
TWENTY THIRD AGENDA. IN TWO DAYS
HERE. VIEW THE GOVERNOR.
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY WILL ALSO
DISCUSS FINANCIAL AID REFORM IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE AGREEMENTS
FROM THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS. FOR TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE HOW THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
INTERACTS WITH ALL OF THIS AND
THE REMAINING BARRIERS IN
EXPANDING OUR STATE'S FINANCIAL
AID. ADDITIONALLY WE WILL
DISCUSS AN UPDATE ON THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM WITH THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS- WE HAVE BEEN
JOINED BY SENATOR A CHORE BUT WE
HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW.
SO BEFORE WE BEGIN I WOULD ASK
SENATORS MEN OR TROUBLED IF YOU
HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS. ARE
WE ARE UNUSUALLY SPEECHLESS AT
THIS POINT- I THINK THEY'RE
GOING TO SAVE IT TO WARM UP
LATER SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN WITH ISSUE ONE. IT'S A
STATE FINANCIAL AID EXPANSION
UPDATES AND PROPOSALS ONGOING
ISSUES. AND THE S. AND- WE HAVE
AS PANELISTS MORE NGUYEN GARCIA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. CHECK BREMNER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION GABRIELA CHAVEZ FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
WITH THE KING FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
WILL GO IN THAT ORDER AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH MARLIN GARCIA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WELCOME TO THE. OKAY
I THINK WE ARE WE THINK I'M AND
YOU DIDN'T L. OKAY. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN LAYERED AND MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE MY NAME IS
MARLENE GARCIA AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME PRESENT BEFORE YOU TODAY. UP
FIRST LET ME START BY THINKING
OF THE LEGISLATURE AND THOSE OF
YOU ON THE SUB COMMITTEE IN THE
GOVERNOR FOR YOUR HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS LAST YEAR AND
EXPANDING THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ENTITLEMENT GRANTS. AND
ADDRESSING THE- STUDENTS BASIC
NEEDS. THIS ACTION ALONE
PROVIDED MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND NEW CAL GRANTS TO LOW
INCOME STUDENTS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS LAST FALL WHO
OTHERWISE WOULD NOT HAVE
RECEIVED TO GET CRACKED EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE FULLY ELIGIBLE.
SOME OF THESE STUDENTS WERE ABLE
TO. ACTIVE- AND WERE ABLE TO USE
FOR BASIC- LIVING EXPENSES FOOD
HOUSING AND OTHER SCHOOL
EXPENSES. SO WE WERE REALLY
THRILLED TO BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
OPPORTUNITY AVAILABLE TO SO MANY
STUDENTS. WE HAVE LAID A SOLID
FOUNDATION FOR FINANCIAL AID
REFORM AND NOW WE ARE EAGER TO
COMPLETE JOB BY IMPROVING THE
CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK. THE
GOVERNOR HAS LAID OUT A BOLD 70%
COLLEGE ATTAINMENT GOAL AS PART
OF HIS TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET PROPOSAL. CALGARY
EQUITIES. TWO THIRTY THREE THAT
GOAL. THE CALIFORNIA EQUITIES
WILL PROVIDE A WORKABLE
EQUITABLE FINANCIAL AID FORMULA
THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
OF COLOR AND LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS THIS FRAMEWORK IS VITAL
TO MEET ATTAINMENT GOALS WHILE
KEEPING STUDENTS ON A PATH TO
GRADUATION WE KNOW HOW EXPENSIVE
IT IS TO ATTAIN A COLLEGE
EDUCATION AND- THE- BEST IN OUR
INVESTMENTS. TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE HEADLINES IN
HOME IT IN A MOMENT AMID COBIT
NINETEEN. YES SIR TOO HIGH NOT
TO AND IMPLEMENT THIS- EQUITY
FRAMEWORK NOW OUR WORKFORCE AND
OUR ECONOMY DESPERATELY NEED
CALIFORNIA'S TALENT TRAINED AND
SKILLED WORKERS READY TO THRIVE
. CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENTS
ARE FACING HUGE CHALLENGES AND
ARE STRUGGLING TO MEET THEIR
BASIC NEEDS ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS PROLONGED AND PAINFUL
PANDEMIC LET'S REMOVE FINANCIAL
AID IS ONE OF THESE BARRIERS.
LOW INCOME STUDENTS HAVE SO MANY
COMPLEX ISSUES TO NAVIGATE
INCLUDING AFFORDABILITY AND
FINANCIALLY CAN GO A LONG WAY IN
MAKING IT EASIER FOR THEM TO
SUCCEED. ROGER COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTES THERE WAS CAL
GRANT REFORM LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR THAT WAS ULTIMATELY VETOED
BY THE GOVERNOR WHO INDICATED IN
HIS VETO MESSAGE THAT HE
SUPPORTED. THE CONCEPT OF CAL
GRANT REFORM AND MAKING IT
EASIER FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
NAVIGATE THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
BUT THAT THIS WORK. WITHIN STATE
. THIS YEAR'S BUDGET PROVIDES US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD OFF OF
LAST YEAR'S HISTORIC INVESTMENTS
AND REMOVE THE REMAINING
BARRIERS TO STUDENT ELIGIBILITY
AS WE STREAMLINING VERY
COMPLICATED PROGRAM. CALIFORNIA
IS POISED TO TAKE CRITICAL
ACTION THIS YEAR TO MAKE COLLEGE
AFFORDABLE NOT JUST FOR OUR
LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS BUT OUR
MIDDLE CLASS STUDENTS THIS IS A
GAME CHANGER MOMENT FOR MOVING
CLOSER TO SUPPORTING DEBT FREE
COLLEGE AND INVESTING IN THE
FUTURE TALENTS OF OUR STATE THAT
WE SO DESPERATELY NEED RIGHT
NOW. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OR WE CAN TURN TO DRAG
OUT BREMNER MY COLLEAGUE WHO CAN
PROVIDE FULL DETAILS ON THE
VARIOUS BUDGET ITEMS BEFORE YOU
TODAY. WE ARE GOING TO GO TO MR
BREMNER BUT I'VE A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION WHICH
LEGISLATURE. POLLUTION THAT'S ON
THE WALL BEHIND. WE ONLY. OKAY
WAS LIKE RESOLUTION OF THIS LINE
IS. I HAVE OPTED FOR BILL
EISENBERG AND THEN I HAVE
ANOTHER ONE OVER HERE FROM
SENATOR LOW INSTALLED. OKAY THAT
TELLS ME A HOW LONG AGO YOU WERE
RECOGNIZED I DON'T THINK SO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EISENBERG IS
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX SO IT'S IT
SHOULD BE. IN OTHER WORDS IT
MEANS I'M PRETTY OLD. NO I'M
SORRY ONLY YOU CAN SAVE LIKE
THAT TO- COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS AT THE END OF ALL FOR
AND WE WANT TO MISTER BROWN.
GOOD MORNING SURE LAYERED AND
SENATORS IT IS GOOD TO BE BACK
WITH YOU THIS MORNING I'M JAKE
PREMIERE- DIRECTOR GOVERNMENT
AND EXTERNAL REALLY. THE
CALIFORNIA STREET. AND ALSO IT
MIGHT TODAY BY JUST EXPANDING ON
SOME OF THE POINTS THAT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR GARCIA HEY-
I'M HAPPY TO ALSO SHARE UPDATES
ON A SPECIFIC IMPLEMENTATION-
PROGRESS WE'VE MADE AROUND THE
CALIBRATED TITLE MEANT THAT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR. OR CEO SPOKE
TO FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS AS WELL AS THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM IN ITS
REVISED STRUCTURE. BUT JUST TO
BRIEFLY EXPAND ON THE POINTS
AROUND OUR PROGRESS IN A
FINANCIALLY EXPANSION AND
REFORM. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
NATIONAL LEADER IN CREATING
AFFORDABLE PATHWAYS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WE BUILT ON
THAT WORK. LAST YEAR HOWEVER WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE APPS.
SERVING STUDENTS. YOU'RE A
MATERIALS A GREAT JOB AT. TO THE
REMAIN CAPS IN ACCESS TO THE CAL
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS GEMMA. THE
ADDITIONAL COME. IN OUR SYSTEM
RIGHT NOW. ANDWE KNOW THAT OUR
LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS. ALSO
LACK THE- ABILITY TO. FULLY
ADDRESS FOR NON TUITION EXPENSES
LIKE HOUSING FOOD TECHNOLOGY
TRANSFER AND BOOKS AND OTHERS.
WE DO NEED BELIEVE THAT PERSON
TO ADDRESS AND WE'RE MOVING A
BARRIERS TO ACCESS IN THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM FOR ALL OF OUR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. PURSUING HIGHER
EDUCATION. WE CAN BUILD ON THE
MOMENTUM FROM LAST YEAR'S
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS TO CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS- AND WHAT WE WERE
ABLE TO REMOVE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS THERE
ARE STILL BARRIERS FOR OUR
STUDENTS YOU ARE TRANSFERRING TO
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS OR WHO
ENROLL AS FRESHMEN OUT OF FOR
YOUR INSTITUTION. PERTAINING.
ONE BEFORE IT PURSUE THEIR POST
SECONDARY AND- ADDITIONALLY YOU
REQUIRE TO PROVIDE. FOR GPA DATA
KEEP OUT MANY OF OUR ADULT
LEARNERS FROM ACCESSING CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE QUALIFY BASED ON THEIR
INCOME. YEAH REQUIREMENTS ARE A
RATIONING NEXT FOR STATE
FINANCIAL. THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY EXCLUDES OR
ADULT RETURNING LEARNERS DESPITE
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROBABLY
SERVING THE TOP 1100% OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AS
CHANCELLOR WE SAYS. TOMGRAM ALSO
CURRENTLY PERCENT MORE BUT MADE
SPEND A STRAIGHTFORWARD PATHWAY
TO AFFORDABLE. AS YOUR AGENDA
NOTES WE HAVE EIGHT DIFFERENT
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS CURRENTLY
BEFORE EVEN CONSIDERING THE
OTHER NEWS SPECIALIZED PROGRAMS
THAT. PART. THIS MAKES UNDER AND
NOW THE CHALLENGING STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
MIGHT BE THE FIRST IN THEIR
FAMILY TO ATTEND COLLEGE. THE
SECOND IS REMOVING BARRIERS- BY
STREAMLINING THE PROGRAM AND
ESTABLISHING A CALGARY TO WORK
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT AND
HOW FOR STUDENTS LOOKING HER
DUTIES AND PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS
AS YOUR GENDER ALSO WANTED. I
DON'T. I MEAN WE HAVE WE CAN
MAKE HOW AND LIGHT OF LAST
YEAR'S EXPAND AND BEES PROPOSED
AS WELL AS WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN LA- TO
A CALL ESTIMATE WHAT I CAN SHE.
FULL TO ME. BRANCH FOR IN SUCH A
WAY THAT ELIGIBILITY ON WITH
THAT FOR THE PROGRAM FOR IT
PROVIDES A SUPPORT TOWARDS
POLITICS FOR STUDENTS WE CAN
MAKE ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
STUDENTS FOR CAL EIGHT I'M MORE
PRETTY. I NOTED WE ARE WORKING-
DEPART OF FINANCE THE L. A.
WOULD LIKE. BUDGET STAFF TO
DEVELOP COST ESTIMATES FOR THAT
PROPOSAL I CAN SHARE THAT THE
INITIAL ESTIMATES SUGGEST THIS
WOULD BE LIKELY IN THE- THE
RANGER. CHIU HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR PERHAPS MORE IN
ONGOING ADDITIONAL FUNDS BEYOND
THE CURRENT CALTRAIN
APPROPRIATIONS. SO WITH THAT I
WILL PAUSE THERE AND- WITH FORTY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT
OUR PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING THE
NEW FINANCIALLY EXPANSIONS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND I WOULD
COMMENT THAT. EARLY THE
RESOLUTION THE WALL BEHIND YOU
YET TO AND WE LOOK FOR TO LIKE
THE IN AND WANT TO WRESTLE THAT
SHOW- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
GABRIELA CHÁVEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE. HI GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED BASED AT THE RALLY
CHAVEZ BUT THE POINT OF
FINANCES. THE COCKRUM PROGRAM
THE STATE'S LARGEST IN FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAM IS EXPECTED TO SAVE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN TWENTY. TWO TWENTY
THREE HE GLENDALE A HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS NEARLY
ONLY TO THE GULF. IS IN THE
TWENTY. THE BUDGET ASSUMES
FINANCIAL AID X. OF THREE POINT
EIGHT. OF WHICH THREE FOUR
BILLION SCORES A COMMON PROGRAM
AND THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO MILLION I'M GOING TO GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT THE MIDDLE CLASS
THE REVISED LAST PROGRAM HE- WE
NEED TWENTY ONE BY TWO ACT WHICH
EFFECT IN TWENTY. TO TWENTY. THE
BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES AN INCREASE
OF THREE HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE
LEARNING A LINE OF PEOPLE
EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES A TWO YEARS TOTAL OF.
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION. WHEN
COMBINED WITH THE FUNDS. IN THE
PROGRAM AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET I. THINK I'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND NOW WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO LIESEGANG FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WELCOME TO SENATORS BEFITTING
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
. COMMENT BRIEFLY ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS IN THIS
ISSUE CARE AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCES SHARE
THE COMPANY PROVIDES AT TOTAL
FUNDING LEVEL OF SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO MILLION ON MINE FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM. NOT LINES. THE LAST
LEGISLATURE AND SO WE HAVE NO
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSED
FUNDING LEVEL. BASED ON MOST
RECENT BY THE BY THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THIS AMOUNT IS ENOUGH
TO FIND AN ESTIMATED 24% OF THE
TOTAL CALCULATED MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WORK SPEAKS. THIS
PROGRAM IS TO BE IMPLEMENTATION
IS PROVING TO BE COMPLEX. AND AT
THIS POINT IT IS UNCERTAIN
WHETHER WHAT AMOUNTS FOR
STUDENTS WILL BE DETERMINED IN
TIME FOR THEM TO RECEIVE THAT
INFORMATION THIS SPRING. AFTER
MAKING A CALLABLE DECISIONS. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR BUDGET
INCLUDES AN ADJUSTMENT SAID
INTENDED TO ALIGN THE PROGRAM'S
FUNDING LEVEL. BUT THE MOST
RECENT PAY FOR ESTIMATES FROM
THE COMMISSION. EACH SPRING THE
COMMISSION TYPICALLY OUT ITS
INVESTMENT STRICKLAND WAS RECENT
AVAILABLE PROGRAM DATA. AND IF
YOU'RE NOT WILL INCLUDE RECENT
DATA ON THE NEW COMMUNITY
COLLEGE EXPANDED RETIREMENT
PROGRAM. I THINK I THINK THIS
INFORMATION IS FORTHCOMING. WE
RECOMMENDED THE LEGISLATURE WAIT
UNTIL THE NEAR VISION LANCASTER
STATED BEFORE FINALIZING ANY CAL
GRANT FUNDING DECISIONS. MY
COMMENTS THIS FIRST ISSUE HERE
THANK YOU HAVE TAKING QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
QUESTIONS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM AND- OF AND I'M AND ASK A
COUPLE OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
DECIDING WHETHER THEY WANT TO
ASK AND- OF THE FIRST ONE
ACTUALLY RELATES TO COMMENT AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S JUST
MADE. BECAUSE LOCATION IS NOT
JUST TO LOOK AT NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET BUT TO MONITOR THE IMPACT
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE PREVIOUS BUDGET.
AND EVEN THOUGH. FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST JUST POINTED
OUT THE OBVIOUS THAT DID SOME
STATISTICS WON'T BE M. ON THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. OF
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM UNTIL THE
MAY REVISED I WAS GONNA ASK AT
LEAST TO STUDENT AID COMMISSION
AND OTHERS CAN COMMENT. ABOUT TO
WHAT- WHAT STEPS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
TO IMPLEMENT IT HOW IT'S GOING
IF YOU FEEL THERE'S ANY
PROBLEMS. ARE JUST GIVE US AN
OVERVIEW OF WHAT IT'S BEEN LIKE
TO IMPLEMENT THAT THUS FAR. AND
I THINK WE'LL START WITH THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR KRISTA
LOGICAL PERSON. WELL I WILL SAY
THAT- IMPLEMENTATION- IN
NOVEMBER OF THE REMAINING CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS WERE L. R. FOR
THE ENTITLEMENT RECIPIENTS- THEY
WERE INITIALLY- ELIGIBLE BUT NOT
RECEIVING AWARDS AND IT DID TAKE
A MAJOR EFFORT TO GET THAT DONE
AND WHAT'S FOR US IS IT YOU KNOW
THE SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME. I
BELIEVE THAT WE PLEASED WITH THE
RESPONSE WITH THE NUMBER OF NEW
AWARDS I GOT DISTRIBUTED AND
SENT OUT TO THE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES- BY NOVEMBER AND- SO
FAR WE HAVE I THINK THAT THE
PAID RATE IS STILL BEING PROCESS
SO IT'S NOT A 100% YEAH BUT
WE'RE REALLY WORKING ACTIVELY TO
GET THAT PAID RATE TAKING CARE
OF SO THAT THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
THE MONEY IN THEIR POCKETS. WE
CAN PROVIDE THE DETAILS I'M PAID
RATES AND- AND THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO HAVE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED THEIR DISBURSEMENTS YOU
MEAN YOU CAN NOW ONE I HELP THAT
HAVE THAT DETAIL UNLESS MY
COLLEAGUES- JAKE HAS THAT
MOREOVER THE OTHER QUESTION IS
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE RATES AND-
CHANGING RATES DISSENT MEAN THAT
. SOME PEOPLE BE AT ELIGIBLE FOR
RETROACTIVE PAYMENTS IF THE
RATES WERE IN PLACE BUT THEY
WERE NOT REALIZED AS THEY
STARTED THE SCHOOL YEAR. SO WHAT
HAPPENS UNDER THE PREVIOUS-
COMPETITIVE GRANT- WE HAD A POOL
OF ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS. ARE JUST UNDER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A CAL GRANT BUT
THEY WERE PLACED IN THE
COMPETITIVE POLE AND THEY'RE
ONLY FORTY ONE THOUSAND AWARDS
IN THAT COMPETITIVE POLE SO WHAT
HAPPENED IS THERE'S ABOUT ONE IN
EIGHT STUDENTS WHO WAS ELIGIBLE
AND ACTUALLY GOT AN AWARD THE
REMAINING STUDENTS DIDN'T GET.
AWARDS INSTITUTE IF THEY HAD GPA
. WERE A TO GET AWARDS AND SO
THE AWARDS THAT ARE OFFERED TO
THEM AND THE FINAL STEP IS FOR
THEM TO ACTUALLY WALK INTO THE
FINANCIAL AID OFFICE AND PICK UP
THEIR TAX. BILLS WILL BE
CONSIDERED BURNER HAS HIS HAND
UP BEFORE COLUMN YOU JUST SAID
ONE THING. HE SAID IF THEY HAVE
GPAS. DOES THAT MEAN IF THEY
HAVE THEM AVAILABLE- IS THAT IT
DOES THAT MEAN AND I'M SORRY
THIS IS THE- SPECIAL INTERESTS
QUESTION FROM SOMEBODY THAT WENT
TO A GRADE LAW SCHOOL. IF YOU
WANT TO A PASS NO CREDIT SCORE
AND YOU HAVE NO GRIP. DO NOT
QUALIFY FOR GRANT. I THAT'S A
TECHNICAL ISSUE THAT I KNOW I
KNOW YOU WILL QUALIFY FOR CAL
GRANTS BUT THERE'S ANOTHER WAY
TO DETERMINE THE GPA AND I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH EXACTLY WHAT THAT
IS. BUT I WILL SAY THAT THIS GPA
REQUIREMENTS PARTICULARLY A FAX
ADULT LEARNERS PEOPLE GET OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL FOR YEARS AND THEY
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL AND- PULL UP THE GPA
TRANSCRIPT THAT IS. KIND OF
IRRELEVANT TO WHO THEY ARE AND-
TODAY AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
PROJECT. IS IN THE GROUND.
BIRTHDAY CAL EQUITIES FRAMEWORK
TO ELIMINATE THE GPA FOR A STATE
THAT BE A RELEVANCE. FACTOR IN
DETERMINING- ON WEEKENDS. YOU
CAN REPORT TO ME OFF TO THE
SIDE. AFTERWARDS IF YOU DISCOVER
THAT AND- AND I AM A VERY
CONSERVATIVE ALUMNI AND SO. IT
TURNS OUT THAT. I OPPOSED TO
GRADES BEING GIVEN WHEN THE-
ACADEMIC SENATE VOTED ON IT
HIGHLIGHTED CAMPAIGN TO DO THAT
SO. MUCH I THINK SAWYER YES MR
BREMNER YOU'RE. ARE PATIENTLY
BEEN WAITING. THANK YOU SAN AND
I CAN ANSWER A COUPLE THOSE POSH
TO BED TIME YOU JUST HEAD ON.
ALL FIRST JUST CHIME IN THIS
CALL ABOUT. THIS IN A HURRY WHEN
WHICH STUDENTS ARE SEEKING CAL
GRANT BUT MIGHT NOT HAVE WHAT WE
CALL A CAL GRANT ELIGIBLE GPA TO
SUBMIT THERE IS A PROCESS
THROUGH WHICH STUDENTS CAN
SUBMIT A TEST SCORE IN LIEU OF
GPA. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT HOME
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN PARTICULAR
UTILIZED CURRENTLY- WHAT I WILL
SURE THERE IS THAT OF COURSE.
TAKING ONE OF THE TESTS THAT
QUALIFY WHICH ARE ARE ACTIVELY
DEAN- ELIMINATED AS AS PIECES
FOR CONSIDERATION FOR ADMISSIONS
TWO OR FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITIES
IT'S ALSO SOMETHING THAT
TYPICALLY DOES RETURNING ADULT
LEARNERS AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
GARCIA SPOKE TO YOU. I'M NOT
DONE AND THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
TEST SCORES. AB THAT STORY A
BARRIER THOSE TWO BUT TO GET TO
OTHER AROUND HOW MANY HAVE WE
CURRENTLY WHAT IS TO THE NEW
COLLEGE ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT
LOOK LIKE RIGHT NOW I'M REALLY
PLEASED TO SHARE NUMBERS THAT WE
HAVE. SOME MORE SPECIFICS ON
WHAT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR GARCIA
SPOKE TO YOU IN NOVEMBER IN OUR
FIRST ROUND OF PROCESSING THESE
AWARDS WE SENT OFFERS FOR
CALIFORNIA WARTS YOU OVER ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR GARCIA NOTED-
THIS REALLY REPRESENTED STUDENTS
WHO WOULD NOT HAVE PREVIOUSLY
BEEN. AL PORTION AND THEN WHO
WOULD HAVE BEEN CAN. TO BE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT. THAT DOES
NOT PROVIDE PREDICTABLE ACCESS
GIVEN ITS IMPACT. SO WHEN YOU
LOOK AT HOW MANY STUDENTS WOULD
HAVE RECEIVED AWARDS UNDER THE
FORMER SYSTEM AND HOW MANY
STUDENTS WERE INSTEAD OFFERED IN
NOVEMBER THAT YIELDS WHAT LOOKS
LIKE A NET INCREASE OF ABOUT
NINETY FOUR THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS OFFERED A CALTRAIN
AWARD. BECAUSE OF ACTIONS TAKEN
LAST YEAR BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR SO THAT IS JUST-
SOMETHING WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
TO SHARE THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION I'M ALSO PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT IN THE PROCESS OF.
CONTINUOUSLY PROCESS. THAT'S
WORKING. IS PROVIDED BY THE
STUDENT THEIR CAP FINANCE AID
OFFICE. ANOTHER FOR THOUSAND
OFFERS TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WERE DELIVERED IN
JANUARY ON TOP OF THE PREVIOUS
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
THAT I MENTION. THERE ARE SOME
SPECIFIC ISSUES I CAN SHARE IN
TERMS OF HOW STUDENTS THAT
ACTUALLY GET PAID THEIR WORK AND
THIS IS A CAMPUS BASED PROCESS.
ONCE THEY'VE BEEN OFFERED THEIR
WORK BY THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION- BUT AGAIN THIS IS
ALSO SOMETHING THAT WOULD
TYPICALLY HAPPEN WITH A
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS.
AS AWARDS WERE BEING RECYCLED TO
OTHER STUDENTS AS THE INITIAL
OFFER STUDENT WASN'T BEING PAID
THEIR WORK SO I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT BUT ONE OF
THIS YEAR AND THE REALLY GOOD
NEWS ABOUT HOW MANY ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS WERE ABLE OFFERED AWARD
THIS YEAR. BECAUSE OF THE
INVESTMENT AND EXPANSION. MADE
IN LAST YEAR'S. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COM THAT TO. HELP IN. A AND
FOR THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
THEN MR BREMNER. LET ME ASK THE
SAME THING ABOUT THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP. OF THE IN
TERMS OF- WHAT STEPS YOU'VE
TAKEN TO IMPLEMENT IT AND WHAT-
YOU KNOW THUS FAR- FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND ANY CHANGE IN
THE PROGRAM OR ANY PROBLEMS AND
WE'LL START WITH THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND THEN I WILL GO TO
MISTER BREMER. AFTER THAT. SO WE
HAVE STARTED CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE SEGMENTS TO TALK ABOUT THE
DETAILS AS WE KNOW THEM IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FROM LAST
FROM LAST. AND WE BEGUN TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THIS WOULD
WORK IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS BECAUSE THERE IS
AN OVERLAY WITH THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS SO IT'S MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PLUS. IN THE CURRENT
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
. STUDENTS WHO ARE HIGHER INCOME
THAN THE ELIGIBLE CAL GRANT
SEASONS ARE THE ONES WHO GET
AWARDS AND NOW WITH THE NEW
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP- UC AND
CSU STUDENTS. WHO WHO- RECEIVER
CAL GRANT AS WELL AS STUDENTS
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE BECAUSE THE
FAMILIES EARNING LESS THAN TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND A YEAR ARE ALSO
ELIGIBLE SO IT'S BEEN GREATLY
EXPANDED. SO THE DETAILS THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON IS HOW YOU
ACTUALLY DETERMINE THAT CUSTOMER
TENDONS BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS
BASED ON. THE COST OF ATTENDANCE
AND THAT THAT THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP WOULD BE THEIR LAST
DOLLAR IT. STUDENT. SENATE
OFFICERS WOULD- ADDRESS THE-
FINANCIAL. PROGRAMS THAT
STUDENTS ARE. FOR PACKAGES AND
WHATEVER REMAINS THAT'S WHERE
THE STATE WOULD COME IN AND USE
MIDDLE CLASS ADULTS SCHOLARSHIP
TO CLOSE THE UNMET NEED GAP. AND
AT THIS POINT GIVEN THE FUNDING
LEVEL THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED WE
CAN CLOSE ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
PERCENT. OF THAT OF THE UNMET
NEED GAP. AND AND THERE'S
DIFFERENT WAYS YOU CAN.
IMPLEMENT SO THOSE ARE THE
ISSUES THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED
BY. WE'VE YOU GO TO THE L. A-
THING WHEN YOU SAY YOU CAN MEET
TWENTY FOUR PERCENT. OF THE
UNMET NEED GAP. DOES IT MEAN
THERE 76% UNDERDRESSED AT THAT
POINT. THE FUNDING WOULD COVER
CORRECT IT'S ONLY THAT THE
CURRENT FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHICH COVER
APPROXIMATELY 24% OF WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE THE FULL COST OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROGRAM
OVERSEE YOU KNOW SEVERAL YEARS
AND WHEN YOU SAY THE FULL COST
OF IMPLEMENTING THAT'S REALLY
STAFF. AND THAT'S WITH THIS ITEM
MORE TALK ABOUT RIGHT WERE THERE
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE N THE
COSTS OF IMPLEMENTATION. ARE NOT
BUYING A DRESS STORE BY THE
BUDGET. WELL THE STAFFING THIS
IS ISSUE I'M REFERRING TO BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP CRAFT FENDI. HASH IN
THE GRANT TO PASS A WRECKED
ASSISTANCE. CORRECT THAT'S WHAT
THIS MEANS FOR YOU TO NOW OKAY
JUST TRYING TO CLEAR THAT UP BUT
I INTERRUPTED YOU WHEN YOU WERE
GOING TO GO ON TO SOMETHING
ABOUT THE L. A. O. RIGHT THE L.
A. O. POINTED OUT THAT. THERE
ARE SOME YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT
COMPLEXITIES WITH IMPLEMENTATION
THAT WE'RE REALLY STARTING
THROUGH RIGHT NOW. AND WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE WAYS IN WHICH WE
CAN REALLY STREAMLINED SO THAT
WE CAN GET THE FUNDS OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT STUDENTS ARE IN DIRE
NEED NOW. SO WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT VARIOUS OPTIONS-
PROBABLY TWO OF THE MOST COMPLEX
ISSUES THAT WE THINK WARRANT
SOME CONSIDERATION AND WE REALLY
WANT TO HAVE A ROBUST
CONVERSATION WITH THE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS QUESTION.
CLEAN OF LEADS SENATE STAFF.
REALLY GET SOME INPUT. SHE ALL
ONE- RIGHT NOW MIDDLE CLASS.
REQUIRES THAT THIS BE THE LAST
DOLLAR TO PROVIDE IN THE
STUDENTS FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE.
THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO
IMPLEMENT AND THE SEGMENTS HAVE
REALLY SPOKEN OUT QUITE A BIT
IT'S MUCH EASIER TO IMPLEMENT
IT. AS PART OF THE OVERALL
PACKAGING SO THAT YOU CAN KIND
OF RELY ON THE SPECIFIED AMOUNT.
BECAUSE LAST DOLLAR THAT AMOUNT
VARIES IT'S A MOVING TARGET. AND
SO WHAT ARE THE IDEAS TO MAKE IT
EASIER AND STAFF NOT JUST FOR
THE- BUT ALL. FINANCIAL
ADMINISTRATORS EMPLOY. A
SEAMLESS WAS BE TO MAKE AN EARLY
. FIRST THAT MEANS YOU KNOW AND
THEN TO ALSO HAVE A DEFINED.
THAT YOU COULD GO BACK INTO YOUR
PACKAGING SO ARE TWO ISSUE THAT
WE REALLY. BUDGET CONTINUE JUST
AND HEAR FROM THE ARCHITECTS OF
THE PROPOSAL AS WELL AS THE
SEGMENTS IN TERMS OF AN
IMITATION WERE PREPARED TO
FACILITATE THOSE CONVERSATIONS-
OKAY SO WE'VE ALREADY STARTED
BUT THOSE ARE SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE'RE ZEROING IN ON. THANK
YOU ARMINA ASK MR BREMNER FEW
HAS ANYTHING TO ADD AND WHEN
HE'S DONE I'M GONNA GO TO THAT
COLAIO TO SEE IF SHE HAS ANY
COMMENTS SINCE OF THE L. A. O.
WAS REFERENCED IN YOUR COMMENTS
MR BREMNER. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND ALL ALL DOES OFFER SOME
BRIEF ADDITIONAL DETAIL TO ALL
THE POINTS THAT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OR CEO JUST LAID OUT
BUT I THINK REALLY REFLECT WHERE
WE ARE IMPLEMENTATION AND SOME
OF THE KEY CHALLENGES- THAT WERE
CONSIDERING TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH WITH OUR CAMPUS
PARTNERS- AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR NOTED WEEK WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A WORKGROUP WITH ARE
YOU SEE AND SEE IF YOU
COLLEAGUES TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE
CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
SUCCESSFULLY IN. THIS PROGRAM.
THE OTHER KEY PIECE THAT'S BEEN
TAKING PLACE SINCE THE-
REGULATORS. I'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE L. A. O. AND SEEKING
ADDITIONAL- STATEMENT DATA ABOUT
HOW THEIR INSTITUTIONAL AID
FUNCTIONS THAT USE IN CSU.
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE TOTAL COST
FOR IMPLEMENTING THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM GIVEN
THIS STRUCTURE COULD BE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR SPOKE TO
WHERE IT'S A PROGRAM THAT NOW
LOOKS AT TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE WANTS TO BE LAST
DOLLAR AND SIT ON TOP OF ALL
OTHER FORMS OF. FINANCIAL AID
AND ALSO PROVIDES AWARDS TO
STUDENTS BASED ON THE ANNUAL
APPROPRIATION- THOSE ARE THE KEY
DATA POINTS THAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO IDENTIFY HOW MUCH EACH
STUDENT COULD EXPECT TO RECEIVE.
WE NEED TO KNOW THE TOTAL COST
I'M INTERACTION. FINDING CREATED
FOR THIS PURPOSE. AND ALL THE
OTHER FORMS OF FINANCIAL AID TO
EACH OF THOSE NEW STUDENT
RECIPIENTS WOULD RECEIVE. SO IN
LATE DECEMBER WE DID- SHARE WITH
OUR COLLEAGUES AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALEJO- WHAT THE UPDATED
COST ESTIMATES LOOKS LIKE BASED
ON THE ADDITIONAL DATA THAT WE
RECEIVE FROM YOU SEEN CSU- AND
WE THEN SAW ON JANUARY TENTH OF
COURSE THE FUNDING AMOUNT THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOM PROPOSED TOWARD
THIS PROGRAM. IT DIDN'T REFLECT
THE AGREEMENT FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACTIVE
NEGOTIATION. AND WE STILL ARE
RECEIVING APPLICATIONS FOR STATE
FINANCIAL AID. MARCH SECOND I'M
MORE THAN WE WILL UNDERSTAND HOW
MANY STUDENTS DO YOU SEE IN CS
YOU HAVE APPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID
AND CAN BE. CONSIDERED FOR A
CALTRAIN WORK. BUT I CAN SHARE
IN TURN OF SOME OF DATA- OR CALL
THE WE SET THAT LA SPOKE TO THIS
A LITTLE. THE TOTAL FOR HIM. WE
ASSESSED TO BE TWO POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS TO COVER THAT
FULL AWARD AMOUNT THAT SITS ON
TOP OF OTHER FORMS OF BAY AND
THEN COVERS THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE. THAT WOULD SERVE AS
THE AGENDA MATERIALS LIKE
LEAVING OUT OVER THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND STUDENTS SO A
MUCH LARGER PROGRAM. AND IT HAS
BEEN PREVIOUSLY AND WE CAN PRESS
COME BACK TO THAT IN JUST. A
STATE IN. THIS PROGRAM. I DON'T
THINK 8% THOSE TO WOULD BE C. S.
MISTER. TO FORTY DOLLARS.
BALANCE THE OTHER 32% ARE AT THE
UC- ABOUT A HUNDRED FOURTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT WOULD
STAND TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP WORD. OF THE
TWO POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS AN
APPROPRIATION ABOUT 38% WOULD GO
TO THE NEW SEAT. OUR STUDENTS-
TWO HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF THAT SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY TO. SIXTY TWO PERCENT-
WERE ABOUT THREE OR NINETY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS WILL GO TOWARDS
THE ISSUE STUDENTS. WE ALSO IN
PROVIDING ESTIMATE ESTIMATED. AN
INCOME BASED ANALYSIS TO
DEMONSTRATE HOW MUCH OFAN AWARD
WOULD GO TO STUDENTS BASED ON
THEIR FAMILY INCOMES AND MADE
SURE THAT DATA WITH. BERMAN
FINANCING COMMITTEE STAFF THAT
THEY HAVE THAT AVAILABLE AS WELL
I'M AND THAT MIGHT BE SOMETHING
AS YOU CONSIDER PERHAPS MAKING
REFINEMENTS TO THE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE ON THIS PROGRAM SUCH
THAT IT WOULD BE A- FIRST DOLLAR
AND TO FIND AWARD AMOUNT. FOR
DIFFERENT STUDENT POPULATIONS
YOU CAN EXPECT TO BE OUR
POLICYMAKERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CONSIDER WHAT'S AN APPROPRIATE
AWARD FOR STUDENTS OF VARIOUS
INCOME. CATEGORIES THANK YOU FOR
THOSE CA THEY'RE HELPFUL AND LET
ME ASK WITH THE KING. SHE HAS
ANY COMMENT GIVEN THE REFERENCES
TO THE L. A- THAT HAPPENED IN
THESE. DANCERS TO THESE
QUESTIONS. THANK RIGHT RECALL
EXACTLY COMMISSION HAVE.
PROVIDED SUFFICIENT INFORMATION
ON BOTH THE COST ESTIMATE IN TWO
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES
BETTER LEADING. TO THE
DIFFICULTY IN ESTIMATING A
STUDENT'S AWARD AMOUNT BUT THE
CURRENT AVAILABLE INFORMATION. I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE ASPECTS YEAH SHE'LL.
IF WE WANT CLASS SCHOLARSHIP TO
EXPAND ACCESS IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE TO STUDENTS
ABOUT HOW MUCH FINANCIAL AID IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM. AND IT'S NOT
CLEAR MESSAGING THAT LEADS TO
OUR INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE ABOUT
DETERMINING A STUDENT'S AWARD
AMOUNT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. THEY
HAVE THAT INFORMATION HERE IN
THE SPRING AS THEY'RE MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT MOMENT FOR THE.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE YEAR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ARM I'M
GONNA TO QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF SENATOR MEN
AND THEN- WHEN HE'S DONE IT
SENATOR- TROUBLED HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR WILL GO TO HER
SENATOR MAN. I THANK YOU CENTER
CAROL AIRD- AND THANK YOU TO THE
WITNESSES FOR YOUR- VERY
ELIMINATING TESTIMONY. I JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON AND CAL
GRANT REFORM. AND- YOU KNOW I
KNOW YEAH I WAS A PROFESSOR
BEFORE COMING TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND I KNOW. IN TALKING MY
STUDENTS HOW DIFFICULT IT HAS
BEEN FOR THEM TO ACCESS
FINANCIAL AID HOW COMPLICATED IS
AND I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WAS BROUGHT UP BOTH IN THE
L. A. R. O. REPORT- AS WELL AS
AS SOME OF THE OTHER MATERIALS-
WE RECEIVED AND ALSO I THINK IN
IN SEVERAL YOUR TESTIMONIES.
IT'S I GUESS MY QUESTION IS YOU
KNOW DO WE HAVE ANY SENSE OF THE
SCALE- WITH WHICH THIS
COMPLEXITY IS A PROBLEM LIKE IN
OTHER WORDS- HOW MANY STUDENTS
ARE PREVENTEDEVERYTHING FROM
ACCESS AND CAL GRANT WE HAVE
SOME SENSE OF THE SCOPE OF THIS
PROBLEM. AND DO WE HAVE. IT
IDENTIFY RECORD. MEANS TO REDUCE
THIS COMPLEXITY. THERE'S
STREAMLINING OR OTHERWISE- YOU
KNOW SO I GUESS THAT THAT WOULD
BE MY QUESTION I THINK FOR C.
SACK AND THEN AND PERHAPS FOR
ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO TAKE ON
THAT QUESTION. LET'S GO TO- I'LL
TAKE A STAB AT THAT QUESTION-
REALLY THE COMPLEXITY OF
NAVIGATING THE FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM IS REALLY ONE OF THE CORE
PRINCIPLES BEHIND CAL GRANT
REFORM AND WHAT LED US TO- DOING
THE WORK IT WAS A OF ONE YEAR
WORK GROUP THAT WE CONVENE
LOOKING AT ALL THE OBSTACLES FOR
STUDENTS. YOU ACCESS FINANCIALLY
AND IT IS DEFINITELY A BARRIER
PARTICULARLY FOR FIRST
GENERATION LOW INCOME SO
SPINELLI. AND SO THAT WAS ONE OF
THE GUYS PRINCIPLE THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE THIS A USER FRIENDLY
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WAS BUILT
IN NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE FOR VERY
DIFFERENT DEMOGRAPHIC AND OVER
THE YEARS. WE ADDED A LOT OF
LAYERS TO THE PROGRAM TO ADDRESS
VARIOUS MEANS THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO REDESIGN THE CAL
GRANT BASED ON TODAY'S STUDENTS
NEEDS SO THAT'S WHY WE TAKE
EIGHT DIFFERENT KINDS OF CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT'S WHAT WE
HAVE NOW. AND WE REALLY NARROW
IT DOWN TO TWO PROGRAMS CAL
GRANT TO FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WITH ONE SET OF
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS AND CAL
GRANT FOR FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS
AND ONE SET OF ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. RIGHT NOW IT
STUDENT APPLIES FOR FINANCIAL
AID THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHICH OF
THE EIGHT PROGRAMS ARE PLANNED
FOR ALL WITH DIFFERENT
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS. AND
WHAT ONE OF BUT WE'RE REALLY
HOPING TO ACHIEVE WITH THIS CAL
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK IS THAT
WE EMPOWER STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
NO I'M APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL
AID THIS IS WHAT I'M APPLYING
FOR HERE ARE THE REQUIREMENTS.
AND TO BE ABLE TO BE INTENTIONAL
IN THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS
WHEN THEY DECIDE TO GO TO
COLLEGE ABOUT WHAT THE COST OF
GOING TO COLLEGE ARE SO THAT'S A
HUGE PART OF OPENING ACCESS.
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE FAMILIES
THAT RULE THEM. THIS THEY'RE NOT
. OR THAT WE CANNOT CALL. AND WE
BELIEVE WILL GOAL. WAY IN THEM
ARMENIAN WITH THE IN. EARLY ON
THAT SAY. GET HAVING TO
EVENTUALLY A LOOK UP TABLE THAT
SAYS I MAKE THIS AMOUNT OF
MONEY. THEREFORE I AM ELIGIBLE
FOR THIS AMOUNT OF SPENDING AND
WE THINK THAT'LL BE POWERFUL FOR
THOSE FIRST GENERATION FAMILIES
AND THE LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS
START LIMIT LET ME REPHRASE THAT
BECAUSE MAYBE I DO IT WILL- X. A
WELCOME BACK ON TWENTY TWENTY
YOU'RE THE TYPE- I GUESS I WAS
LIKE WHAT IS THE FOR LIKE I
GUESS THESE PROPOSALS- ONE
WHAT'S THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEM
WE'RE FACING WE HAVE ANY DATA ON
LIKE YOU KNOW WHETHER IT'S
QUALITATIVE OR QUANTITATIVE- YOU
KNOW I CLEARLY THE PROBLEM AND
JUST TRY TO GET A SENSE OF LIKE.
DO WE KNOW HOW BIG THE PROBLEM
IS TO INTERVIEWS WITH STUDENTS
THROUGH SURVEYS- AND THEN
SECONDARILY- TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU PROPOSED THESE REFORMS TO
WHAT EXTENT ARE THESE FORMS BE
ARE THE OTHER. AND WHY NOT SAY
MORE INCREMENTAL OR MAYBE MORE
BOLD REFORMS- YOU KNOW THE SO
THAT WOULD BE REALLY IS THE CORE
THE QUESTION. I'LL TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE JAKE WHO HAS THE DATA.
CAN SHOW WHO WHO'S NOT GETTING
AN AWARD THAT WE BELIEVE WOULD
GET IN A WORD AFTER CAL GRANT.
REFORM. SENATOR MAN I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TO THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
REALLY WHAT DRIVES OUR WORK AT
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
AROUND PURSUING REFORM AND
STREAMLINING AND THE ELIMINATION
OF ERRORS ON THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS WHAT WE MOST RECENTLY
ASSESSED EVEN TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE HISTORIC EXPANSION
WE MADE LAST YEAR AND A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STATEMENT
AROUND PATRICK REFORM WE WERE
DOING. GREAT YOU HELP BRING.
CLEANLY ALIVE WITH THE STANDARDS
FOR THE NEW FOR PELL GRANT IT
WILL BE A PICTURE WEEK. WE COULD
SERVE AN ADDITIONAL ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL AID BECAUSE THEY
EITHER FACE BARRIERS BASED ON.
WHEN THEY GRADUATED FROM HIGH
SCHOOL THE AGE AT WHICH THEY
TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION OR A GPA IN
TRANSCRIPT REQUIREMENTS. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE CHARACTERISTICS
OF THE STUDENTS AND EVEN
FURTHER. I'M CALLS US TO ACTION
THESE ARE DISPROPORTIONATE
PROPORTIONATELY ARE BLACK AND
LATINO STUDENTS WHO ARE MOST
OFTEN CAPPED OUT OF FINANCIAL
AID BECAUSE OF THESE NON
FINANCIAL- RATIONALE MACINNES
OWNS THAT WE UTILIZE IN
FINANCIALLY CURRENTLY. AND
THEY'RE ALSO- STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT HAVE FAMILY RESOURCES TO
CALL ON TO HELP THEM PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION. SO WE HAVE
OUTLINED THE A STRIP. TO PULL.
OF A DRESSING NOT ONLY. YOURS
CHOOSE TO MILLEDGEVILLE
PREDICTABLE ACCESS TO CAL GRANT
BUT ALSO ADDRESSING- HAS. MADE
THIS CHANGES. WHICH MAKES SENSE
. AND WE IN THE OF HEALTH DO A
VERY AFFECT JOB COVERAGE WE
SHOULD. WE KNOW AND WE HEAR FROM
STUDENTS I'VE EVER DAY OF THE
CHANNEL POSED. INTERFACE ME FOOD
AND HOUSING. WE ALSO SEE DATA
THROUGH MARCH PROCESS THAT YOU
NEED COMMISSION THEY REALLY
INDICATES HOW WIDELY FELT THIS
PROBLEM IS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WHEN WE SURVEYED
STUDENTS EVEN BEFORE THE ONSET
COVE IN NINETEEN ONE OUT OF
THREE STUDENTS WOULD INDICATE
THAT THEY WERE FOOD INSECURE
ANOTHER ONE OUT OF THREE
STUDENTS INDICATE THAT ARE
HOUSING INSECURE. AND EVERYTHING
THAT WE'VE GATHERED IN THE TIME
SINCE THEN. IT HAS CONTINUE TO
SERVE TO. ABOUT HOW THEY DEALING
WITH THE CAN DOWN. INCREASED
COSTS THAT THERE WERE TO US.
WEEK THE STUDENTS ARE SAYING
THEIR FOOD HOUSING EXPENSES ARE
ONLY GONNA. DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND WHEN YOU LOOK TO BREAK THAT
DOWN BAY. INCOME THEIR RACE
ETHNICITY. ALWAYS COMES TO WHO
ARE THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
THAT THERE OF THE UP AND IT'S
OUR AND LATINOS WERE. SAYING
THAT THEIR COSTS HAVE GONE UP SO
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE
MORE PREDICTABLE ACCESS TO STATE
FINANCIAL AID. BUT THE STATE ON
COURSE TO REAL. WISHING ALL OUR
STUDENTS. ARE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND ELSE WHICH TO COME. ALL RIGHT I HAD A SECOND
QUESTION- SO. THIS I THINK IT'S
TO DIRECTORS IS COMMON. IN
TESTING- YOU KNOW FOURTEEN SAID
I WAS PROUD BE COOPER THAT- AND
I DIDN'T THAT THE GO. DID IN HIS
HEAT MESSAGE TALK THE NEED TO
CONSIDER THIS IS PART THE BUDGET
BY HE ALSO X. THAT- ANOTHER KEY
READ. ONE FIFTY SIX WERE HIS
BELIEF I PRESUME IN FOR BY
ANALYSIS THE X. BRANCH THAT-
THIS WOULD RESULT IN UNTENABLE
COST PRESSURES TO THE STATE- DO
YOU STILL THINK THAT THIS IS
TRUE- AND IF NOT SORT OF WHAT'S
CHANGE THAT THAT MIGHT- YOU
KNOW. ESSENTIALLY WITH THEIR
FARMS HERE LOOK VERY SIMILAR TO
THE ONES PROPOSING FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX INSIDERS WONDERING SIR
WHAT WHAT WHAT THE REASON FOR
THE CHANGES OTHER THAN THE
BUDGET PROCESS BECAUSE- OUT YOU
KNOW IF YOU BELIEVE YOUR
SIGNIFICANT CAUGHT. LAST YEAR I
AM NOT SURE YOU MEAN. I THINK
THERE ARE TWO ISSUES. THAT THAT
WE NEED TO ADDRESS ONE IS- THIS
YOU NEED COMMISSION AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE A DIFFERENT SET OF DATA
THAT WE WERE WORKING WITH IN
TERMS OF WHAT I BELIEVE THE COST
PRESSURE WORK WE HAVE- TO COME
AND HAVE BEEN IN ABOUT COST
PRESSURE AND WHAT WE'RE DOING.
OTHER THE LAST. REALLY A LINE ON
THE COSTS PRESSURES TO START
WITH A THE SAME- BASED WEIGHT
COSTS AND- AND SO WE'VE DONE
THAT AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE TO PASS
CATCHERS THAT- JAKE EARLIER BUT
IT IS. SOMETHING THAT WERE IN
LINE WITH THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
. THIS IS ISSUE IS THAT IT'S OUR
BELIEF THAT. THEY AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX THE BIGGEST COST
PRESSURE OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX REALLY WAS CAL GRANT IN
TITLE MEANT FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. SO WHEN THAT
WILL BE DRESSED IN THE BUDGET
YEAH REALLY JUST LEFT THE
REMAINING COMPACT AND PULL FOR
THE FOR INSTITUTIONS EIGHTEEN.
AND STREET WHO IS A TEN COLLEGE
BEYOND WHEN YOU'RE OUT OF HIGH
SCHOOL IF THEY'RE GOING TO YOU
THE CSU. CALLER HE TO THAT
COMPARE PULL SOME TO THE CALL
COMPETITORS PULL ALBEIT AS LONG
AS IT WOULD READ THOSE BARRIERS
BRING THEM INTO THE ENTITLEMENT
MIX AS WELL SO THAT ALL STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA IF YOU DECIDE TO
START COLLEGE AT TWENTY TWO MORE
THAN A YEAR OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TO COMPETE FOR
A VERY LIMITED PULL CAL GRANT
SHE WOULD GET A CAL GRANT. SO
THOSE COSTS. IN THE WAY. TO YOUR
MANAGE THESE COSTS AND- BUT AT
THE SAME TIME PROVIDE THE
PREDICTABILITY AND THE ASSURANCE
TO FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS IN
PARTICULAR BUT LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. IN ALL OVER ALL THAT
THEY CAN AFFORD TO GO TO COLLEGE
AND THIS IS WHAT IT COSTS. BUT
BUT WE ARE IN NEGOTIATIONS WE
ARE TRYING TO TALK THROUGH THOSE
COST PRESSURES. MICHELLE BY.
UNITA CHAVEZ YEAH EXCUSE ME
EXCUSE ME EXCUSE ME WE HAVE A
HAND FROM SOMEBODY IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO LET ME
GO TO REBEKAH KIRK. I THINK
SHE'S GOING TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION GOT SERVICE THANK.
SHARE REBEKAH KIRK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I AM JUST
WANTING CHECK TO CLARIFY WE ARE
HAVING DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION ABOUT THE
MOST RECENT PROPOSAL HOWEVER
WE'VE NOT YET SEEN. ANY DETAIL
OR SPECIFIC LANGUAGE FOR THIS
YEAR'S VERSION OF THE PROPOSAL
THAT WE HAVE NOT YET HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THE
DETAILS OR TO CONDUCT OUR OWN
FISCAL ANALYSIS AND WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED AT THIS. I WOULD JUST.
SPEAKING HAS THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM IS AN ENTITLEMENT AND
EXPANSION OF ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAMS BEYOND WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN AS A SIGNIFICANT
EXPANSION IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT AT THE EXPANSION
IN TITLE MEANT CAN BE
CONSIDERABLY COSTLY. THERE'S
ALSO A FAIR AMOUNT OF
UNCERTAINTY INVOLVED BECAUSE IT
IS AN ENTITLEMENT EVEN IF THERE
IS A PROJECTED COST AT A CERTAIN
LEVEL THAT CAN FLUCTUATE
SIGNIFICANTLY AS CASELOAD
INCREASES OR DECREASES OVER TIME
SO FROM FROM THE FINANCE
PERSPECTIVE YOU KNOW THE
EXPANDING ENTITLEMENTS AS ALWAYS
A SOMEWHAT RISKY AND A CONCERN
FOR US BECAUSE IT LIMITS
BUDGETARY FLEXIBILITY AS WELL AS
PRESENTS SOME FINANCIAL
LIABILITY INTO IF YOU PLAN ON
GOING. I THAT SENTIMENT A QUICK
FOLLOW UP I DO WE HAVE A SENSE
OF LIKE WHAT THE ONGOING.
LIABILITIES ARE LIKELY TO BE. ON
A YEAR BY YEAR BASIS. I'M I'M
NOT SURE IF THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT CAN MAKE THAT STUDENT
COMMISSION IS PREPARED TO
ADDRESS FROM A FINANCE
PERSPECTIVE WE CAN NOT BECAUSE
WE'VE NOT YET SEEN A SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL ON HOW TO OPPORTUNITY-
REVIEW. OUR ESTIMATE COSTS. I
WOULD TURN TO MY COLLEAGUE JAKE
. WHO HAS HIS HAND UP. YES THANK
YOU SENATOR AND I'LL JUST OFFER
AN INITIAL PROJECTION WE ARE AS
I NOTED EARLIER STILL WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IN LA AND TO REFINE A MORE
PRECISE COST ESTIMATE TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT OUR CURRENT STUDENT
ENROLLMENT PATTERNS
PARTICIPATION IN THE CURRENT CAL
GRANT TO ESTABLISH A BASELINE AS
WELL AS WOULD BE OUT YOUR COST
PRESSURES WOULD LOOK LIKE.
PROGRAM. BUT I CAN SHARE LIKELY
BE. IN THE RANGE UP HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION ONGOING FOR MORE
IN ORDER TO ESTABLISH A CALTRAIN
TO ACCELERATE FOR THE CLEANLY
ALIGNED WITH THE ELIGIBILITY
STANDARDS FOR THE FEDERAL PELL
GRANT PROGRAM. OF COURSE AS THIS
PROCESS MOVES FORWARD. ENGAGE
THE LEGISLATURE AND HER
COLLEAGUES AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THERE ARE OPTIONS FOR HE
COULD REFINE THE POLICY
FRAMEWORK. IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
SAVINGS ABOUT THE DESIRE OF OUR
POLICY MAKERS BUT WE DO GET THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION BELIEVE
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT BARRIERS
TO REMOVE. AND THAT ALIGNING
THESE TWO PROGRAMS WITH THE
FEDERAL PELL GRANT WILL ALLOW US
AS A STATE TO SEND A CRYSTAL
CLEAR MESSAGE TO OUR STUDENTS
AND THEIR FAMILIES ALL OF THE
FINANCIAL AID THAT THEY WOULD.
WORK GOT IT I APPRECIATE THE
THAT'S A HELPFUL NOW BEFORE
CLOSE TO SEE WHAT THAT IS-
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO BE FISCALLY
PRUDENT THAT THAT BEING SAID I
WAS ONE OF THE REASONS I
SUPPORTED AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
TO BEGIN WITH THIS- MY- STRONG
BELIEF THAT. THESE TYPES OF
INVESTMENTS PAY OFF. YOU KNOW
INCREDIBLE RETURNS OVER THE LONG
RUN. AND I THINK ONE OF THE
REASONS IN MY VIEW- THE
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN SO RESILIENT
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC. AND THIS
RECESSION THAT HAS HIT A LOT OF
STATES REALLY HARD. EYES BECAUSE
OF OUR STRONG WORK FORCE AND THE
ROLE OF OUR- HIRED SYSTEM IN
PREPARING OUR WORKFORCE. AS A
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU SENATOR
MENSEN ROADSHOW BOAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR LETTERED AND- THANK YOU
FOR THE LINE OF QUESTIONING THAT
BOTH OF YOU HAVE- GIVEN THIS-
THIS MORNING AND I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THE- FOR WITNESSES THIS
MORNING AND COMING BACK I'M VERY
EXCITED TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU
THIS YEAR ONCE AGAIN- LET ME
JUST BEGIN BY- SITTING HERE AND
JUST REALLY REALLY. READING HERE
JUST FOR THE RECORD AND I THINK
IT'S SUPPORT FOR THE PUBLIC TO
NOTE. AND WHERE WE ARE AT THAT
TIME STUDENT DEBT IN CALIFORNIA
IS A TWENTY TWENTY. SAYS THAT
THE STUDENTS THAT ATTEND
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HAVE SOME OF THE
LOWEST DEBT IN THE NATION UPON
GRADUATION. AND IT GOES ON TO
SAY THAT IN NINETEEN NINETY. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND 2046% OF
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE GRADUATES
HAVE A STUDENT LOAN DEBT. AND
THE AVERAGE LOAN DEBT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE GRADUATE. IN
NINETEEN TWENTY TO TWENTY
NINETEEN I'M SORRY TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY. WAS
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE. PLACING THE
STATE THIRD LOWEST IN THE NATION
ON THIS MEASURE- I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT- THAT'S SOMETHING TO BE
PROUD OF I MEAN IT I KNOW THAT
WE STILL HAVE SOME CHALLENGES.
WE'LL FOR. MAKING COLLEGE- MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS BUT THIS IS ACTUALLY
REALLY GOOD PROGRESS I THINK IN
A VERY POSITIVE PERSPECTIVE IN
MY OPINION. ON THAT AND I THINK
IT- WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE AND
ACTUALLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IN
COMMENDED. THE EFFORTS THAT HAVE
BEEN TESTED- MADE AN EFFORT TO
CREATE COLLEGE MORE AFFORDABLE
IN THIS CALIFORNIA. SO ON THAT-
I HAD A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AND
THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE- MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP- WHAT ARE THE
OVERALL DIFFERENCES IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION ACTIVITIES
BETWEEN THE PREVIOUS AND THE NEW
VERSIONS OF. OF THIS GRANT AND
THEN FROM THERE. AB I'M GOING TO
WANT O KNOW. IF- THE C. S. A.
C. I BELIEVE THAT ANY STATURE
TERRY STATUTORY CHANGES ARE
NEEDED TO IMPROVE THE PROGRAM IN
EMPLOYMENT IN THE CHANGES. I
THINK WE'LL GO TO WHO ARE WITH
GOING TO ASK WHICH ONE AND THAT
ANSWERS THIS QUESTION MR BREMNER
HAS HIS HAND UP SO LET'S GO TO
HIM. SURE AND SENATOR THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE
STRUCTURE OF THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM IN A COUPLE
OF KEY- REGARDS. THE FIRST IS
THAT THE- CURRENT MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM THAT WE'RE
PAYING OUT THIS YEAR. IS STILL
ONE THAT'S BASED ON COVERING UP
PERCENTAGE OF TUITION. FOR
STUDENTS THAT DO NOT RECEIVE A
CAL GRANT. SO THAT'S A SMALLER
UNIVERSE OF TOTAL STUDENTS THAT
WE SERVE. AND IT'S- I NEVER
WANED RANGE AND THE TYPES OF
AWARDS THAT WE PROVIDE TO
STUDENTS. AGAIN JUST BASED ON
THAT PERCENTAGE OF TUITION
COVERAGE FOR NON CALTRAIN
RECIPIENTS. AND THE NEW
STRUCTURE BEEN. HELLO THE
GOVERNOR'S. WE WOULDN'T BE
SERVED ALL AND FAMILIES HELLO
CERTAIN INCOME BUT A RECEIPT
CALTRAIN OR NOT. AND THE TARGET
OF THE AWARD WOULD BE. UNMET
NEED FOR A STUDENT TO COVER
THEIR TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE
AFTER FACTORING IN THE OTHER
FORMS OF FINANCIAL AID FOR WHICH
THEY QUALIFY. A STUDENT
CONTRIBUTION THAT'S CONSISTENT
ACROSS ALL STUDENTS IN THE
PROGRAM. AS WELL AS FOR FAMILIES
WITH INCOMES OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN ADDITIONAL
PARENTAL CONTRIBUTION. WHAT THIS
MEANS IS THAT THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL METRICS WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO INCORPORATE AND HOW WE
DO THIS AT THIS DO NEED
COMMISSION AND IDENTIFY THE
AWARD AMOUNTS FOR EACH OF OUR
POTENTIAL RECIPIENTS. AS I NOTED
EARLIER WE NEED TO KNOW THE
TOTAL COST OF THE PROGRAM AND
WHAT THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE IS FOR ALL OF THE
STUDENTS WOULD BE RECIPIENTS. WE
CAN ALSO NEED TO KNOW WHAT'S THE
ANNUAL APPROPRIATION TOWARDS
THIS PROGRAM. FOR WHICH WE CAN
PRO RATE THE WAR- CAN. ACROSS
ALL RECEIVE OF THE CURRENT
STRUCK. AND WE ALSO NEED TO KNOW
ALL OF THE OTHER FORMS OF
FINANCIAL AID FOR WHICH THE
RECEDING SO WE CAN IDENTIFY
UNMET NEED GAP FOR EACH OF THE
STUDENTS IN THE PROGRAM. SO THAT. CERTAINLY HAS X. THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WE WOULD SEE BECAUSE
FROM ABOUT. FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
AND THIS KERR PROGRAM. THAT
WOULD IN JUST THREE SIXTY
THOUSAND AND THE NEXT ITERATION
OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WE WILL BE
IMPLEMENTING IN THE NEXT
ACADEMIC YEAR. IT ALSO. MEANS A
MORE COMPLICATED WORK
INDIVIDUALIZED SET OF AWARDS FOR
EACH STUDENT PARTICIPATION. SO
THAT'S CHANGE THE-
CONSIDERATIONS WE CAN MAKE
AROUND HOW UNDER ITS CURRENT
STRUCTURE WILL BE ABLE TO INFORM
STUDENTS ABOUT THE SPECIFIC
AWARD AMOUNT THAT THEY CAN
ANTICIPATE RECEIVING. BECAUSE
IT'S NOT REALLY MUCH MORE
INDIVIDUALIZED FOR EACH STUDENT
IS RECEIVING AN AWARD BASED ON
THEIR COST OF ATTENDANCE AND
THEIR OTHER FORMS OF AID FOR
WHICH THEY RECEIVED. SO I THINK
THAT COULD HAVE DIRECTOR GARCIA
NOTED WE DO THINK THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS
THAT COULD BE MADE TO THE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
HELP US STILL MOVE FORWARD IN
MPLEMENTING WHICH IN THIS
CURRENT APPROPRIATION. MIGHT
ALLOW US TO PROVIDE. A CLEAR
PICTURE TO STUDENTS EARLIER
ABOUT THE- PROTECTION YOU SEE.
PREACHING FROM THE LAST ALL ARE
STRUCK. YOUR FIRST DOLLARS. AND
IDENTIFY FOR THE- AND- STATUSES
OF STUDENTS HOW MUCH OF AN AWARD
YOU WANT TO SEND TO EACH OF
THOSE STUDENTS. RATHER THAN
GOING THROUGH THIS PROCESS-
FIGURING OUT ALL OF THEIR OTHER
FORMS OF AGE FIRST. AND THEN
WHAT THE YOUNG MAN NEED GAP IS
AND WE THINK THAT YOU COULD
STILL DO THAT THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS IN SUCH A WAY THAT STAYS
WITHIN. THE APPROPRIATIONS
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED AND- HAS
BEEN NEGOTIATED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. GO SO JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY IN ORDER TO DO WHAT YOU
JUST STATED DO WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT IN STATUTE. OR DO OR DO WE
OR CAN IT JUST BE ACCOMPLISHED
TO THE BUDGETARY. JUST FOR THE
RECORD YOU KEEP NODDING YOUR
HEAD YOU SHOULD OUT LOUD SAY YES
IF THAT'S WHAT. I WAS ABOUT TO
COME UP WITH YOU TO ENTER AND
THAT IS CORRECT. NEW JERSEY
THROUGH THE BUDGET ACT PROCESS.
THANKS YOU MAKE THAT DECISION TO
THE- OKAY SO IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
BE ACCOMPLISHED THROUGH A
STATUTORY CHANGES. YOU WERE
NODDING YOUR HEAD AGAIN WAS AT
IT YES YES YES. STATE BUDGET
PROCESS OKAY THANK OKAY- AND
THEN ONE LAST QUESTION AND THIS
HAS TO DO WITH- AND I'M NOT SURE
IF I JUST MISSED IT IN THE EARLY
pTHAT OUR STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING
YOUR LETTERS OF ACCEPTANCE. AB
RIGHT THROUGH NOW FEBRUARY JERRY
VERY MARCH I KNOW I KNOW THAT
MUCH OF THE DETERMINING FACTOR
FOR ATTENDING A CERTAIN SCHOOLS
IS THE FINAL. AWARDS SO WITH
THAT IN MIND HOW SOON. TAKING IN
CONSIDERATION WHEN THE STUDENTS
HAVE TO MAKE A FINAL-
DETERMINATION OF WHAT SCHOOLS
THAT THEY WILL ATTEND AND
KNOWING HOW MUCH- FINANCIALLY
THEY'LL BE RECEIVING. WHEN CAN
THE STUDENTS- AND OF THEIR WARDS
OUR HOW SOON CAN THEY LEARN OF
THEIR WARDS MOVING FORWARD. YEAH
AND WE KNOW THAT IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT QUESTION SENATOR
AROUND HOW THIS CAN HELP INFORM
STUDENTS ABOUT. WHAT AID IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM SO THAT THAT
CAN SUPPORT DECISIONS THEY MAKE
ABOUT ENROLLMENT AND WHICH
UNIVERSITY THEY WISH TO ATTEND.
AS I NOTED THERE IS ADDITIONAL
DATA THAT WE NEED AT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION TO DETERMINE FOR
EACH INDIVIDUAL STUDENT WHETHER
OR IN WHAT LOOKED LIKE THAT'S
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE CALTRANS WHAT OTHER
FORMS OF FINANCIAL AID THEY
MIGHT BE RECEIVING FROM THE
CAMPUS. AND THEN WHAT IS THE-
HOW. THIS PROGRAM- IN THE STATE
BUDGET PROCESS RIGHT NOW THERE
IS A PROPOSED APPROPRIATION OF A
TOTAL OF SIX HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
MILLION FOR WHICH WE KNOW
THERE'S- A BROAD LEGISLATIVE
SUPPORT- THAT MEANS THAT IT'S
NOT A FINAL APPROPRIATION AND WE
DON'T HAVE THAT ADDITIONAL DATA
FROM OUR CAMPUSES. AROUND WHAT
THE AID PACKAGE LOOKS LIKE. SO
WE COULD IDENTIFY- INITIAL
PROJECTED THE WORDS BUT THOSE
WOULD BE SUBJECT TO CHANGE.
BASED ON THE FUNDING AMOUNTS
RECEIVED AND CHANGES TO OUR
STUDENTS FINANCES OVER THE
COURSE OF AN ACADEMIC YEAR. AND
TO THE CHANGES IN THEIR
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE OVER THE
COURSE OF AN ACADEMIC YEAR. I'M
BECAUSE OF HIS LAST DOLLAR
NATURE OF THE PROGRAM AWARDS CAN
CHANGE FOR STUDENTS. EVEN IN THE
COURSE OF THE ACADEMIC YEAR THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY STARTED. WE HAD
A SIMILAR PROGRAM THOUGH IN A
MUCH- MORE REDUCED CO WHEN WE
WERE FIRST IMPLEMENTING THE
CURRENT MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM THAT FOCUSES JUST ON
JEWISH. IN THOSE EARLY YEARS.
YOU MAKE. DATE WITH. PLACENTA A
NOTIFICATION TO STUDENTS LETTING
THEM KNOW THAT THEY MAY QUALIFY
FOR MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP-
BECAUSE AT THAT TIME BETWEEN
MARCH AFTER THEY APPLIED FOR
STATE FINANCIAL AID. AND THE
STATEMENT OF INTENT TO REGISTER
DEADLINE AT UNIVERSITIES THAT'S
TYPICALLY IN MAY- FINANCIAL AID
OFFICES AND SEE SEPARATE ABLE TO
HELP EACH STUDENT THE PRECISE
AWARD AMOUNT THEY WOULD RECEIVE.
I WANTED TO LET THEM KNOW THERE
MAY BE JUST ON THE FLOOR. THAT'S
SOMETHING WE CAN TAKE BACK FOR
CAMPUS PARTNERS AND WORK THROUGH
ITS YOUTH THAT'S APPROPRIATE. IN
THIS SITUATION- BUT GIVEN THE
STRUCTURE OF THIS PROGRAM AND
MAKES IT. DIFFICULT BETWEEN
MARCH AND MAY HELP EACH STUDENT
PRECISELY WHAT WHAT ABOUT THE
RECEIPT AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
PROPOSING. THESE TARGETED
REFINEMENTS TO THE PROGRAM
STRUCTURE THAT MIGHT HELP US BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE A CLEAR PICTURE
STUDENTS EARLIER IN THE PROCESS.
ABOUT THE. AGE THAT THEY CAN
ANTICIPATE RECEIPT. THANK YOU.
DOES THAT COMPLETE YOUR WITH LET
ME JUST MAKE A OF A ONE LITTLE
COMMENT HERE MENTIONED HAVE YOU
WERE JUST THIS AND I REALLY.
THAT THAT'S GAVEL DOWN THE TENTH
HEARING FOUR AND A HALF WEEKS
FROM NOW YOU'RE STILL THAT
EXCITE- HE THEN IS MUCH AS I
WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO CONTINUE
TALKING ABOUT THIS BECAUSE THIS
IS VERY IMPORTANT WE STILL HAVE
FOUR. ITEMS ON THE AGENDA AND
LET ME JUST MAKE A SUMMARY
COMMENT WHICH IS THAT I THINK
THE STAFF'S. ARE CHARGED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE BUDGET IN THE
THREE YEAR EXENDITURES MENTIONS
PART OF THE CASE VERY WELL WHICH
IS SAID. WE REALLY MADE
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES LAST YEAR TO
ADD ACCESS. IN THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING GOING SOMEWHAT MORE IT
IN THE PROPOSED BUDGET IN THE
NEXT YEAR. AND YET WE ALSO WANT
IN MAY TO HAVE REALLY DETAILED
OUR DATA. ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR SO WE
CAN JUDGE IT IN OUR FINAL
DECISIONS. AND I THINK SPEAKING
FOR MYSELF I REALLY APPRECIATE
WHAT CENTRO CULTURAL BOGUE
POINTED OUT ABOUT THE- WHO DEBT
BEING LOWER IN CALIFORNIA
COMPARED TO SOME OTHER STATES
BUT WE STILL HAVE WORK TO DO.
AND APPRECIATE WHERE THE
GOVERNOR'S VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
ENTITLEMENTS AT THE SAME TIME.
IF I HAVE A BROTHER WHO HAD
THREE KIDS THAT WENT TO COLLEGE
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS AND IT AND
HE WAS JUST HANGING BY HIS
FINGERNAILS FINANCIALLY ALL THE
WAY THROUGH. AND I THINK THAT
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE THAT
ACCESS TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GET AS CLOSE TO A DEBT FREE
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE AS WE CAN.
AND THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK NOT
JUST AT THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
VERY IMPORTANTLY LOOK AT THE
SIMPLIFICATION IN A WAY THAT IT
DOESN'T SCREEN PEOPLE OUT OF THE
PROCESS. AT THE SAME TIME WE
HAVE TO LOOK GOING FORWARD AT
THE GAPS AND DO OUR BEST TO MEET
THEM WHETHER IT'S THROUGH
LEGISLATION. TO THAT WE THE
BUDGET. AND I THINK DISC HAS
BEEN VERY VERY HELPFUL TO THOSE
DIFFERENT ISSUES AND WE WANT TO
LOOK AT THE DATA AS IT CONTINUES
TO COME IN. AND THEN I'LL WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
ASSEMBLY TO TRY TO MEET THOSE
GOALS IN WATER WE CRAFTED MAY
AND JUNE AND- AND I REALLY FEEL
LIKE WE COULD TALK ABOUT THIS
FOREVER. BECAUSE IT IS IMPORTANT
AS IMPORTANT AS IT IS MANY OF
THE THINGS THAT WE DO IN THIS
COMMITTEE IT WILL MAKE A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES. AND THE ABILITY
TO ENTER THE ECONOMY IN A GOOD
WAY. AND IF WE COULD EVER GET ON
WITH THE DRESSING THE HOUSING
ISSUE. THAT PEOPLE WOULDN'T BE
SO INDEBTED FROM COLLEGE THAT
THEY WERE EVEN FURTHER AWAY FROM
GETTING INTO THE HOUSING MARKET
SO ALL THOSE ARE ISSUES THAT WE
WANT TO LOOK AT I THINK AND
CONSIDER GOING FORWARD AND- I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES. ON
THIS. OVER THE ISSUE TO. WHICH
IS WHY CORD WERE. LOAD RESOURCE
. AND INFRASTRUCTURES. AND WE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AFTER THIS THIS IS
VERY DISCREET I HOPE IT DOESN'T
TAKE VERY LONG AND SO WE HAVE
AGAIN GABRIELA CHAVEZ JAKE
BREMNER AND LIESEGANG S. R.
THREE PERCENTERS AND WE'LL START
WITH GABRIELA CHAVEZ FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE BODY
CARE AND SENATORS THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND ONGOING
GENERAL FUND IT FIVE POSITIONS
TO SUPPORT THE NEW PROGRAMS
ESTABLISHED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. AND TO ADDRESS
THE STAFFING NEEDS. BUDGET ALSO
IN. ANY OF FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO EXPAND
THIS SUPPLEMENT EXISTING CASPER
COLLEGE REGIONAL COORDINATOR FOR
ORGANIZATIONS. THANK AND I'LL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SURE WILL
MOVE TO CHECK BERMAN- FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND I DON'T START BY EXPRESSING
THE COMMISSION'S GRATITUDE TO
THE GOVERNOR AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOR THE PROPOSED
STAFFING AUTHORITY AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THOSE
POSITIONS AS WELL AS THE ONE
TIME ALLOCATION FOR THE CASH FOR
COLLEGE PROGRAM. OF THE FIVE
POSITION. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED IN THIS BUDGET ONE WAS
FUNDED IN LAST YEAR'S STATE
BUDGET TO SUPPORT THE STUDENT
AID COMMISSION PARTICIPATION AND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE NEW CRADLE
TO CAREER LONGITUDINAL DATA
PLATFORM THAT IS IN DEVELOPMENT.
OF THE OTHER FOUR POSITIONS TO
WORK PROGRAM TECHNICIANS THAT
WOULD HELP SUPPORT INCREASED
VOLUME AT THIS TO MAKE
COMMISSIONS CALL CENTER AS MORE
STUDENTS ARE BEING OFFERED EIGHT
AND MORE STUDENTS WILL APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL AID THIS FALL AS WE
START TO IMPLEMENT THAT NEW
REQUIREMENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND GOVERNOR. ENACTED IN THE
BUDGET LAST YEAR THAT ALL HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS WILL APPLY FOR.
AID OR SIGN OFF TO WAIT FOR.
ANOTHER POSITION IS AN ATTORNEY-
TO HELP WITH INCREASED WORKLOAD
ACROSS THE AGENCY AROUND NEW
PROGRAMS THAT WILL TALK ABOUT AT
THE FEBRUARY TWENTY THIRD
HEARING AS WELL AS NEW
CONTRACTING ISSUES THAT ARISE
WHEN OUR BUDGET GOES UP. BY ONE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE COURSE OF TWO YEARS. AND THE
FINAL POSITION IS ONE POSITION
THAT COULD HELP SUPPORTERS DO
NEED COMMISSION'S EFFORTS AROUND
THE FINANCIAL AID COMPLETION
REQUIREMENT THAT I JUST
MENTIONED. SO WHAT WE BELIEVE
THAT THESE ARE ALL VERY
IMPORTANT POSITIONS AND WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT MR NEED
COMMISSION DID REQUEST
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS AND
RESOURCES BEYOND WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED. THE SECOND
REQUESTED A TOTAL OF TWENTY
SEVEN NEW POSITIONS INCLUDING
THE FIVE LISTED HERE I'M AT A
COST OF ABOUT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL ON GOING
FUNDING. THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN ORDER TO HELP US.
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN HIGH
QUALITY OF SERVICE THAT WE
PROVIDE TO OUR STUDENTS AND
CAMPUS PARTNERS NOT ONLY IS WE
GENERATE MORE STUDENT
APPLICATIONS WITH THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS STARTING THIS FALL.
BUT AS WE START TO AWARD MORE
STUDENTS. TODAY PLUS ALL SHIP
PROGRAM. I KNOW COMPLETION WERE
THAT THE I. T. AGENCIES WILL THE
FALL IS ONE THAT CAN HOLD A SIX
NEW WORKLOAD FOR THIS TEAM AID
COMING NOT ONLY IN THE RECALL
FOR A FROM AND FAMILIES I THEY
APPLY FOR FINANCE AID BUT ALSO
FOR OUR CASE PARTNERS. WHO ARE
I'M GOING TO BE C. TRIP AND
OUTREACH RESOURCE YOU NEED
COMMISSION. ALL OF THIS COMES
WITH INCREASE AND SIX. NEEDS FOR
OUR STAFF I'M- THE ORGANIZATION
FOR OUR PROGRAMS COLLEAGUES
ADMINISTRATIVE- DIVISION AND I.
T. AND FINANCIAL STAFF THAT ARE
OVERSEEN CONTRACTING PROGRAM
BUDGETS STUDENT APPLICATION
PORTALS. AND OTHER-
ADMINISTRATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE NOTED THERE'S
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE FUNDS BUT
THIS AID COMMISSION IS MANAGING
RELATIVE TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY. BUDGET ACT- BEFORE EVEN
CONSIDERING THE NEW PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WE ALREADY SAW AN
INCREASE OF OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE STUDENT
COMMISSION. THAT DID NOT COME
WITH ANY ADDITIONAL STAFF OR
STATE ADMINISTRATIVE- FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY TO SUPPORT ONGOING
STAFFING NEEDS AS A RESULT OF
THAT. SO AND IN THE FOR THE SAKE
OF BREVITY ALL POTS MY COMMENTS
HERE BUT I'M CERTAINLY ALSO
HAPPY TO SPEECH AT A ONE TIME
PROPOSED INVESTMENT AROUND THE
CASH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT I
HAVE TO SAY MISS COMMITTEE WE
CON. REDUCE THE DEFINITION OF
GRAVITY SO I WILL MOVE ON TO
LIESEGANG FROM THE ALEJO'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU. GIVEN THE
RECENT EXPANSIONS WE'VE JUST
DISCUSSED THIS YOU NEED
QUESTIONS FINANCIALLY PROGRAMS
AND COMPLEXITY OF SOME OF THE
NEW AND EXPANDED PROGRAMS CREDIT
LAST YEAR WE DO THINK STALKING
CASES OF THE COMMISSIONER
WARRANTED AND WE RECOMMEND
APPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED IVE POSITIONS. HI MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE COMMISSION
HAVE NOTED THEY DID REQUEST
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE POSITIONS AND
IN THE COURSE THIS SPRING THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO WORK
WITH THEM AS ELL AS A THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER ANY OF THESE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS ARE
WARRANTED IN ORDER TO. ENSURE
THE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION OF
THESE. PROGRAMS WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT. AFTER THE
GOVERNOR BECAUSE FOR COLOR UP
AND HE THIS IS. TO THE REQUIRE.
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS CONFIRM
HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS ARE
COMPLETING FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS. WE NEED THIS NEW
REQUIREMENT LATEX ATTRACTED
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE IS
LIKELY TO INCREASE DEMAND FOR
CASH FOR COLLEGE WORKSHOP. WE
RECOMMEND APPROVING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ONE TIME
BOND. YEAH THE REQUIREMENT FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IS ONGOING IN
THE INTERIM SOLUTION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE MAY ALSO WISH TO
CONSIDER THE ONGOING FUNDING
LEVEL FOR CASH FOR COLLEGE. IN
TONIGHT AND LEAVE RECOMMENDED IN
YOUR CHEN DONG TOP OF PAGE
TWENTY ONE SOME REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT MAY WISH TO
ADD. TO THIS YEAR'S ONE TIME
FUNDS IN ORDER TO COLLECT THE
INFORMATION IT WOULD NEED TO
BETTER ASSESS THE ONGOING
FUNDING LEVEL FOR CASH FOR
COLLEGE LOOKING FORWARD.
THINKING PARTICULAR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU N. AND LET ME JUST
MAKE A COMMENT AND THEN SEE IF
THERE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE COMMENT IS
THAT. ARE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDATION
APPRECIATE THE L. A. O.
STATEMENT ABOUT THE COLLECTION
OF INFORMATION GOING FORWARD.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE WILL HAVE
MORE DATA. ON THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE ACCESSING THE
CHANGES IN THE PROGRAM AND MAY.
AND I HOPE THAT EVERYBODY WILL
WORK TOGETHER TO DECIDE IF THIS
IS AN ADEQUATE STAFFING LEVEL
BASED UPON THE DATA WHEN IT
COMES IN. AND THAT THERE'S THE
POTENTIAL GIVEN SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ALREADY
EXIST BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE
EVEN WISE AND- THAT THERE MIGHT
BE SOME ADDITIONS NEXT YEAR. AND
IF THERE ARE. DEAR OUR- HOPE
THIS WOULD FACTOR IN DISK. THAT
WOULD BEFORE THE MAYOR MAY
REVISE ON THE STAFFING LEVELS SO
I JUST THINK. WE WOULD LIKE TO
REVISIT THE STAFFING ISSUE AT
THE TIME THAT. THAT MORE DATA IS
IN AND WE HAVE A CLEAR PICTURE
ABOUT WHAT WE MIGHT BE DOING
NEXT YEAR SO. I APPRECIATE THAT
THIS IS HERE. BEFORE WE MOVE ON
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. I SEE NON FROM EACH
OF THEM SO LET ME THANK YOU. ON
THIS ISSUE FOR THAT DISCUSSION
AND NOT MY COMMENTS AND WE WILL.
HAVE CONVERSATIONS AND MADE WILL
SEE WHAT THE GOVERNOR DOES BASED
ON. ON SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
ARE AFFECTED SO MANY THANK
EVERYBODY THAT. PARTICIPATED IN
THE DISCUSSIONS. FOR THE STUDENT
AID. THE FIRST TWO ITEMS WERE
GONNA TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT WHEN
WE'RE DONE WITH THE- NEXT THREE
ITEMS RELATED TO CSU TO THE
COMMENTS TOGETHER. SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO- THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM CSU THE
FIRST ISSUE IS BASED BUDGET
INCREASE RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND GENERAL
UPDATES WE HAVE FOUR PANELISTS.
BRIAN STORM FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY DR NATHAN EVANS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY JENNIFER LOUIS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
LEASE IT CAME FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE OPENING
COMMENTS IN THAT ORDER. AND
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH RAIMES
STORM OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY- WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU CHAIR. I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE A FEW WORDS ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY BEFORE DELVING INTO
EACH OF THE ISSUES ON THE REST
OF YOUR AGENDA TODAY. MY NAME IS
RYAN STORM I AM THE ASSISTANT
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR BUDGET FOR
THE OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR.-WITH ME TODAY ARE NATION EVANS
HE IS THE ASSOCIATE VICE
CHANCELLOR AND CHIEF OF STAFF
FOR THE ACT AGAINST INVADERS.
AND IT ALSO IN A COUPLE OF OTHER
ISSUES LATER WE HAVE. VICE SAN
JUAN SHE IS THE ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR CAPITAL PLANNING
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION. SO
THREE OF US WILL PROVIDE YOU
THAT DETAIL FOR A TO SEE ISSUES
PERSPECTIVE. AND ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS TODAY. SERVER MIGHT BE
TO CALL. I WOULD LIKE TO THREE.
YOU'RE FOR. SOME HIGH LEVEL FAX
POLICY ISSUE. SECOND THE MULTI
YEAR CONTACT THAT HAS BEEN
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR-
BETWEEN THE GOVERNOR AND CSU YES
THIRD COMMENTS ON THIS BUDGET
CYCLE IN PARTICULAR. SO MY FIRST
TOPIC AS A QUICK REFRESHER LIKE
TO SHARE SOME HIGH LEVEL FACTS
AND FIGURES ABOUT THE C. ISSUE.
AS THE NATION'S LARGEST FOUR
YEAR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY DECISION
PROVIDES EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
ON TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES. AND
THOSE CAMPUSES STRETCH FROM CAL
POLY HUMBLE MINORIS TO SAN DIEGO
STATE UNIVERSITY IN THE SOUTH.
THIS ISSUE ANNUAL CONFERS ALMOST
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND DEGREES THAT'S
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
PROGRAMS DEGREES AND POST NEARLY
FOUR MILLION LIVING ALUMNI. ALSO
NEARLY HALF OF ALL THE
BACHELOR'S DEGREES AWARDED IN
CALIFORNIA R. C. ISSUE DEGREES
AND ONE IN TEN CALIFORNIA
WORKERS IS A CSU GRADUATE. NOW
MY SECOND TOPIC WHICH ARE CUT
WHICH OUR COMMENTS ON THE MOST
OF YOUR CONTACT. THE CONTACT IS
AN IMPORTANT MILESTONE FOR
CALIFORNIA. IN THE C. ISSUE
ESPECIALLY FINANCIAL
SUSTAINABILITY AND
PREDICTABILITY. YOU WILL NOT
FIND ALL THE UNIVERSITIES NEEDS
AND REVIEW THIS BUDGET CONTACT
AS A CRITICAL SAFETY NET TO
PROTECT THE UNIVERSITY FROM
ECONOMICS FLUCTUATIONS OVER THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. YOU KNOW THAT'S
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO LAWS ARE
CONSTITUTIONAL PROVISIONS THAT
PROVIDE ANY BUDGETARY ASSURANCES
ARE PREDICTABILITY FROM YEAR TO
YEAR FOR TO SEE ISSUE. SO WE
THEREFORE ARE GRATEFUL VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR. IN HIS
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE SMALL FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT. IT'S MY THIRD
TOPIC. WHICH IS COMMENTS ABOUT
THAT TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET. SO JUST MASON AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SEVERAL BUDGETARY
NEEDS AND THEY ARE ARTICULATED
IN THE TRUSTEES OPERATE BUDGET
REQUESTS- THIS ISSUES PLAN WILL
HELP US ENSURE THAT FAIR AND
EQUITABLE COMPENSATION OF OUR
WORLD CLASS A STUDENT CENTER
FACULTY AND STAFF- THAT BUDGET
PLAN BY THE TRUSTEES WILL
ELEVATE STUDENT SUCCESS FOR ALL
WITH A FOCUS ON COMPLETING AND
ELIMINATING- EQUITY GAPS THAT
EXIST BETWEEN STUDENTS OF COLOR.
FIRST GENERATIONAL- STUDENTS AND
LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND THEIR
PEERS B. R. GRADUATION ISSUE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND THAT
PLAN WILL ALSO REPAIR AND
MODERNIZE OUR AGING FACILITIES
MANAGER STRUCTURE. PROMOTE
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT WHAT
PROVIDE THE SAFEST POSSIBLE
VARMINT FOR STUDENTS FACULTY
STAFF. AND THEN THE PLAN WILL
ALSO PROMOTES TO BASIC AND
TECHNOLOGICAL NEEDS ONLY GROWS
AND COVER MANDATORY COST
INCREASES. NOW GOVERNOR NUISANCE
FUNDING PROPOSAL FOR THE SUSHI
RECOGNIZES THE POWERFUL ROLE OUR
CAMPUS IS PLAYING THE STATE'S
ECONOMY. AND HIS PROPOSAL ALLOWS
US TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
TRUSTEES BUDGET REQUESTED THAT
PLAN THAT SOME OF THOSE PIECES I
JUST MENTION. WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE BE TWO HUNDRED NINETY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF ON GOING
FUNDING. AND THE ONE HUNDRED
MILLION OF ONE TIME FUNDING HE
PUT TOWARD THE ITEMS I JUST
DESCRIBED. BUT THERE DOES REMAIN
A GAP BETWEEN THE TRUSTEES
BUDGET PLAN THE GOVERNOR'S FOR
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. CAN WE
FULLY UNDERSTAND THAT IT WILL
TAKE BOTH AN IMPROVEMENT IN THE
STATE REVENUE PICTURE AND PUBLIC
POLICY CHOICES FIND YOU THE
SENATE AS WELL AS THE ASSEMBLY
GOVERNOR IN MAY AND IN JUNE. FOR
THIS TO OCCUR. WE'LL BE READY TO
DO MORE AT THE TOP I SEE SHE'S
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES TO PROVIDE
CARE- AND COMPETITIVE SOUTH FOR
FACULTY AND STAFF. TO REDUCE
EQUITY GAPS AND MEET THE GROWING
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF OUR
CAMPUSES AMONG OTHER ITEMS
MENTIONED. SO IN CONCLUSION I
HAVE TWO NUMBERS. YOUR NUMBER.
FIRST THIS ISSUE BUDGET BE
INCREASED BY AN ADDITIONAL THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE MILLION IN
ONGOING FUNDING TO. THE TRUSTEES
BALANCE OF THE TRUSTEES PROPERTY
BUDGET PARTIES. IN SECOND THAT
AN ADDITIONAL NINE HUNDRED
MILLION ONE TIME DOLLARS BE
ADDED TO FIND. ECONOMIC
FACILITIES AND WORLD RENEWAL
DATES- OF MY FUTURE COLLEAGUE DR
NATHAN EVANS WILL SHARE VIEWS ON
GRADUATION SHOULD. TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE ENROLLMENT MATTERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- WELCOME DOCTOR
OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A GOOD
MORNING ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS
NATHAN EVANS AND I SERVICE
ASSOCIATE VICE CHANCELLOR AND
CHIEF OF STAFF FOR ACADEMIC
INSTEAD IS THAT THE CSU AND I
WANT TO SAY THAT AGAIN THANK YOU
MISTER STORM THANK YOU CHAIR
LAYERED SENATORS MAN IN A
TROUBLE FOR TODAY'S TOPICS. AS
MR STORE MENTION WE ARE DEEPLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
AND THE LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF STUDENT SUCCESS
ADDRESSING INEQUITIES IN STUDENT
OUTCOMES AND INCREASING ACCESS
TO THE CSU THESE ACTIONS
RECOGNIZE THE ROLE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND THE CSU
SPECIFICALLY PLAYS IN THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND
THE LONG TERM SOCIAL MOBILITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION.
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC CHANCER
CASTRO AND R. TWENTY THREE
CAMPUS PRESIDENTS HAVE GUIDED
THE UNIVERSITY FOLLOWING TO KEEP
PRINCIPLES. FIRST SAFEGUARDING
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
ENTIRE C. ISSUE COMMUNITY. AND
SECOND ENSURING THAT AS MANY
STUDENTS AS POSSIBLE HAVE ACCESS
TO AND STAY ON TRACK TO EARNING
THE LIFELONG BENEFITS OF THE CSU
DEGREE. OUR COMMITMENT TO SEE A
SPOT TO STUDENT SUCCESS IN
EQUITY THEIR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
REMAINS CONSTANT. AND THE C.
ISSUES ABILITY TO MEET THE
STATE'S FUTURE WORKFORCE NEEDS
THROUGH THE INITIATIVE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN PREDICATED BOTH ON
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES AND
ENROLLMENT GROWTH AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
RECOGNIZES BOTH OF THESE
ELEMENTS. I'M PLEASED TO SHARE
THAT IN SPITE OF THE PANDEMIC
DURING THE LAST COLLEGE YEAR
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED THIRTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS EARNED A CSU
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. MARKING AN
ALL TIME RECORD FOR
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREES AWARDED BY
THE CSU. THESE ACHIEVEMENTS
REPRESENT NEARLY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND MORE DEGREES EARNED IN
A SINGLE YEAR COMPARED TO TWENTY
FOUR BY TWENTY FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
THE YEAR BEFORE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
BEGAN. AND THESE GRADUATES HELP
THE CSU ACHIEVED THE MILESTONE
OF FOUR MILLION LIVING CSU
ALUMNI. IT'S ALSO EXCITING TO
SHARE THE GRADUATION RATES FOR
BOTH THOSE THAT INTEREST FIRST
TIME STUDENTS FROM HIGH SCHOOL
AND THOSE THE TRANSFER FROM
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE AT ALL TIME HIGHS IN THE C.
ISSUE FOR ALL STUDENT GROUPS.
BUT OUR WORK ISN'T FINISHED. AS
GRADUATION OUTCOMES HAVE
IMPROVED FOR ALL STUDENTS GAPS
OF MOVED IN STEP WITH THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS. AND TO ADDRESS
THESE GAPS AS ONE OF HIS FIRST
ACTS CHANCER CASTRO AND LISTED A
GROUP OF EXPERTS STAKEHOLDERS.
TO FORM GRADUATION INITIATIVE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. THEIR CHARGE WAS TO
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
STRATEGIC SOLUTIONS. CLEARLY AND
WILL ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS EMPOWER
RECIPIENTS ACROSS OUR TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES. FROM THIS WORK
IN NOVEMBER THE CHANCELLOR
ANNOUNCED FIVE EQUITY PRIORITIES
INTENDED TO AFFECT CHANGE OUT
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM CHANGE.
AMONG THESE PRIORITIES WERE
FIRST AND IMMEDIATE RE
ENROLLMENT AND RE ENGAGEMENT
CAMPAIGNS UNDERSERVED STUDENTS
WHO LEFT THE UNIVERSITY DURING
THE PANDEMIC. SECOND THE
STRATEGIC USE OF SUMMER AND
INTERCESSIONS TO GET STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY THOSE FROM LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES BACK ON TRACK
TO TIMELY GRADUATION. AND THREE
THE CRITICAL EVALUATION OF
UNIVERSITY PROCESS SEES WITH
WITH AN EYE TOWARD ELIMINATING
AS MANY INSTITUTIONAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS TO
STUDENT SUCCESS IS POSSIBLE. I'M
TURNING FINALLY TO ENROLLMENT
THE CSU SYSTEM IS POISED TO
OFFER NEW OPPORTUNITIES TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE AND YEARS
TO COME. AND FALL TWENTY TWENTY
DURING THE EARLY MONTHS OF THE
PANDEMIC THE C. ISSUE RECORDED A
RECORD STUDENT POPULATION WHICH
BUCKED NATIONAL TRENDS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION ROLE AT. FIVE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THIS PAST FALL
THE IMPACT OF THE ONGOING
ONGOING PANDEMIC WAS EVIDENT IN
MODEST DECLINES IN BOTH NEW
STUDENT ENROLLMENT AND INCREASED
RETENTION OF CONTINUING
STUDENTS. BRING OUR SYSTEMWIDE
ENROLLMENT BACK DOWN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN
LEVELS. AND WHILE WE DO EXPECT
TO SEE THE IMPACTS OF LOWER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ENROLLMENT OR
TRANSFER STUDENT POPULATION FOR
SEVERAL YEARS TO COME. I'M
EXCITED TO SHARE THAT
APPLICATIONS FOR FALL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO ADMISSION FROM HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS HAVE ALREADY
REBOUNDED BY NEARLY 15% ABOVE
LAST YEAR. AND LASTLY AS I
MENTIONED THE RE ENGAGEMENT OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS AND THOSE
WITH SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL NEED.
TO HAD TO SUSPEND THEIR
EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY DURING THE
PANDEMIC IS AMONG OUR HIGHEST
EQUITY PRIORITIES. STE WITH
EARLY SIGNALS FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH IN THE BUDGET OUR CSU
CAMPUSES WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE
GREATER NUMBERS OF ADMISSIONS
OFFICER OFFERS. AND FOCUS MORE
TIME ATTENTION TO SUPPORT FOR
YIELDING THESE NEW STUDENTS. AND
THE MULTI YEAR COMMITMENT TO
ENROLLMENT GROWTH WILL ALLOW
MORE SO IF YOU'RE PLANNING AND
ALLOCATION OF NEW ENROLLMENT TO
THE MOST IN DEMAND CAMPUSES IN
REGIONS. TO ACHIEVE BOTH OUR
STUDENTS SUCCESS AND EQUITY
GOALS AND MEET CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE WORKFORCE NEEDS BILL
TAKEN CONTINUED INVESTMENT
COLLECTED FOCUSED AND
INTENTIONAL ACTION. ACROSS THE
C. ISSUE IN SACRAMENTO AND AMONG
OUR VALUED PARTNERS. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME TODAY AND
THESE TOPICS AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
NOW WILL MOVE TO JENNIFER LOUIS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MR CARE AND MEMBERS
JENNIFER LOUIS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS A SKIN IS
FOCUSED- BUDGET WITH AN EMPHASIS
ON ACCESS EQUITY AND INNOVATION.
THIS INCLUDES AN ONGOING GENERAL
FUND TOTAL OF THREE HUNDRED FOUR
POINT ONE MILLION WHICH CONSIST
OF TWELVE MILLION FOUR FOSTER
YOU SERVICES EIGHTY ONE MILLION
AND ONGOING RESOURCES. FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS UNDER ROMAN
GROWTH OF 940-009-9000 FOUR NINE
THREE FOUR FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS IN THE TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE ACADEMIC YEAR AS WELL AS A
5% BASING CREASE. OF TWO HUNDRED
ELEVEN POINT NINE MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO PROVIDES
TWO HUNDRED THIRTY THREE MILLION
AND ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENTS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROJECTS. THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THE CSU BAKERSFIELD ENERGY
INNOVATION CENTER AND SUPPORTING
UNIVERSITY FARMS. THE 5%
INCREASE IN THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE REPRESENTS THE
FIRST YEAR OF A PLANT BASED
GROWTH OF 5% ANNUALLY THREE
TWENTY TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN.
IN RECOGNITION OF CSU'S
COMMITMENT TOWARD ACHIEVING
MULTIPLE GOALS THROUGH A MULTI
MULTI YOUR CONTACT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AIMED AT THE
FOLLOWING INCREASING ACCESS TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
IMPROVING STUDENT SUCCESS AND
ADVANCING EQUITY. INCREASING THE
AFFORDABILITY OF A CSU EDUCATION
INCREASING INTER SEGMENTAL
COLLABORATION TO BENEFIT
STUDENTS SUPPORTING WORKFORCE
PREPAREDNESS AND HIGH DEMAND
CAREER PIPELINES AND PROVIDING
ACCESS TO ONLINE COURSE
OFFERINGS. THIS CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE OR ANY
FURTHER DETAIL AS REQUESTED
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVE POLICE CAME LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. THANK YOU. IN
THIS ISSUE OF HEARING AGAIN DESK
ON THE BOTTOM OF PAGE TWENTY.
VERY ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
MEETING CLIFFORD TO TWENTY THREE
AND THEN TRYING TO IMPLEMENT FOR
THE NEXT TWO YEARS. PAST WEEK
THINK THAT THE APPROACH OF
PROVIDING AN UNRESTRICTED BASED
ON PEACE HAS TO DISADVANTAGES.
ONE OF WHICH IS BAD BECAUSE NONE
OF THESE CASES NOT DIRECTLY TIED
TO DOCUMENT THE COST INCREASES
THAT THE FACULTY FACING. CONCEAL
THE STARTING THE BOTTOM OF PAGE
TWENTY YOUR TIME THAT ONLY FILL
IT OUT MEANT TO KEEP COSTING.
THIS YEAR HE WAS IDENTIFIED. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE.
THIS INCLUDES COSTA. RATE
INCREASED EMPLOYEE HEALTH
BENEFITS. SALARY INCREASES
FACULTY WITH HIM YES HE WAS
RECENTLY NEGOTIATED A TENTATIVE
AGREEMENT. PUTTING THE SALARY
POOL FOR NON FACULTY EMPLOYEES
MANY OF WHOM CURRENTLY HAVE
CONTRACTS. FOR TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. INCREASES IN
CERTAIN NON PERSONNEL COSTS FOR
EXAMPLE BACK INCLUDE GRATION ON
OPERATING EXPENSES. WE RECOMMEND
OF THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
WHICH OF THESE COST INCREASES IT
WISHES TO SUPPORT FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR AND USE THAT TO DETERMINE
THE AMOUNT OF THE BASE INCREASED
BY. BERMAN HE RECALL THE LAST
YEAR'S AGREEMENT INCLUDING
INTENT TO FUND ECONOMIC GROWTH
OF NINE THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY FOR RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. SENDING
THIS THE MOMENT TARGET YES YOU
HAVE SEEN DECLINES IN
ENROLLMENT. AS MY COLLEAGUES AT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE OF NOTED
FUNDING FROM THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. BASED ON ESTIMATES
UNDERLYING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. RESIDENT UNDERGRADUATE
MOMENTS IN THE CURRENT YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO.
ARE PROJECTED TO BE ABOUT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS LOWER THAN
THEY WERE. PREVIOUSLY. WHAT HE
STANDS FOR THE LEGISLATORS AMONG
THE GROWTH TARGET FOR TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. BECAUSE IT CSU
ACTORS NINE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR STUDENTS ON
TO THIS LOWER BASELINE LEVEL THE
CURRENT ACT. IT STILL WOULD BE
PROJECTED TO SERVE FEWER
STUDENTS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE OF THAT ACT AT TWO
YEARS EARLIER TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND SO WE THINK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE. WE WISH TO
CONSIDER HOW THIS IMPACTS THE
MOMENT TARGETS AND PROPOSED
FUNDING LEVEL FOR TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. LEGISLATURE HAS
EXPRESSED QUITE A LOT OF
INTEREST IN GROWING REAL
INTEREST YES YOU AND RIGHT NOW
SINCE CAMPUS ADMISSIONS
DECISIONS FOR TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE ARE ALREADY UNDER WAY WE
THINK ACTUALLY THE GREATEST
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT GROWTH.
EVEN BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. ILLEGAL COULD
NOT ATTEND AT SOME
CONSIDERATIONS THAT YOU MAY WISH
TO THINK THROUGH AS YOU DECIDE
ON A NORMAL LEVEL FOR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. THIS INCLUDES
CHANGES IN A NUMBER OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES ABOUT A FAX
FRESHMAN DEMANDED CSU. CHANGES
INCLUDING COLLAGEN WOMAN SAYS
THAT OF COURSE THE TAX TRANSFER
DEMAND. FROM THE MOMENT MODEL OF
THE LEGISLATURE CHOOSES FOR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR IF IT
IS HIGHER THAN PREVIOUS
EMPLOYMENT IT'S YES YOU LIVE
RECOMMENDED PROVIDING A MOMENT
GROWTH AUGMENTATION. THIS IS
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT FROM THE
APPROACH PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS MULTI YEAR
CONTRACT. WHICH WOULD EXPECTS
YES YOUR ACCOMMODATE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH INCREASES FROM WITHIN ITS
5% ON RESTRICTED BASE INCREASE
STARTING OUT HERE'S- THANK YOU
I'D BE HAPPY TAKING QUESTIONS ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M TOM THAT COMPLETES THE
PANELISTS AND I'M TO BEGIN WITH
A FEW QUESTIONS. AND AND THEN GO
TO MY COLLEAGUES AND FIRST. OF
FOR MR STORM I'M JUST TRYING TO
DO AN APPLES TO APPLES BECAUSE
OF. THE GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDED
5% BASE INCREASE AND THEN YOU
SAID THAT. YOU WOULD LIKE AN
ADDITIONAL THREE HUNDRED AND
SOMETHING MILLION DO YOU KNOW
WHAT PERCENT THAT IS OF THAT I
KNOW 5% PLUS WHAT PERCENT. I
WOULD SAY A THE WAY TO LOOK AT
IT- FROM DESI ISSUES PERSPECTIVE
. IS THAT A WEEK. WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY FUND SOURCES THAT
SUPPORT THE UNIVERSITY- FIRST
STATE GENERAL FUND. AND SECONDLY
WE HAVE THE TUITION AND FEES
THAT STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
PROVIDE THE UNIVERSITY. SO ONE
THING THAT TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THAT WHEN WE DO TALK ABOUT A 5%
INCREASE TO THE GENERAL FUND
PORTION OF OUR BUDGET THAT IS
ABOUT A TWO POINT 85% OPERATING
BUDGET INCREASE. TO UNIVERSITY-
IN TERMS OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
THE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE
THAT I MENTIONED I'D HAVE TO DO
SOME WORK ON A CALCULATOR AND
REAL QUICK I TRY TO BUY ENOUGH
TIME TO DO THAT BUT I DON'T
LISTEN WERE YOU CAN LET YOU KNOW
LET US NOW BUT I WILL JUST. BE
HEARING FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THE UC'S ABOUT THE
PERCENT INCREASE COMPARED TO
THEIRS AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER IS BEFORE I
GET THE INCOMING FROM THE OTHER
BRANCHES ABOUT EQUITY YEAH SO
JUST LET ME KNOW WHAT THAT
PERCENT IS THEN LET ME ASK
ANOTHER QUESTION- ONE OF THE- OF
. THERE MIGHT HAVE BEENTHE
AUDIO TALKED ABOUT YOUR
TENTATIVE AGREEMENT BOB WITH THE
FACULTY AND IT IS ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN OF OUR STAFF REPORT
AND FIRST IT ON THE WHOLE ISSUE
OF TENTATIVE THE SAID IN FRONT
OF BOTH THE BOARD AND THE UNION
TO RATIFY NOW WHAT'S THE STATUS
OF FACTOR THAT THAT'S CORRECT
SEWER BOARD OF TRUSTEES MET LAST
WEEK AND APPROVED. ITS PORTION
OF THAT AGREEMENT. I BELIEVE
THAT THE ARE TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WILL BE OUR- VOTING ON ON THEIR
PORTION OF THE AGREEMENT-
SOMETIME THIS MONTH I BELIEVE
IT'S THE FIRST COUPLE WEEKS OF
THIS MONTH IT. IS THE SCHEDULE.
WE'LL SEE IF WE HAVE A FINAL
AGREEMENT OKAY AND THEN THE WITH
REGARD. THIS GIVES ME THE
DETAILS ARE GENERALLY SPELLED
OUT IN OUR STAFF REPORT AND IT
TALKS ABOUT. PAYMENTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY RELATED- TO WATCH YOURS
YOUR GENERAL FUND- ALLOCATIONS
MIGHT BE FROM THE STATE D. A. IF
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IS
APPROVED AT THAT PERCENTAGE
LEVEL. YOU HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO
IMPLEMENT DISAGREEMENT. WE DO
YES THE- YOUR YOUR AGENDA ITEM I
THINK THAT- PROPERLY- REFLECTS
THAT THE ANTICIPATED COST THAT
WE HAVE WITH THE TEN AGAINST
CALIFORNIA BAPTIST ASSOCIATION
AGREEMENT. SAYS EIGHTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS- THAT WILL COVER
THE GENERAL SALARY INCREASE BUT
THEN THERE'S ALSO ANOTHER
ELEMENT CONSTRUCTION INCREASE SO
EIGHTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
THEIR- WE ALSO HAVE- I NUMBER
MANDATORY ITEMS THAT- THIS KING
POINTED OUT. IN HER ANALYSIS AND
THAT IS REFLECTED JAMES WELL
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT ARE VERY
BASIC THAT WE MUST COVER SO FOR
EXAMPLE. CALPERS SHEETS ANYMORE
HEALTH CARE- PROGRAM COSTS THOSE
COSTS HAVE GONE UP BY ABOUT
FORTY NINE DOGS YOURSELF THOSE
ARE FIRM COSTS THAT WE WILL HAVE
IT THE UNIVERSE REGARDLESS OF
HOW MUCH FUNDS PROVIDED. IN THE
BEYOND THAT IT JUST BECOMES A
DECISION MAKING TREE ULTIMATELY
WHEN YOU THE GOVERNOR IN THE
ASSEMBLY COME TO A CONCLUSION ON
WHAT WILL BE IN THE BUDGET NOPE
IT'S TOUCH UP MORE BECAUSE WE
HAVE SO MANY OTHER PARTIES LIKE
TO ADDRESS FOR EXAMPLE RIGHT NOW
BASED ON THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE WOULD BE
REALLY DIFFICULT TO FOR EXAMPLE.
REALLY BEST A LOT OF PAIN CITING
. AND LONG TERM DEBT SIR ON USED
TO STILL. WILL TO THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE LITTLE BIT WEST ADVICE
JUAN AND OTHERS. BUT IT JUST
MAKES IT THAT MUCH HARDER TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS ALL OF THE OTHER
PRIORITIES. THAT ARE NOT.
FREEING CLEAR RIGHT IN OUR FACE
SO TO SPEAK BUT ARE THINGS THAT
ARE ASPIRATIONAL. LIKE TO
INVESTORS. LIKE TO GRADUATION
AND SHIP REPLY CAN FACILITY
ITSELF WILL BE MORE CHALLENGING
OBVIOUSLY NOTICING THAT STILL
HAS THAT STILL OPEN A SENATOR.
RELATED YOUR QUESTION. IS THAT
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER.
REPRESENTED AND NOT REPRESENTED
GROUPS THAT HAVE HAVE NOT HAD
ANY SORT OF A RESOLUTION TO
THEIR- SALARY NEEDS FOR. FOR THE
FUTURE SO THOSE ARE THAT'S
THAT'S GONNA BE NO THEIR
TRUNCHEONS. OF COSTS THAT WE
WILL BE- I NEED TO ADDRESS WITH
THIS TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS SO. I DON'T WANT TO DO
NOT SOMETHING PRICE I DON'T WANT
TO INFLUENCE. YOUR YOUR- NEGOTIN
. BY A UP QUESTION BUT IF. HE
WOULD YOU EXPECT THAT HOWEVER
YOU CONCLUDE THOSE AGREEMENTS
YOU HAVE ENOUGH FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S 5% TO PAY FOR THEM. I
WILL CERTAINLY SIR DUCK THAT
QUESTION FOR NOW WE'RE GOING TO
LET THAT NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN
THE UNIONS AND- MANAGEMENT WORK
THEMSELVES THROUGH AND WE'LL
JUST HAVE TO SEE WHERE THOSE
AGREEMENTS PLAN BUT OBVIOUSLY
IT. THIS WILL BE ONE OF ONE THIS
WILL BE THE ONLY TIME IN A
HEARING THAT I WILL LET YOU
DUCKED QUESTIONS. YOU VIEW STUFF
YOUR ONE SO I SHOULD PROBABLY
START TO MAKE A LIST OF OTHER
QUESTIONS TO ASK YOUNOW SINCE
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
DOCK. UP- LET ME MOVE TO A
QUESTION FOR DOC EVANS. IN AND
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT. EQUITY
GAPS IN YOUR COMMENTS AND ON
PAGE NINETEEN. OF OUR- AGENDA IT
SHOWS THAT THE CSU GRADUATION
EQUITY GAP FOR BLACK NATIVE
AMERICAN AND LATINO STUDENTS
GREW TO TWELVE POINT 4% IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE UP FROM TEN
POINT 5% AND TWENTY TWENTY I
WOULD ASK HOW YOU IN THE
CAMPUSES ARE FOCUSING ON CLOSING
THESE EQUITY GAPS IN WHAT
ENHANCEMENTS OR RESOURCES ARE
COULD BE PROVIDED TO YOU OR
WOULD YOU NEED TO HELP THE CSU
MEET THAT GOAL. I THANK YOU
TRAILER- AN EXCELLENT QUESTION
AND ONE THAT REALLY IS DRIVING
OUR WORK EVERY DAY- AS I AS I
REFERENCED IN MY COMMENTS- THE
CHANCELLOR ANNOUNCED A THREE TO
FIVE POINT EQUITY PRIORITY-
PLAY. LAST FALL THAT REALLY IS
FOCUSED ON ADDRESSING THOSE
GAPS- NOT ONLY IN THE SHORT TERM
BUT WITH THE GOAL OF ELIMINATING
THEM PERMANENTLY- THAT INCLUDES.
SOME OF THAT GAP HAS IS CAUSED
BY STUDENTS SIMPLY LEAVING THE
UNIVERSITY DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND SO THAT FIRST PRIORITY THAT
I MENTION IN TERMS OF. A FOCUS
RE ENGAGEMENT AND RE ENROLLMENT
CAMPAIGN WHICH IS VERY FOCUSED
ON AFRICAN AMERICAN LATIN ACTS
AND NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS
AMONG OTHERS THAT MAY HAVE LEFT
THE UNIVERSITY DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND- FINDING OUT IN
ADDRESSING EVERY VERY INDIVIDUAL
LEVEL- THE REASONSWHY THEY LEFT
THE CSU WHAT STEPS CAN BE TAKEN
TO GET THEM BACK INTO THE C. S.
U. B. N. ARTS. SUPPORT ARENA. AB
AND ACADEMIC PREPARATION
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE AND AS A
REFERENCE THAT REALLY IS AT AN
INDIVIDUAL LEVEL AND I'LL I'LL
HIGHLIGHT ONE OF OUR CAMPUSES
SAN FRANCISCO STATE THAT BEGAN
THIS WORK VERY EARLY- FOCUSING
ALL STUDENTS FROM THE ENTERING
CLASS OF TWENTY NINETEEN OR FALL
TWENTY TWENTY. THAT WERE NO
LONGER STILL ENROLLED AND AGAIN
SORT OF CREATING A TRIAGE TEAM
TO MAKE OUT REACHED STUDENTS TO
WORK THROUGH INDIVIDUAL. C.
ISSUE COMMUNITY IN THIS ASE SAN
FRANCISCO STATE AND IN THEIR
CASE WHILE THEY MAY HAVE ONLY
INITIALLY. HAD A GOAL OF
RECOUPING 10% OF THEIR STUDENT
OF THOSE STUDENTS AN ACT FIRST
PASSED ACTUALLY DOUBLE THAT IN
AND RECOUP TO- 20% OF THOSE
STUDENTS SO IT'S THAT VERY
INDIVIDUALIZED STRATEGY THAT IS
IN THE SHORT TERM. AS WELL AS
SOME THAT ARE LONGER TERM- WE AT
ONE OF THE OTHER ELEMENTS IS
FOCUSED ON HIGH ENROLLMENT.
COURSES THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS OF- EARNING A NON
PASSING GRADE PREDOMINATELY FOR.
STUDENTS OF COLOR LOW INCOME
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS AND
THEN WORKING WITH WITH FACULTY
WITH ACADEMIC DEPARTMENTS TO
LOOK AT THE- G. THE STRUCTURE. I
THOUGHT OLOGY THE- THE MODE OF
INSTRUCTION TO REALLY LOOK AND
SEE IF THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES
TO RETHINK AND REWORK THAT
TEACHING APPROACH SO THAT WE
HAVE STRONGER OUTCOMES AGAIN
USING THE SAME CURRICULUM AND
EMPOWERING FACULTY TO HELP MAKE
THOSE CHANGES SO. SUMMER VERY
STRATEGIC SHORT TERM EFFORTS
LIKE THAT RIAN GO GAUGE MEN RE
ENROLLMENT OTHERS ARE INTENDED
TO BE MORE SYSTEMIC CHANGES.
FOCUSED ON- AS I SAID SORT OF
COURSE REDESIGN AT FOR THE
BETTERMENT. OF STUDENTS I'M
GOING FORWARD. ARMAR I WOULD
HOPE YOU WOULD KEEP US INFORMED
ABOUT. WHAT IT MIGHT TAKE TO.
pGOALS AND IF THERE'S ANY
ASSISTANCE FOR- WERE RE
DIRECTION OR ANYTHING THAT GETS
US THERE AND LET ME ASK THE
OTHER HALF OF THAT QUESTIONING
YOU SORT OF GOT UP TO IT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS BUT- HOW CAMPUSES
ARE USING. OUR STATE BUDGET
FUNDS TOWARD EXISTING OF
PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE PROGRAM TO IMPROVE
GRADUATION RATES AND REDUCE
EQUITY GAPS. THANK YOU CENTER
LAYERED AND MAYBE TO- CONNECT
THE DOTS I WILL- CITY TO THIS
SORT OF- END OF YOUR LIFE
COMMENTS REGARDING MY PRIOR
RESPONSE. AS MR STORM ALLUDED TO
THERE STILL REMAINS A GAP
BETWEEN THE BUDGET THAT WAS
ADOPTED BY THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES AND THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL- AMONG
THOSE ELEMENTS IS CONTINUED
INVESTMENT INTO GRADUATION
INITIATIVE AND SO. THAT IS AN
EXPLICIT WAY- THAT WOULD
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THIS WORK-
TO SEE THAT AND AUGMENTATION
COVERING. THEIR WORK TO MISTER
STORMS POINT THAT DELTA OUT
BETWEEN. EIGHT OUR TRUSTEES
BUDGET AND THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET IN TERMS OF
ALLOCATION OF. OUR PRIOR
RESOURCES THE ACT IF AS YOU
ALLUDED TO THEY HAVE GONE TO
BOTH THE INFUSION OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE A SUCCESSFUL WAY TO SORT
OF GET STUDENTS INTO A CONTACT
WITH THE WITH THE UNIVERSITY
THEMSELVES IN TERMS OF SETTING.
OBJECTIVES AND GOALS IN TERMS OF
MINIMUM NUMBER OF UNITS AND-
METRICS FOR THEIR OWN STUDENT
SUCCESS. WELL I- THING AND THIS
IS I WAS- WHOLE CHANCE CASTRO
OUT IN SHINING LIGHT ON POINTS
OF SUCCESS DO HAVE CAMPUS IS
ALREADY. OUT OF LOCALLY
ELIMINATED EQUITY GAPS- AT THE
MACRO WHAT YOU IS WHAT YOU SEE
IN THE END TODAY'S HEARING
REPORT BUT WE HAVE CAMPUSES THAT
HAVE HAD TREMENDOUS SUCCESS. AND
TAKING THAT LEARNING AND
APPLYING IT TO OTHER CAMPUSES
FOR EXAMPLE A CHANCER CASTRO HAS
ILLUSTRATED THAT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- BUT FRESNO STATE WHERE
HE WAS FORMALLY PRESIDENT AND
STANISLAUS. SHARED MANY OF THE
SAME STUDENT COMMUNITIES AND
STANISLAUS HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN NEARLY ZERO WING OUT OUT THE
GAP- FOR PELL ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
AND SO AS A FORMER. AS SENIOR
LEADER AT FRESNO TO LEARN FROM
HIS COLLEAGUES JUST UP- JUST UP
THE VALLEY WAS INVALUABLE AND
RELEASING OTHER STRATEGIES TO-
TO HELP STUDENTS FROM SIMILAR
COMMUNITIES SUCCEED. THANK YOU
M. OBVIOUSLY FROM THESE TWO
QUESTIONS WE HAVE AN INTEREST IN
THIS AND WE WANT TO KNOW. IT
AND- WE WANT YOU TO TELL US
WHAT'S WORKING AND WHAT'S NOT
AND WHAT YOU HAVE THE RESOURCES
FOR US SO JUST NOTED AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSES. ARE I
HAVE ONE LAST QUESTION BEFORE
GOING TO MY COLLEAGUES AND IT'S
PROBABLY. A RAIMES STORM
QUESTIONS ABOUT OUR- BARB A
REPORT OF SPEAKS TO THE SWANTON
PACIFIC RANCH REBUILD CAL POLY.
AND IT'S A THIRTY EIGHT HUNDRED
ACRE WORKING RANCH THAT JOB THAT
SERVES AS AN EDUCATIONAL
FACILITY WITH AMAZING LEARNING
AND FOR ST AGRICULTURE. AND CZ
YOU FIRE IN TWENTY TWENTY
DESTROYED MOST EVERYTHING IT'S
I'VE BEEN THROUGH THERE. AND
THE- THERE'S ONE BUILDING THAT
WAS AT THE EDGE OF A FIELD THAT
SURVIVED EVERYTHING ELSE SEEM TO
GO OUT OF FORCED WILLIAMS- ALL
THE OTHER BUILDINGS EVEN A
NARROW GAUGE RAILWAY. AND I HAVE
IT'S IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE IN
THE STAFF REPORT BUT I HAVE. HE
SENT TO ME. SORT OF WHAT A
REQUEST IS FOR THE REBUILD AND I
THINK IT FALLS INTO CATEGORIES
SO I THINK THE PRIORITY IS.
SOMETHING LIKE EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION JUST FOR THE FACILITIES
TO MAKE SURE THEY COME BACK. AND
THEN THIRTY MILLION FOR AN
ADDITIONAL- ACADEMIC CENTER THAT
MIGHT FOCUS. ON THE REBUILD AND
VISITORS AND OTHER THINGS AND MY
QUESTION IS. COULD YOU SPEAK TO
. WHERE MONEY HAS COME IN FOR
THE REBUILT I MEAN AS THEIR
DISASTER RELIEF MONEY IT IS
THEIR OTHER STUFF THAT THAT IS
COMING IN THIS IS JUST THE
UNFUNDED GAP AT THE END TO DO
THE REBUILD BAND- JUST SPEAK TO
SORT OF WHAT MIGHT BE A REQUEST
RELATED. TO THAT. SENATOR SO IN
IN KIND OF A ROUGH ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE. SO THERE'S A CURRENT
ESTIMATE OF BETWEEN FORTY NINE
POINT THREE MILLION AND FIFTY
FOUR POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
TO RE TURN THE RANCH TO ITS
PRIOR STATE SO THIS IS JUST KIND
OF THESE TWO PIECES OF THIS OF
THIS RANCHES SITUATION FIRST AS-
CAN WE GET IT BACK TO WHAT IT
WAS BEFORE AND THEN THERE'S AN
ASPIRATIONAL ASPECT OF IT.
THAT'S BEYOND THAT FOR-
EXPANDING AND MAKING A LARGER
EDUCATIONAL CENTER SO JUST ON
THE PART OF GETTING THE RANCH
BACK TO WHERE WAS BEFORE
OBVIOUSLY WITH NEW BUILDINGS IN
THE RENT FOR STRUCTURE. RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE ABOUT THREE PIECES
OF THIS RESTORATION FIRST IS
ABOUT THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS ESTIMATED- THAT WILL BE
COMING IN FROM INSURANCE THAT
COVERS YOU KNOW BUILDINGS THINGS
THAT WERE COVERED IN THAT WAY-
THEN ALSO THE CAMPUS SAN LUIS
OBISPO HAS SUBMITTED EAST. BASED
ON THEIR TO. REIMBURSED FOR
YOU'RE LOOKING T ABOUT ELEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
REIMBURSEMENT SOME MANY MONTHS
IF NOT YEARS DOWN THE ROAD-
THAT'S USUALLY AT. THAT DURATION
OF TIME IT TAKES PAYMENT
ACTUALLY. FOLLOW THROUGH AND
FINISH OFF CLAIMS. THAT LEAVES
THE CAMPUS WITH THAT AMOUNT THAT
YOU MENTION EIGHT POINT SEVEN
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. OF KIND OF A GAP
BECAUSE ON A FEMA CLAIM THEY
COVER TYPICALLY SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF THE COST OF A CLAIM
AND THEN THERE'S THIS KIND OF
THIS GAP AND WHAT'S ALSO PART OF
THIS EQUATION ON THE EIGHT POINT
SEVEN MILLION THAT YOU REFERENCE
SENATOR. IS THIS NOTION THAT-
THERE'S AN ADJUSTMENT OVER THE
WHOLE. TOTAL COST OF THE PROJECT
BECAUSE AS TIME MARCHES ON AND
CONSTRUCTION COSTS INCREASING
PERMITTING- REMAINING COST
INCREASES WELL. WE'RE WE'RE JUST
BUILDING IN AN ADDITIONAL THE
CAMPUS IS BUILT AN ADDITIONAL
10% ADJUSTMENT JUST A FACTORY
AND I'M NOT JUST GETTING THE
MONEY BACK- TO COVER CURRENT
COST BUT YOU DO NEED TO BUILD IN
SOME SORT OF FUNCTION OF
INSULATION SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ABOUT EIGHT POINT SEVEN EIGHT
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS. F FUNDING GAP- BUT I
DIED ALSO DON'T WANT TO LEAVE
THE COMMITTEE WITH THE
IMPRESSION THAT THIS IS ALL
GONNA COME TOGETHER SUPER
QUICKLY AT THE MOMENT YOU KNOW
THE CAMPUS HAS A MULTI YEAR-
PLAN IN TERMS OF GETTING GETTING
A SWANTON PACIFIC RANCH BACK UP
AND RUNNING. SEPARATELY APART
FROM THAT THERE'S THIS DESIRED
JUST HAPPENED EVEN BEFORE THE
FIRE BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE WAS A DESIRE TO AND
ACTUALLY- A PERMIT TO ACTUALLY
EXPAND ALL OF THE EDUCATIONAL
CENTER FACILITIES PRETTY
EXTENSIVELY- FROM THAT VANTAGE
POINT THAT'S THAT'S ASPIRATIONAL
SAYING THAT IS GOING TO THAT
THAT'S ESTIMATED TO COST ABOUT
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
THERE'S NO FUNDING. FROM ANY
SOURCE COMING IN FOR THAT THAT'S
GONNA REQUIRE PHILANTHROPIC AND
OTHER SOURCES ON THE GROUND IT'S
KIND OF A LONG TERM ASPIRATIONAL
AS MUCH SO HOPE THAT WAS HELPFUL
TO YOU THAT ACTUALLY WAS VERY
HELPFUL AND- I HAD THE
MISFORTUNE DURING MY NINE YEARS
ON THE CITY COUNCIL TO HAVE A-
HUNDRED YEAR STORM IN THE FIRST
SIX WEEKS AND THEN AN EARTHQUAKE
DESTROY OUR DOWNTOWN THE. YOUR
IN YEARS BETWEEN AND THE FEMA.
OF PAYMENT FOR THE FOR DESERVE
HAD NOT BEEN. BY THE TIME A LOT
OF THEM BY THE OF THIS DOES. SO
UNDER HOW. OF THAT PROCESS TAKES
UNDERSTAND THAT. THAT ARE YOU
ARE MAKING PROJECTIONS AND
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO THIS AS SORT
OF THE PLOT NUMBER BASED ON ONCE
INSURANCE AND FEMA AND OTHER
THINGS CALM. BUT WE ARE ALSO IN
A UNIQUE BUDGET SITUATION THIS
YEAR WHERE THERE WILL BE
PRIORITY TO ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES AND NOT ON GOING
EXPENDITURES AND SO I WOULD
HOPE. THAT YOU AGREE ON THIS AND
GIVE US THE CHANCE TO HELP YOU
THIS YEAR IF SOME OF US ON THE
COMMITTEE WANT TO DO THAT AS WE
MOVE TOWARD. THE DECISION MAKING
IN MAY SO I THINK WE WOULD WANT
TO MAKE SURE. THAT YOU UPDATE
THESE NUMBERS MAKE THEM CLEAR IF
THERE WAS A ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION MAY DID IT BE DONE
IN A WAY THAT IT COULD SURVIVE
YEARS AND MAKE SURE THAT IT. IF
MAJOR GAP ONE HOWEVER THESE
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES COME IN.
AND I WOULD JUST HOPE. THAT
FINANCE IN AND AWAY- WOULD WORK
WITH YOU ON THAT JUST SO THAT.
THAT WE COULD TRY TO GET TO
UNITED FRONT ON WHAT THE FACTS
ARE IF IN FACT WE WANT TO DO
SOMETHING AND I IS ONE OF THREE
MEMBERS WOULD. TOWARD THE
OFFICE. OF THE MAY. REVISE WITH
THAT FOR MY QUESTIONS IN MY ME
GO TIME. ASK YOUR FIRST PER BOAT
. BROKE WOULD LIKE GO FOR WITH
AND- THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE. SO. A
QUESTION FOR THE CSU I'M JUST
GONNA CURIOUS ON HOW YOU PLAN TO
PRIORITIZE THE PROPOSED BASED
INCREASE OF TWO HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS. GIVEN
THE IDEA AND HOW YOU PLAN ON
DOING THAT. IT WOULDN'T WHAT IT
WILL DO IS WE WILL BE
PRIORITIZING A LOT OF. ITEMS
THAT ARE MORE MANDATORY NATURE
CONSTANTLY KNOWS ABSOLUTELY SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
MENTIONED IN YOUR AGENDA ITEMS.
A NUMBER OF THOSE. A NUMBER OF
THOSE BUDGET PRIORITIES ONE OF
THOSE BEING- THAT TENTATIVE
AGREEMENT WE SPOKE ABOUT BETWEEN
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION C. ISSUE
ABOUT EIGHTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
OF COSTS SINCE THE WITH THAT-
DENTISTRY FOR THE TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE YEAR. WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF MANDATORY COSTS WILL
BE COVERING A MENTION
HEALTHCARE- WHENEVER WE DO BRING
ON BUILDINGS IN THIS IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE SENATOR BUT- HERE'S AGO
WE BEGAN THE PROCESS OF. EITHER
REFURBISHING OR BRING ON NEW
FACILITIES AND WITH THAT ONCE
THOSE BUILDINGS ARE FINISHEDAND
WE HAVE OUR FINAL PUNCH LIST
DONE. VIED AND ALLOW. FOR LACK
OF WORK FOR CAMP FOR K. TO.
ACTUALLY OPERATE. AND MAINTAIN
THOSE FACILITIES SO WE HAVE A
LITTLE OVER THREE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE WOULD BE
ALLOCATING TWO CAMPUSES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE CAMPUS BUILDINGS
ARE ACTUALLY OPERATIONAL AND
INTERNALIZED ON AND WATER ON
RIGHT. SO THE NUMBER OF THOSE
VERY- BREAD AND BUTTER SORT OF
ITEMS THAT WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
PAY FOR. AND THEN AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THE BUDGET. CYCLE IN AS
WE GET TO A FINAL BUDGET PACKAGE
NOT KNOWING WHAT THE FINAL
NUMBER IS. FROM YOU IN THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE GOVERNOR. WILL
BE MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT
OTHER AREAS CAN WE INVEST IN OF
THE TRUSTEES BUDGET PRIORITIES.
SO WE HAVE A NUMBER OF OTHER
AREAS LIKE THE GRADUATION THIS
YEAR YOUR BASIC NEEDS. WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL COMPENSATION COSTS WE
ANTICIPATE YES THERE ARE A
GRIEVANCE THAT ARE SETTLED WITH
OTHER UNITS- THERE ARE A FEW
OTHER ITEMS. NOT DISABILITIES
WE'LL HAVE TO. TAKE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF MONEY LIKE WE ALWAYS
DO EVERY YEAR I MEAN WE- RARELY
HAVE HAD OUR BUDGET REQUEST
FULLY FUNDED OBVIOUSLY WE'D LOVE
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN AGAIN THIS
YEAR BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT YOU
GUYS HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES. AND
THEN WE JUST HAVE TO RATION WE
JUST HAVE TO RATION THOSE
PARTIES AS WELL AS RATION
CAMPUSES SO. I HOPE THAT'S AT
LEAST- INDICATION OF SOME OF THE
INITIAL THINGS THAT WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE SPENDING THAT
SPENDING ON BUT THEN ALSO AN
INDICATION OF OTHER THINGS THT
WE WILL BE MAKING DECISIONS ARE
RARE. BUDGET. ACTIS FINALIZED.
THANK YOU SIR SO. HE WILL BE
TAKING ALL OF THESE FOR EMPLOYEE
BENEFITS FACULTY SALARY
INCREASES AN OLDER. OTHER SALARY
INCREASES IN OTHER OPERATING
COST IN CONSIDERATION OF
PRIORITIZING THE MONIES. NOW
THIS QUESTION IS FOR THE L. A.
L. BUT I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY
THAT IN YOUR OPINION- THE
GOVERNOR'S REGISTERED ACTUALLY
PRIORITIZED ONE OF THESE AREAS
FOR ITS BASE FUNDING. YOUR
QUESTION I APOLOGIZE IF I'M
MISUNDERSTANDING THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IS AND I'M PROVIDING
UNRESTRICTED BASE INCREASE OF 5%
AND SO IT'LL LAST YEAR'S YEAR
TO. USE ITS DISCRETION TO
PRIORITIZE IN THE WAYS THAT MY
COLLEAGUES JUST ARM HAS
DESCRIBED. CONDITION IS RATHER
THAN PROVIDING UNRESTRICTED
BASING CREASE. IN THE
LEGISLATURE IDENTIFY WHICH
SPECIFIC COST INCREASES SUCH AS
THE ONE DECIDED FROM YOUR AGENDA
IT WISHES TO SUPPORT. AND THEN
TALLY UP THE ASSOCIATED COSTS
PRESS BASED ON FUTURE COST
ESTIMATES AND USE THAT TO
DETERMINE THE SIZE TO BE
SUPPLEMENTATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS- SO. AB BEST TO
DATE THEY PRIORITIZE CERTAIN
AREAS THEY WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE CAN WE DO ALL OF THEM
WHEN WE CONSIDER THE BASE
FUNDING. FILL IN YOUR NINE DAY
STARTING AT THE BOTTOM AT AGE
TWENTY. THREE PROVIDED FOR
NUMBER IS THAT SATURDAY
SOMETHING IF YOU COST ESTIMATE.
FOR DOING EACH OF THOSE FOUR
EXTRA STUFF ITEMS. AND WHILE I
CAN'T GET A MENTAL MATH OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD. AND DEBT WE DID.
FIND THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED APPLICATION LEVEL. AS
TWO HUNDRED ONE MILLION FIVE
PERCENT. WOULD LIKELY BE ENOUGH
TO COVER. SAID BULLETED ITEMS AS
IT REGARDS AS IT RELATES TO
EMPLOYEE BENEFITS AND AS OTHER.
I'M COSTS BUSINESS JUST TRYING
TO FIND THINGS LIKE MAINTENANCE.
AND OPERATING EXPENSES AND
EQUIPMENT INFLATION. IT WOULD
ALSO BE ENOUGH TO COVER THAT
SALARY INCREASES INCLUDED IN THE
AGREEMENT LANDSCAPES FACULTY.
AND WE THINK THAT WOULD LIKE
LEAVE ENOUGH FOR APPROXIMATELY
THREE PER INCREASE IN SALARY FOR
OTHER NON OF. I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION BUT I'M GONNA WAIT- I
WOULD MAKE SURE I HAVE A
ANDERSON THIS BEFORE I ASK SO-
OKAY. YEAH OF GIVE THIS BACK TO
US INNER LAYER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEN. THANK YOU CHAIRED BY.
I THANK YOU CHIRLA AND- I JUST
WANT TO THE GOVERNOR FOR- THE 5%
BASING CREATES I THINK THAT IS
CRITICAL FOR US TO- PORTION- I
KIND OF THINK OF THE CSU'S IN
AND HIRE A GENERALLY IS- SUBJECT
TO THE SAME PRINCIPLES OF LOCAL
CONTROL THAT THIS LEGISLATURE.
OFTEN LOOKS TO IN ALLOCATING-
BUDGET FUNDS. IT IS CERTAINLY I
THINK THIS YES ARE BETTER
POSITIONED AND THEN. WE OR THE
GOVERNOR TO TRY TO ALLOCATE
FUNDS TO SOME OF THEIR DIFFERENT
NEEDS AND- I THINK. IT'S BEEN
AWHILE SINCE WE'VE GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT BASED INCREASE I
THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE USE OF
THESE FUNDS. MY QUESTION HERE.
AND I THINK THIS IS PROBABLY FOR
MR STORM OR SOMEONE ELSE FROM
CSU. I EASE YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT THE DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT.
I WANTED TO DRILL DOWN A LITTLE
BIT ON THAT IN AND SEE IF WE
COULD UNDERSTAND SIR WHAT WAS
CAUSING THIS AND TO WHAT DEGREE.
THAT THE CRIME WAS DRIVEN BY
SHORT TERM COVERAGE RELATED
FACTORS VERSUS LONGER TERM MORE
STRUCTURAL FACTORS. IN I GUESS I
JUST START BY ASKING DO WE HAVE
ANY DATA GENERALLY ON. LIKE WHAT
VARIABLES ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
INCREASES OR DECLINES IN
ENROLLMENT- TO MAYBE I'LL START
THERE. AND I BELIEVE THAT MR
STORM'S GOING TO HAND OUT TO
MISSION OKAY. THAT'S RIGHT THANK
YOU I THINK YOU CENTER MAN- YES-
YOU DATE SO THE INFORMATION THAT
IS IN THE AGENDA IS CERTAINLY
LOOKING AT THE AGGREGATE LEVEL
FOR THE CSU AND ALL OF OUR
CAMPUSES. BUT TO YOUR QUESTION
IN TERMS OF GETTING UNDERNEATH
THAT WE DO SEE VARIATION BY
CAMPUSES- SO FOR EXAMPLE EVEN IN
FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE- WE HAD-
AT LEAST TWO CAMPUSES THAT WERE
EITHER AT OR ABOVE. THEIR HIGH
WATER MARKS FOR ENROLLMENT IN
PRIOR YEARS SO- THE OUTCOMES ON
CAMPUSES WE SEE DO SEE VARIATION
SOME OF THAT IS GEOGRAPHIC SO
CAMPUSES THAT ARE- PERHAPS MORE
RURAL AND DEPENDED ON STUDENTS
FROM OUTSIDE THE REGION POTS AND
TO MEET THEIR ENROLLMENT NEEDS.
ARE THEIR ENROLLMENT TARGETS.
THIS A GREATER TO DOWN SOME OF
CAMPUS IN HER AND SO. AREAS THAT
. BE AND I SAY MAY BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A NOT ONLY-
INVESTIGATION IN OUR SYSTEM BUT
IN HIGHER EDUCATION WRIT LARGE-
MAYBE AND DURING THAT WINDOW OF
TIME WHERE INSTRUCTION WAS
LARGELY ONLINE THAT STUDENTS
CHOSE TO- MAKE DECISIONS TO
REMAIN CLOSER TO HOME SO CLOSER
TO POPULATION CENTERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE ALSO- AND AGAIN.
THE ACROSS CAMPUSES BUT IT'S ALL
SOME DECLINES IN AVERAGE UNIT
LOAD- IT SO WELL AS WELL WE HAD
SEEN YEAR OVER YEAR THE AVERAGE
UNIT THAT STUDENTS HAVE TAKEN-
INCREASING WHICH WAS A PART OF
OUR STRATEGY FOR GRADUATION
INITIATIVE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
GET STUDENTS. TO COMPLETION-
MORE QUICKLY- WE SAW A SLIGHT
DEEP- DEATH AND THAT AND WE SAW
SOME VARIATION BY SPECIFIC
STUDENTS SEGMENTS- AGAIN.
INVESTIGATING THAT TRYING TO
ADDRESS AND AS I MENTIONED IF
FOR EXAMPLE IN THE RE ENROLLMENT
WORK AT OUR CAMPUSES ARE DOING.
THAT'S OFTEN AT A VERY
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT- LEVEL TO
UNDERSTAND THE REASONS PERHAPS
THEY DID LEAVE THE UNIVERSITY
SO. THERE ARE A VARIETY I THINK
WHAT IS ENCOURAGING IS WHAT
WE'RE SEEING FOR FALL TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AS I MENTIONED.
APPLICATIONS FOR A FIRST TIME
STUDENTS THAT WOULD BE
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL THIS
SPRING- HAVE BOUNCED BACK. AND
AROUND 15% ACROSS THE SYSTEM- WE
AS AS BY WHAT I BELIEVE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM- OR MAYBEBOTH
FROM THE L. A. O. AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE REFERENCE- WE ARE
WATCHING CLOSELY OR IN IN CLOSE
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ABOUT. THEIR EXPERIENCE
WITH COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUSES
ACROSS THE STATE WE KNOW AND NOT
ONLY IN CALIFORNIA BUT
NATIONWIDE. THAT TWO YEAR
COLLEGES SAW THE MOST DRAMATIC
DECREASES IN ENROLLMENT AND SO-
WE'RE WORKING WITH THEM TO TRY
TO GET BETTER PROJECTIONS- BUT
ALSO TO COMMUNICATE ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY. IN. TERMS OF-
GREATER ENROLLMENT OFFER.
PROSSER SYSTEM THAT WOULD COME
WITH THIS WITH THE- THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL. THANKS FOR A QUICK
FOLLOW AND MAYBE THE STRAP WITH
MORNING ENGLISH- YOU KNOW HOW
WHEN I LOOK AT. THE- THAT THE
DECLINE IN. AT BOTH COMING
COLLEGES AND CSU. I GUESS IT.
BACKS WERE OF WHICH IS YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ARE STAYING HOME MORE AND
MAYBE. MORE RELUCTANT TO GO JOIN
A VIRTUAL CLASSROOM ENVIRONMENT
WHO WANTS TO GO TO SCHOOL LET
ALONE A VIRTUAL SCHOOL RIGHT-
BUT ALTERNATIVELY YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE KIND OF IN THE SECOND YEAR
OF WHAT IS A VERY INTERESTING
LABOR MARKET. AND IT IS
CERTAINLY THE LAST I'D SAY SIX
MONTHS TO YEAR WE'VE SEEN A VERY
TIGHT LABOR MARKET WITH EVER
INCREASING WAGES I WAS DRIVING
BY AND IN AND OUT THE OTHER DAY
AND I SAW. A SIGN FOR TWENTY.
MAY NOT AS- NOTHING MAYBE I
SHOULD TAKE A PART. JOB BECAUSE
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD WAGES- CANNOT
. AFTER WE HAVE ALL TEN BUDGET
HERE FAIR ENOUGH. HI I WAS YOU
KNOW JUST KIND OF WONDERING- YOU
KNOW TO WHAT DEGREE
HISTORICALLY. MAYBE BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE THE COVERT SPECIFIC
DID I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY TO.
NAY SENT ITS TO RECENT. BUT YOU
KNOW PRESUMABLY YOU GUYS HAVE A
SENSE OF LIKE WHAT HAPPENS
DURING RECESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
BOOMS. I IT'S BEEN AWHILE SINCE
WE HAD A TIGHT LABOR MARKET BUT
DO WE TEND TO SEE DECLINES IN
ENROLLMENT OR BOARD. NO IMPACTS
ARE ONE OF THE FACTS OF. THESE
TYPES OF TIGHT LABOR MARKETS ON
ENROLLMENT AT CSU'S. SACRAMENTO
WONDERFUL QUESTION AND
ABSOLUTELY THERE IS A
CORRELATION I'M TRADITIONALLY
WITH. THE LABOR SITUATION AND
THE ECONOMY I'M PARTICULARLY.
FOR AT THE TRANSFER STUDENT
POPULATION AND POST BACK- THAT
INDIVIDUALS MAY CHOOSE NOT. TO
EAT TO EITHER DELAY. OR TO STOP
OUT. I'M IN THOSE STUDENT
CATEGORIES WHEN THERE IS A VERY
TIGHT LABOR MARKET BECAUSE
THOSE- THE COST BENEFIT. IN THE
MARK DATA DELAYED MARKET TIME.
YOU TEARS YOUR AND DRIVING. AND
TRYING TO DO THE HARD. I DON'T.
MANY OF THE PRINCIPLES THAT WE
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT IN IN
SORT OF ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT
HAVE SORT OF FLYING OUT THE
WINDOW DURING THE PANDEMIC I
DON'T THINK THAT'S JUST FOR THE
CSU I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
CERTAINLY SEEING AND HEARING
THAT FROM. OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
UNIVERSITIES AND INSTITUTIONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY- YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE AS I MENTIONED WE
ACTUALLY BUCKED THE NATIONAL
TREND IN THE PRECEDING FALL THE
FIRST BALL OF THE PANDEMIC AND
ACTUALLY HAD RECORDS CSU
ENROLLMENT AND I ACTUALLY SAW
INCREASES IN TRANSFER STUDENTS.
AT A TIME WHEN THEN- THERE WERE
SIGNIFICANT LAYOFFS AND SO NOT
EVERYTHING WAS LINING UP AS IT
S IT MAY HAVE BEEN IN OTHER.
OKAY RECESSIONS AND DURING A
VERY STRONG ECONOMIC TIMES AND
LABOR MARKET SO. IT'S A LITTLE
IT'S A LITTLE DIFFICULT TO READ.
WHAT THE IMMEDIATE IMPACT WILL
BE BUT CERTAINLY FOR CERTAIN
STUDENT POPULATIONS THAT- A
CRITICAL IS A TRANSFER STUDENTS
AND POST BACCALAUREATE STUDENTS.
THEY'RE THEY'RE- WEIGHING BACK
COST BENEFIT OF GOING INTO THE
LABOR MARKET IS SOMETHING THAT
MAY BE OF HIGHER. IMPORTANCE
RIGHT NOW. SO FINAL QUESTION FOR
YOU- WE SUPPOSE THAT WE ARE
GETTING THIS WRONG A LITTLE BIT
AND AT LEAST FOR LIKE THE NEXT
FEW YEARS WE'RE GOING TO SEE A-
DECLINE IN ENROLLMENT BEYOND
WHAT WE'RE- PROJECTING RIGHT
NOW. WILL BE THE IMPACT
STRUCTURALLY ON YOUR BUDGET- AND
WHAT WOULD THAT IMPLY FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AS FAR AS WHERE WE
SHOULD DIRECT RESOURCES DURING
WHAT IS A- YOU KNOW. AN UNUSUAL
SECULAR HI HERE AS FAR AS OUR
BUDGET SITUATION. ANOTHER IS
WHAT WHICH WE SPEND THIS MONEY.
ASSEMBLY WANNA HELP THE CSU'S-
YOU KNOW PROP UP THINGS. BUT
ASSUMING ALSO THAT WHEN THEY SEE
MAYBE FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS-
DECLINES IN ENROLLMENTS WHAT
WHAT IS THE BEST BANG FOR THE
BUCK. WELL IF I COULD TAKE THAT-
I THINK ONE THING I NEED TO STEP
BACK AND- EXPLAIN SOMETHING
FIRST SENATOR SO WE CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW ENROLLMENT WORKS
FUNDAMENTALLY FROM A BUDGETARY
PERSPECTIVE. SO SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE CSU. THERE'S
BEEN THIS CONTRACT ESSENTIALLY
BETWEEN THE C. ISSUE IN STATE.
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT HAPPENED
FOR MANY DECADES AND ABOUT A
COUPLE DECADES AGO THIS MODEL
WAS A LITTLE BIT OF JUSTICE BUT
THE IDEA WAS THAT. FOR EVERY
STUDENT THAT WE ADD WORK EDUCATE
WE WOULD RECEIVE FUNDING FROM
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO
EDUCATE. IN OVER THE LAST SIX
DECADES WE HAVE INCREMENTALLY
RECEIVED FUNDING FROM THE STATE
TO EDUCATE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
STUDENTS AND THAT'S CALLED WHAT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ALL OF
US WHO ARE ON THE PANEL HERE
TALKING ABOUT OUR FUNDED
ENROLLMENT FOR OUR ROLE THAT
TARGETS SO RIGHT NOW WE ARE
FUNDED AT THIS LEVEL RIGHT NOW
TO EDUCATE. THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED FORTY SIX FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS NOW YOU HAVE
A PROPOSAL ON THE TABLE HERE
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION THAT.
WAS LINKED TO AN AGREEMENT LAST
YEAR THAT SAID HEY C. ISSUE
YOU'RE GONNA EDUCATE AND WE'RE
GONNA GIVE YOU THE FUNDING
EDUCATE. NINE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR. MORE
STUDENTS THERE'S A THERE'S A
PROBLEM NOW WITH THIS AND WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT THE F.
ING WORLD IT DIPS OKAY WHAT IF
IT ACTUALLY DOES. WELL AS YOU
KNOW AND AS MY COLLEAGUE DR
EVANS WOULD SAY. ENROLLMENT
MANAGEMENT IS BOTH AN ART AND A
SCIENCE WE'RE GONNA BE TIMES
WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE
STUDENTS THAT ARE GOING TO TAKE
YOUR OFFER TO BE ADMITTED TO
UNIVERSITY AND THERE ARE OTHER
TIMES ARE GOING TO BE BELOW THAT
. RIGHT NOW THERE MIGHT BE YOU
KNOW THEORETICALLY THERE MIGHT
BE A DEBT. IN TERMS OF STUDENTS
WHO WANTED TO BE AT EDUCATED AT
THE C. ISSUE. NOW WHEN IT COMES
TO OUR TARGET IN WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW WE'RE REALLY PRETTY
WHAT WERE WHAT. AT THIS POINT WE
ARE AT ONE OF THE CLOSEST POINTS
WE'VE THEN IN TERMS OF OUR
ACTUAL ROLE WITH. TO OUR FUNDED
TARGET. SO I THINK IT'S JUST A
THREE OR FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS
FOR ME IF I'M WRONG IN. MY
COLLEAGUES NODDING HIS HEAD. SO
WE'RE PRETTY CLOSE TO BEING
RIGHT OUT THAT OPTIMAL NOW. NOW
HERE'S THE CRYSTAL BALL PARK
THAT'S DIFFICULT. DO YOU ADD
THIS ADDITIONAL EIGHTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ORDER FOR US
TO EDUCATE MORE AND DO WE ARE WE
GET HAVE THAT STRONG OF. A
DEMAND FROM THE STUDENTS TO BE
EDUCATING THEM THAT'S A TOUGH
CALL TO MAKE BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU
SEE ON THE TRANSFER SIDE- WORST
SIR ARE NOT AS ROBUSTLY. SEEKING
TO ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY. NOW IF
YOU DO DECIDE ULTIMATELY SAY
WELL LET'S LET'S LET'S BACK OFF
DISAGREEMENTS LET'S
HYPOTHETICALLY. YOU COULD
REDIRECT SOME OF THAT FUNDING TO
OTHER THINGS LIKE GRADUATION
THIS YEAR. SO YEAH WHILE IT
MIGHT NOT BE A HUMONGOUS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FOR OUR
CAMPUSES. I ANTICIPATED. YOU
COULD HAVE A GUARANTEE THAT
THERE WILL BE MONEY THAT WILL BE
DEDICATED TO GRAB CHIPS THE
CURRENT LOT OF STUDENTS SO THAT
THEY CAN GET JUST ALL THE
COURSES THEY NEED TO DO THAT.
BUT AS FOR OUR PLANNING GOES
WE'RE MARCHING FORWARD WITH THE
IDEA THAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
BUT MEASURES TO PROPOSALS
ENACTED. THAT WE WILL BE GROWING
ARE LED BY THAT NINE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR.
STUDENTS AND WE DO HAVE
PRELIMINARY ALLOCATIONS TO ALL A
NOT ALL BUT SEVERAL OF OUR
CAMPUSES. AND THEY'RE PLANNING
TO GROW BY THAT- AND SO THAT'S
WHY THE LATE LANDED NOW YOU DO
HAVE SO OPTIONS AND I THINK MISS
KING AS AS- ARTICULATED PRETTY
CLEARLY THAT YOU KNOW MAYBE
MAYBE THERE'S THIS IDEA THAT IF
YOU WANTED TO YOU COULD MAKE AT
HOME A TARGET. YOU KNOW FOR
BUDGET YOUR PLUS ONE JUST
BECAUSE OF THE SOFT THE SOFTNESS
OF THE MOMENT RIGHT NOW- BUT-
OBVIOUSLY WE WOULD WE WOULD WE
WOULD DO IT EITHER WAY JUST
DEPENDS ON ON. ON WHAT YOU'RE
DECISIONS WERE BUT- YOU
OBVIOUSLY YEAH I CAN- I MOVE OFF
OF THAT NINETY FOUR HUNDRED IF
YOU CHOSE BUT IT WOULD CREATE A
RECALL FOR US BECAUSE WE HAVE
ALREADY INDICATED OVER CAMPUSES
THEY SHOULD GO FOR THAT. WE
SHOULD BE GOING FOR THAT KIND OF
BUILDING GROSS BUT- BUT THERE
ARE CERTAIN STEPS THERE ARE
SOME. NUANCES LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
DR EVANS. TALKING ABOUT. THANK
YOU RIGHT MR TRUMP. THANK YOU OF
SENATOR MEN AND- THAT COMPLETES-
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ON OF
. FOUR ON ISSUE THREE IN ORDER
TO MOVE TO ISSUE FOR BUT LET ME
JUST SAY WE HAVE TWO MORE ISSUES
AND THEN WE HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
WE HAVE A HARD STOP BY NOON SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO THESE NEXT
TWO ISSUES IN A WAY THAT WE CAN
ALLOW SOME. TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
ISSUE NUMBER FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY- WE WILL HAVE RYAN
STORM AGAIN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSITY WILL HAVE
A OUR VIRUS AS OF SAN JUAN FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY BUT
I DID NOTE THAT THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER REFERRED TO HER AS VICE
AND ONE SO. WHAT WILL ALLOW HER
TO. ANSWER TO WHATEVER SHE
ANSWERS TO THEM THEN WILL GO TO
JENNIFER LOUIS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIALLY
SECURING FROM THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND WE'RE GOING
TO GO IN THAT ORDER AND WE'LL
BEGIN WITH MR STORE. FIVE FOR
BREVITY I'VE DEFERRED MY
COMMENTS- IN AND ALLOW. PASS I'M
SORRY BY SAN JUAN PROVIDE OUR
COMMENTS THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU
WE APPRECIATE THAT RECORD
SETTING PROPERTY ARE WILL MOVE
DEVICE AND ONE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CARE LAYERED AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING STILL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ONE TIME
FUNDING A ONE HUNDRED MILLION TO
ADDRESS THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG. GIVEN THE EVER GROWING
BACKLOG THE CSU TAKES A MULTI
PRONGED STRATEGY TO ADDRESS
PRIORITY PROJECTS REQUESTED BY
TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES. THE
AGENDA NOTE THE FIVE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR BACKLOG WHICH WE
BELIEVE IS ARTIFICIALLY HIGH AS
OUR- FUNDED PROJECTS THAT ARE
NOT YET COMPLETED. THEY NEED TO
BE UPDATED IN OUR ANNUAL
DATABASE HOWEVER OUR PROGRESS IN
FUNDING PROJECTS IS BEING ERODED
BY THE MORE THAN THIRTEEN
PERCENT. COST INFLATION
EXPERIENCE THIS LAST YEAR AND IT
IS STILL OCCURRING AT JUST 1% AT
JUST UNDER 1% FOR THE MONTH OF
JANUARY. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
WAYS TO SEE IF YOU WORKS TO
REDUCE THE BACKLOG. ONE THE
TRUSTEES USE CAPITAL FUNDS TO
RENOVATE OR REPLACE EXISTING
FACILITIES. THESE FOR THE
FACILITY HAVE A NUMBER OF AGE
SYSTEMS AND THE FULL RENOVATION.
AND ENABLES A COMPREHENSIVE
ANNUAL. UPSET OUR CAPITAL
PROGRAM IS THE SECOND METHOD IF
DEVELOPED INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM HIS PROJECT
THE VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
FUNDING DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THERE'S USUALLY AN IMPROVEMENT
OUR BETTERMENT COMPONENT. TO THE
IN INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
AND EVERY CAMPUS TYPICALLY GET
FUNDED WHEN WE GET CAPITAL FUND
. THE THIRD APPROACH IS TO
ADDRESS A BROAD BACKLOG IS TO
REQUEST DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
FUNDING FROM THE STATE. SUCH AS
A HUNDRED MILLION PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. AND THEN
FOR THE CAMPUS LEASE OPERATING
FUNDS TO KING LATER A RESERVE IT
DOESN'T THAT DOESN'T NEEDED
MAINTENANCE RESERVE OR
IMPROVEMENT RESERVE. ACCOMPLISH
THE PROJECT. WITH THE SUPPORT OF
THE LEGISLATURE
INTEREST EARNINGS HAVE BEEN USED
TO FUND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS AND THIS LAST YEAR THE
EMAIL TOTAL FIFTY FIVE MILLION
FROM INTEREST EARNINGS. AND THE
LAST IS THE- PENDING NEW
BUILDING. I AM TORMENT THAT'S A
COMPONENT OF OUR OFFER BUDGET
REQUEST AND A COUPLE YEARS BACK
WE WENT FROM ABOUT ELEVEN
DOLLARS PER SQUARE FOOT. ABOUT
TWENTY BASED ON WHAT CAMPUS ARE
ACTUALLY OF FUNDING FOR
MAINTENANCE OF PLANT. SO THAT
THERE'S NO EASY ANSWER ON THE
BACKLOGS OF STRATEGIES RELY ON A
REOCCURRING BASIS FUNDS FOR
CAPITAL FINANCING OR PATIENT CO.
SUCH AS A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE MILLION IN THE CSU
OPERATING BUDGET REQUESTS FOR
BUILDINGS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR WE STICK
WITH THE ONE TIME FUNDS. WHERE
THE GOVERNOR INCLUDES INCLUDES A
HUNDRED MILLION IN HIS BUDGET
THE REQUESTED ONE BILLION IN THE
TRUSTEE'S REQUEST. TO SEE IF YOU
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE FUNDING
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE LOADING.
SUPPORT THE ECONOMIC PROGRAM AND
PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS TACKLING
STAFF THE SAFE AND FUNCTIONAL
ENVIRONMENT SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS WILL MOVE ON TO
JENNIFER. LOUIS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH S. SENATOR AND
MEMBERS- AS MENTIONED EARLIER A
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DOES PROVIDE TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
THREE MILLION A ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND. OF WHICH A HUNDRED
MILLION. IS DEDICATED TO
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND ENERGY
EFFICIENCY PROJECTS. EIGHTY
THREE MILLION FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE CEASE YOUR
BAKER STILL ENERGY PATIENTS
CENTER AND FIFTY MILLION TOWARD
SUPPORTING UNIVERSITY FARMS. AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I AM
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
FURTHER DTAILS. THANK YOU AND
THEN WILL MOVE TO LISA CAME FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
. INDIA MANY IN THE PAST WE
THINK DIFFERENT MAINTENANCE ARE
PRUDENT USE OF ONE TIME FUNDS AS
IT HELPS ADDRESS ISSUES EXISTING
BACKLOG AND POTENTIALLY AVOID IT
COSTS DOWN IT SAYS HE PLANNED
EMERGENCY REPAIRS AND SO FORTH.
WHEN USING ONE TIME MONEY FOR
THIS PURPOSE THOUGH IS THAT IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING CAUSES. WALKER
BACKLOGS TEND TO EMERGE WHEN ON
AND ON BASIS CAMPUSES ARE NOT
SETTING ASIDE ENOUGH FUNDING
FROM THEIR SUPPORT BUDGETS FOR
MAINTENANCE AND RENEWAL
ACTIVITIES. CONTACTS YOU SEE WAS
ASKED ME AT ITS CAMPUSES WE NEED
TO SPEND A COMBINED TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR MILLION ANNUALLY
OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS. IN
ORDER DRAFT MAINTENANCE AND
RENEWAL NEEDS AND KEEP THE
BACKLOGFROM GROWING. AND THIS
IS SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN ITS
ESTIMATED TO CURRENTLY BE
SPENDING. HI WITH THIS IN MIND%
WE WOULD RECOMMEND YOU CONSIDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS A
STARTING POINT. WE WOULD
RECOMMEND PROVIDING THE ONE TIME
FUNDS AS A HUNDRED MILLION AS
POST. BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME FUNDING
COMES AVAILABLE YOU COULD
CONSIDER PROVIDING EVEN MORE.
AND AT THE SAME TIME WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO BEGIN
THINKING ABOUT A LONG TERM
STRATEGY TO ADDRESS ISSUES
ONGOING MAINTENANCE AND RENEWAL
NEEDS. SO THAT THE BACKLOG
DOESN'T CONTINUE TO GROW YEAR
AFTER YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THEN LET ME. GO TO MY
COLLEAGUES FIRST AND SEE IF
THERE'S A QUESTION FROM EITHER A
SENATOR ROACH- BUG. I WOULD I'M
JUST. INTRIGUED ABOUT YOUR
COMMENT IN WHICH THE BACKLOG- IT
HOW IT INCREASES OVER TIME. WHAT
WOULD BE SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU WOULD
HAVE IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE I DO WANT TO DO SOMETHING
STATUTORILY OR IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT. WE JUST. GUIDE ME ON OUR
GUIDE US ON THAT ON THAT POINT.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. WE
BASIS THERE ARE BUILDING SYSTEMS
OF THE CAMPUS SAYS THAT ARE
REACHING THE END OF THEIR USEFUL
LIFE AND IN ORDER TO PREVENT THE
BACKLOG FROM GROWING CAMPUSES
NEED TO ON AN ONGOING BASIS
SPEND MONEY TERROR WHEN YOU WANT
TO PLACE THIS. THE SYSTEM
COMPONENTS. BECAUSE THAT WOULD
BE AMOUNT OF THE COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS ACTIVITY WE THINK THAT
IT WOULD TAKE SIGNIFICANT
PLANNING FOR THE STATE. TO
DEVELOP A STRATEGY TO ADDRESS
THESE NEEDS. IN ABOUT A WEEK FOR
THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL BE SHARING
A SIMILAR ITEM FOR YOU SEE AND I
THINK YOU'RE A VERY SIMILAR
STORY WITH PERHAPS EVEN LARGER
NUMBERS BACK. THROUGH
LEGISLATURE TO ENGAGE IN THIS
LONG TERM PLANNING. SB ONTO THE
SCOPE OF THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE BUDGET THIS IS
SOMETHING WE COULD WORK WITH
YOUR STAFF TO FURTHER EXPLORE IN
THE FALL FOR EXAMPLE. AND IN
THAT FOR THE EXPIRATION. SOME
QUESTIONS HE COULD CONSIDER
INCLUDE. BUT FUND SOURCES FIRST
THESE ON NEED. WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE AND- OF THOSE FUNDS. AND
WHAT REPORTING REQUIREMENTS YOU
MIGHT WANT TO IMPLANT INSURE
THAT ANY ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATIONS ARE HAVING TO
INTENDED EFFECT. I HOPE THAT
HELPS WITH SOME OF THE INITIAL
CONSIDERATIONS AND- WE EXPECT
WOULD LIKELY BE ACTED PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT PLANNING PROCESS TO
ADDRESS THIS NEED. SIGNIFICANT
IN DAY AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE FOR YOUR COMMENTS. FROM
SENATOR MEANT. YES SEVEN COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR CSU- FIRST THAT
YEAH I THINK THIS IS IN A REPORT
AND WE CAN REITERATE IT OUT WHAT
IS THE SIZE OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE AND INFRASTRUCTURE
HOLE UP THAT ACROSS THE CSU
SYSTEM ACCORDING YOUR ESTIMATES. I WOULD AFFECT BASED ON
INFLATION SOMEWHERE BETWEEN FOUR
POINT SIXTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN THE BACKLOG GUYS SO THIS IS
THIS IS REALLY A DROP IN THE
BUCKET AND HOW MUCH OF THAT IS
SHOVEL READY LIKE THAT. THAT
COULD BE STARTED RIGHT AWAY. BUT
WE'VE WE'VE PUT TOGETHER A LIST
OF ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS. FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
WE WOULD TRY TO MOVE TO THOSE TO
CONSTRUCTION ON THOSE OF QUICK
AS WE CAN. BUT I WOULDN'T SAY
THEY'RE ALL SHOVEL READY. OKAY
SO BILLION WOULD LIKE. GIVE ME A
TIME WHEN THEY COULD BE STARTED
NEXT YEAR OR WOULD BE LONGER
THAN THAT. IF YOU START IN THE
NEXT YEAR. GOT IT AND THEN I
GUESS MY QUESTION FOR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE OR L. A- IS IT RIGHT
MY UNDERSTOOD THAT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE DOES NOT COUNT
AGAINST AGAIN LIMIT. I EIGHT
ANYONE HAS THE EXPERTISE TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION. YEP MY
QUESTION SENATOR. YES CURRENTLY
IS A MINISTRATION IS TREATING
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AS AN
EXCLUSION FROM THE GAMELAN FROM
FEDERAL AND ANY FUNDS PROVIDED
FOR THIS PURPOSE WHICH WOULD NOT
COUNT TOWARD THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS THE NEXT. TO ANY
YEAR WHERE WE ARE GOING TO BE
WELL OVER AGAIN LIMIT THIS WOULD
SEEM LIKE A VERY PRUDENT USE OF
FUNDS AND SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION. YEAH WHICH HELP
CONTINUE TO RAISE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND OTHERS THIS IS WHY
NOT TAKE MORE OF THIS SURPLUS
FUNDING PRETTY SINCE IT DOESN'T
COUNT AGAINST AGAIN LIMIT AND
USE IT TOWARDS THIS TYPE OF
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. AND
WASTE A LOT OF CALIFORNIANS
VALUES ON- YOU KNOW GETTING TO
ZERO EMISSIONS I IN WAYS THAT-
HELP TO RESTORE- ONE OF THE
CROWN. JEWELS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. HI THE WORK FOR OF ED
I THINKING. THIS SEEMS LIKE A
VERY. USE OF FUNDS AND I WAS OUT
FRANKLY DISAPPOINTED TO SEE SUCH
A LOW NUMBER I FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE HERE. THANK YOU-
THAT COMPLETE YOUR COMMENTS WERE
MADE JUST SAY THAT- THAT OUT A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS THEY WERE
ASKED BY MY COLLEAGUES SO I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND WE WILL
JUST LOOK AT THIS. AS IT MOVES
TOWARD A MAY AND JUST REPEAT.
THE WHOLE NOTION THAT THIS MAY
WELL BE A BUDGET THAT. ARE THAT
IS ABLE TO DO SOME GOOD THINGS
THAT ARE ONE TIME EXPENDITURES
AND SOME OF THIS WOULD BE A
LOGICAL THING FOR THAT AND THAT-
CENTER MEN'S ADMONITION ABOUT
THE GAM LIMIT WAS VERY
APPROPRIATE SO. WE'LL JUST LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING MORE THAT IS
IN THE MAY REVISE. OUR WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO OUR LAST ISSUE.
WHICH IS STUDENT HOUSING UPDATE
SENATE'S RYAN STORM FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY OF
AYE SAN JUAN FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. AND THEN
REBEKAH KIRK FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND WE WILL GO IN
THAT ORDER AND START WITH RAIN
STORM. YEAH I ASK MY COLLEAGUE
BY SEN WANT TO MINOR COM. YOU
BROKE YOUR- RECORD FOR BREVITY
SO WE WILL MOVE ON TO A VICE AND
WON'T. EARLIER THIS IS YOUR
PREACH THE PRECIADO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES
ACCEPTANCE VERY BY SUBMITTAL FOR
THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM. OUR
REGIONAL TO MIDDLE THOUGHT 1100%
GRANT FUNDING AND AFTER WE
LEARNED WE READ. READ THIS READ
THE PROGRAM GUIDELINES WE RAN
MULTIPLE FINANCIAL PLANS IN
ORDER TO ROUTE SUBMIT REVISED
DOCUMENT JUST LAST WEEK
PROPOSING PROJECTS WITH 65%
GRANT FUNDING. AND 35% CSU CO
FUNDING. WE SUBMITTED TEN
PROJECTS FUNDED THROUGH A MIX OF
THESE TWO SOURCES. AND ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
MILLION WE'RE SEEKING GRANT
PROGRAM FUNDING. THE SCOPE OF
THE PROJECT STAYED THE SAME THE
CHANGE WITHOUT THE CO FUNDING TO
STRETCH THE STATE HOUSING GRANTS
BY LOWERING THE COST. PER BED.
FROM THE GRANT AND ECO FUNDING
ALSO ENABLED US TO SUBMIT
ADDITIONAL PROJECT FOR
CONSIDERATION IF YOU SACRAMENTO.
WE WENT FROM NINE PROJECTS
SUBMITTED TO TEN. FIFTY TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO CSU TARGET APPROPRIATION OF
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION. IS
INCREASED TO A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY MILLION AND- ALSO SIXTY
SIX. BECAUSE AT FOUR CAN'T. IF
FORTY NINETEEN MILLION AS FUNDED
WHICH EXCEEDS THE FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION TO YOUR TARGET BUDGET
422-000-2120 TWO AND TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY NINTH AFFORDABLE BEDS
WOULD BE CONSTRUCTED AT EIGHT
CAMPUSES. WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
CAMPUS IS ON THE POTENTIAL FOR
THIRD YEAR THE PROGRAM. AND SEEK
GREATER FLEXIBILITY IN THE
PROGRAM GUIDELINES TO INCLUDE
THE SILLY RENOVATIONS IN
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT USE
EXISTING AVAILABLE HELPING FACE.
TO MAKE THEM IMMEDIATELY
ACCESSIBLE TO LOW INCOME
STUDENTS. BUT THE ISSUE IS JUST
STARTING THE PROCESS TO FURTHER
DEVELOP OUR STUDENTS HELPING
PLAN TO COMPLY WITH NEW
REQUIREMENTS IN THE EDUCATION
CODE FROM AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. WILL BE CONDUCTING A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT BY CAMPUS THAT
PROJECTS UP 222-000-2620 SEVEN.
THEY TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
PROJECTED ENROLLMENT GROWTH OR
CHANGES AND THE GOAL TO CLOSE
THE DEGREE GAP. WORK WILL
INCLUDE CANVASES WILL MEET
PROJECTED HOUSING NEED BY
INCLUDING ANY STATE HOUSING
GRANTS OR CSE FUNDING IS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ACADEMIC
AND STUDENT AFFAIRS IN THE CSU.
WE ANTICIPATE THE PLAN WILL
INCLUDE SPECIAL POPULATIONS.
SUCH AS THOSE NEEDING EMERGENCY
SHELTER OR RAPID RE HOUSING. AND
FOSTER YOU. THE FIRST REPORT IS
DUE JULY TWENTY TWO AND THEN
EVERY THREE YEARS THEREAFTER.
CANCELAR ANXIOUSLY FORWARD WITH
POTENTIAL GRANT PROJECTS GIVEN
THE CONTINUED COST ESCALATION.
AND FIFTY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM THANK YOU AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU AND THEN WE'LL GO TO
REBEKAH KIRK OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. THANK YOU REBECCA
KIRK FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE WERE PLEASED TO SEE
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
OF COURSE ESTABLISHED THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM TO INCREASE THE STOCK OF
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING. AT
UC CSU AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THE PROGRAM STATUTE
APPROPRIATED FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY ONE
SORRY IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO. WHICH INCLUDED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
PLANNING GRANTS TO THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE S.
IT ALSO INCLUDED INTENT LANGUAGE
FOR APPROPRIATIONS OF SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
IN THE SUBSEQUENT TO FISCAL
YEARS REPRESENTING A TOTAL OF
TWO BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
THREE YEAR PERIOD. THE TWENTY
TWENTY TO GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
FOR THE SECOND YEAR
APPROPRIATION TOWARD THE PLANS
TWO BILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
PROGRAM. WE RECEIVED AS NOTED IN
YOUR AGENDA ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN
APPLICATIONS IN THE INITIAL
FILING AROUND. REQUESTING MORE
THAN THREE POINT TWO BILLION IN
STATE FUNDING. THE NEXT STEP FOR
THIS PROGRAM IS THAT BY MARCH
FIRST TE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WILL PROVIDE THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WITH A LIST OF PROJECTS PROPOSED
FOR INCLUSION IN THE BUDGET ACT
OR OTHER LEGISLATION. FROM THAT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR. ONE NOTE THAT I WOULD
MENTION IS THAT ALTHOUGH THE
STATUTE ESTABLISHES PERCENTAGE
SHARES FOR EACH OF THE SEGMENTS.
SPECIFICALLY 50% FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES 30% FOR THE
CSU AND 20% FOR THE UC. THOSE
PERSONS SEGMENT SHARES APPLIED
TO THE OVERALL TWO BILLION
ENVISIONED OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD. AND NOT NECESSARILY TO
EACH INDIVIDUAL YEAR'S
APPROPRIATION LEVEL. HAPPY TO
ADDRESS THE QUESTION THANK YOU
THANK YOU OF I'M GOING TO JUST
MAKE A COMMENT. AT THE BEGINNING
HERE AND THAT IS I SPOKE TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WEEK YESTERDAY
AND THEN MAP WITH A NUMBER OF
TRUSTEES AFTERWARDS. AND THEY
WERE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
AMOUNT FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
I'VE TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT AND
SOME OF THE REGENTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ABOUT
IT AND WE HAVE CSU HERE. AND THE
INTERESTING THING IS THAT OF
THIS PROGRAM IS OVER SUBSCRIBED
ALREADY AND IT'S IN ITS FIRST
YEAR AND THERE IS A BIG DEMAND
AS I MOVED TO THE DISTRICT
AROUND THE STATE DURING THE
INTERIM. THE WHOLE LEVEL OF
HOUSING AND SECURITY AT THE
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM WAS
PHENOMENAL AND SO. I REALLY
APPRECIATE CSU PAWNING REALLY
APPRECIATE THE MAXIMIZING
WHATEVER THEY CAN GET AND I KNOW
THERE WAS A BLIP AND SORT OF HOW
THIS UNFOLDED. AT CSU AND I JUST
HOPE AS WE WORK THROUGH ALL
THREE BRANCHES AND GET REPORTS
JUST LIKE THIS FROM THE OTHER
TWO BRANCHES. THAT THE FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT WILL REALLY ASSESS-
BECAUSE A ANECDOTE I HEARD THERE
WERE THREE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS OF APPLICATIONS FOR WHAT
IS TWO BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS AND THAT SNAP. AND
SO I WOULD HOPE THE FINANCE
DEPARTMENT WOULD TAKE A LOOK AT.
THE AMOUNT IT'S BEEN APPLIED FOR
WHETHER IT HAS SOME VALIDITY.
WHETHER THIS INDICATES ARE OF. A
DEMAND IT'S MUCH GREATER THAN-
MONEY THAT'S AVAILABLE AND
ALLOWS US TO ADDRESS THIS MAY
REVISED IN A WAY THAT WE HAVE
THE FACTS IN FRONT OF US SO- I
APPRECIATE THE REPORT. WONDER
WHY THAT OUT THEN ONE TO ASK IF
EITHER OF MY COLLEAGUES HAD ANY
QUESTIONS NON FROM- FROM THEM SO
WE JUST KNOW MY COMMENTS I
APPRECIATE. OF THE TESTIMONY ON
THIS AND I APPRECIATE EVERYBODY
THAT HAS BEEN A PANELIST. OF LOS
FOUR. ARE WE ARE ARE NOW THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO PUBLIC. AND IT
CAN BE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ANY OF
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
FRONT OF US RELATING TO THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
COMMISSION AS I SAID EARLIER WE
HAVE A HARD STOP AT. AT NOON-
BOMB TO REMIND YOU TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE. THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN
THREE SIX EIGHT. A. 283-373-6283
THREE AND IT'S ON THE SCREEN
RIGHT NOW UNDER IT JUST. BEFORE
I TALK ABOUT LIMITS- AND ASK IF
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THE HEARING
ROOM WISHES TO TESTIFY ON THIS.
SEEING NEITHER OF THE SERGEANTS
THAT SEEM TO BE MOVED TO
TESTIMONY OF WE WILL GO TO THE
CONFERENCE LINE AND- I'M NOT
GONNA ANNOUNCE A LIMIT AND TELL
THE PERSON ON THE CON FOR THE
OPERATOR TELLS ME HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE IN THE QUEUE SO LET'S
GO TO THE- ARAFAT TO THE
MODERATOR WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND DON'T WANT YOU Q.
PEOPLE OFTEN AND TELL US WHERE
WE ARE WHEN YOU DO THAT. THANK
YOU MISTER REAGAN GENTLEMAN TO
EXPRESS PUBLIC COMMENT OVER THE
TELEPHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
AGAIN THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. USING THE TONES ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
ELEVEN LINES IN Q. THAT USUALLY
DOUBLES- SO LET'S DO THIS HE
WILL HAVE THAT HARD STOP NEAR
KNOWN AND IF IT DOUBLES WE COULD
ACCOMMODATE A MINUTE FROM EVERY
PERSON SO- FOURTH WE WILL ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GO UP TO A MINUTE AND
WE WANT YOUR NAME AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND THEN YOUR
OPINION AND I WANT TO LET
EVERYBODY KNOW IN CASE IT TURNS
OUT THERE SIXTY PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO TESTIFY. THAT WE WILL TAKE
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR YOUR
COMMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE IN
WRITING AFTERWARDS OR OR TO
SUPPLEMENT WHAT YOU SY FOR A
WEEK AND YOU CAN GET THE CONTACT
INFO FROM THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
ARE WITH THAT- MODERATOR- WHAT
BEGAN. THANK YOU WE'LL THE FIRST
TIME LINE. SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRED LAYERED
SENATOR JOSHUA HAGEN POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THEIR CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY WILL
PROVIDING PUBLIC TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE CAL GRANT PARK
WOULD BE GREAT. WE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS YEAR TO BUILD
ON TREMENDOUS PROGRESS THAT WAS
MADE LAST YEAR AND POLICE SIMPLE
I CAL GRANT PROFIT GREATLY
EXPANDING THE STUDENTS TO GET
ABOUT. I'D LIKE TO YOU THE
LETTER. THE GOVERNOR METERS AND
ACTUALLY LAST YEAR. FOR COMBAT
LEVINE WATER A HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND GIVE AWARDS LOW INCOME
. COLLEGE STUDENTS. EXPANDING
AFTER FINANCIAL AID AS WELL OF
THE MOST. POLICY MODERATE THE
BAILABLE THE FULLY ARE DROPPED
THE DOCTOR NICK. OF OUR WITH BIG
. THANK OF THEM SOME THEY NEED
COOPER. GOAL SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
TO THE RACIAL ISSUE SIMPLE
POINTED CAL GRANT REMOVING
RATIONING MECHANISMS FOR EIGHTY
WILL PROVIDE ESTIMATED A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS WITH FINANCIAL AID. THE
MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE BLACK AND
WHITE NECK. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
PRIORITIZING EXPANDED ACCESS TO
THE PROGRAM LAST YEAR WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR LEADERSHIP
AGAIN THIS YEAR THE BOOK BY THE
CAL GRANT PROCESS. TO KEEP THE
CULPRIT THANK YOU FOR CALLING
THREE BEFORE DOUBLE FOR
GENERATIONS THE PUBLIC. PARKING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMON- MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER.
LINE TWENTY ONE. IN MY LEAD AND
NUMBERS MY NAME IS A GRAND OFF
GET YOU KEEP CRUZ I'M HERE TODAY
AT OF THE THING FINANCIAL
COLLISION THANK YOU FOR YOUR CAN
SUPPORT OF OUR STUDENTS AND YOUR
COMMITMENT FOR ABOUT A NEW BOOK
HOW GRANDMA. AFTER A MOTHER
OVERCOME YOUR SEVENTY FIVE
STUDENTS BY LEFT OUT OF IT BEING
FINANCE BECAUSE OF HUNGER OUT IN
WITH THE EGGMAN FINANCE HARDSHIP
AND IF YOU FOR ME I HAVE TO WORK
JOB WHILE THEY MY THREE. I CAN
PAY FOR TUITION AND UNNECESSARY
AS ONLY ONE THERE BY THE IN
COLLEGE. YEP YOU CAN ADDED
STRONG FAST AND I'M GOING ABOUT
THE ENOUGH AND AID BUT THE CAL
GRANT ID UNDERTAKEN FOR A
SOMETHING GREAT NOW I'M BY THE
CALL EIGHT COMMISSION I'M A BIG
FAN AID AND WANT YOU BOARD WITH
THANK SO MUCH THANK YOU IT'S
ALWAYS GREAT TO HEAR FROM BANANA
SLUG- MY NO SPEAKER. IF YOU- IN
ADDITION WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO SUPPORT AND INVEST IN THE
CAPACITY OF TEACHER PREPARATION
PROGRAMS. PARTICULARLY AT THE
CSU TO MEET THE DEMAND FOR MORE
EDUCATORS AT ALL LEVELS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS MODERATOR NEXT
SPEAKER. NINE TWENTY NINE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRISTY VALLEY HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
EMPLOYEES UNION NEW TO THIS TO
THIS AREA AND HAPPY TO BE HERE
THIS MORNING- I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK YOU FOR
INCLUDING PROVISIONS IN SB ONE
TWENTY NINE LAST YEAR WHICH
APPROPRIATED TWO MILLION
DOLLARS. IF YOU CHANCELLORS
OFFICE TO VALUATE CSU STAFF THE
SALARIES AND THE PERSON PROBLEMS
WITH EQUITY IN VERY OF LACK OF
AFFECT SALARY STEPS AND PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS TURN SALARY
MODEL OUR MEMBERS ARE BY THE
PROGRESS TO S. R. X. THAT THE
DRAFT OF FINE WILL BE IN MARCH
AND ADVANCE OF THE REPORT THAT'S
REQUIRED TO READ TO BE FURNISHED
TO YOU THE BUDGET COMMITTEES BY
APRIL THIRTIETH OF THIS YEAR
ONCE. WE EXPECT THE FUNDING TO
BE INCLUDED S. YEAR'S BUDGET
REQUEST AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
THE FINAL BUDGET THE SALARY AND
STAFFING CHALLENGES THAT PRESENT
PERSON FOR SO LONG AND WE HERE
TO AND SUPPORT ON THAT MATTER IT
COMES YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR. NEXT SPEAKER
. NEXT WE HAVE LONG THIRTY FIVE
THREE FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF THIS IS DEBBIE BROWN WITH
STRONGER AND FOR YOU AND I'M
JUST HERE TO X. ABOUT FOR
SUPPORT FOR PROBABLY DOLLARS I'M
GOING OKAY AND IN THE SPENT FOR.
FOX TO SUPPORT HER WERE VERY-APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROPOSAL AND
URGENT SUPPORT SECOND I WANT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE R. CAL
MODERNIZATION AND IN PARTICULAR
REMOVAL OF THE GPA REQUIREMENTS
FOR CAL GRANT ACCESS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
POPULATIONS THAT WE SERVE YOUTH
AND STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS CONTINUE TO FIND
THIS COULD BE THE BIGGEST
BARRIER TO CAL GRANT ACTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE KNOW WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM YOU IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS WELL-
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. BLIND
ONE. TWENTY TO FIVE. THE MORNING
CARE LAYERED AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JASIM PRASAD AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT LEGISLATORS FOR THE
CITY BUT AT THE TOP ME COLLEGES
AND I'M HERE TODAY AS PART OF
THE SIX FRANCE AID COLLECTIONS
YOU ALL FOR YOUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO FACE MANY
FINANCIAL BERGEN WE URGE
LEGISLATORS TO CONTINUE SUPPORT
ON MAKING CAL GRANT PROGRAMS. I
TOTAL FOR THE STUDENTS SUCH AS
MYSELF WHO DO NOT TO DO
QUALIFIED BUT I CANNOT
ACHIEVEMENT THE FINANCIAL AID
THAT THEY NEED TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL COSTS A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. WELCOME
TO LINE. THREE FOUR THREE FOUR.
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS THIS IS
BENJAMIN TRAN WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE LOS
ANGELES- ALSO REPRESENTING THE
BEST JUST CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET ITEM ONE
ON CAL GRANT REFORM- AS WE KNOW
WITH THE DIGITAL BARRIERS TO
ACCESS. THANKS THE MOST MARK
COMMUNITIES AND NOT ALSO PROJECT
INCLUDES THE ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY HOW THE HAS
HISTORICALLY FACED
MARGINALIZATION THROUGH LANGUAGE
AND ACCESS TO. THAT NOT BUILT
FOR THAT- SO MAKING IT ACTIVE
MOTION WILL ALSO THESE COMMUNITY
I THANK YOU TO MY FOR THE AND
HOPING THIS TO THIS ISSUE BEING
. THANK YOU REALLY ARE YOUR
MODERATOR NO SPEAKER. PINE
THIRTY THREE THREE. HELLO MY
NAME IS KIMBERLY WILL AND I
WOULD BE GOOD CREE AND WHAT THE
ARE AFTER WHAT O'CLOCK THE
ORGANIZATIONS WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE HOW WORK IS PUTTING
ON THE PATH THANK YOU AND I'M
LIKE BY RIGHT ARE YOU COULD PUT
ON IN CONSIDERATION BUDGET
OFFICE IT. FOR THE REQUIRED AT A
LINK GRANT AND WOKE I'M REAP
LIKE HOW THEY PUTTING ALL HIS
LONG PATH MASON HIGH COURT WOULD
HAVE MEANT HUNDRED NINETY. OF
THE NINETEENTH COMMUNITY WHAT IS. AND THE BOARD MAKE CALVET
EQUITY BY PARTY ALL COUNCIL ON
THE PATH TO HIGHER EDUCATION
GIVES IMPACT NINETY ON TOP
ECONOMY WITH THEM WE CANNOT TO
LOSE KNOCKED YOU TO IN OUR. I.
THANK YOU FOR LUNCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR MODERATOR
NEXT BE. WE'LL GO LINE. TWO
ZERO. GOOD MORNING SURELY CAN BE
MAINLY WHAT HE GUYS THAT YOU
TRAIL WHAT- FIRST WE'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT THE FUNDING THE CATHOLIC
COLLEGE PROGRAM BEING IS VITAL
CRITICAL AS WE. WORK PROSECUTED
COME. OR CHOIR MAN AT ARE AT
LOVE- NEXT SCHOOL YEAR. SECOND
WE TO SUPPORT THE ADDITIONAL
STAFFING PER ARE. NOT A BIG YOU
HEAR ME A LARGER IN THAT AFTER
GET A QUICK. AS WELL AS THE
INCREASE ON THE OF FINDING GOAL
OUT TO THE LAST HISTORIC BUDGET
CHANGES- WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST A
BLOOD. LEGISLATURE TO CONFINE
THAT FINANCIAL REFORM WHICH ARE
TO STREAM THE COLOR PROGRAM WILL
MOVE LINGERING OUT BARRIERS.
BETTER A NOT TUITION. AND THE
PRIOR KIND MONICA STUDENTS
MOVING ON TO DO TO COULD HAVE.
INCOME DRUG OF SIXTY. HAD
MENTIONED BY. MY COLLEAGUE THE
CAMPAIGN BECAUSE I. THIS IS A
RACIAL WE USE WHEN YOU KNOW
LEADERS. FINISH THE JOB AND
FOLLOW ON LAST YEAR'S HISTORY
INVEST AND CHANGES. FINALLY ON
HOW ISSUE LIKE ALL OF THE
IMPECCABLE GUIDING CORRECTAMENTE
. BY ON OUR TO RESEARCH DONE ON
OUR MY BOY TO REPORT- DOES THAT
. WE NEED DENY IT YOU COULD AND
I'M- BAKED ME. EXCUSE HOUSING
EXCEPT ME I WANT TO GO WAY OF A
FEW WOULD MIND JUST SUBMITTING
ADDITION COMMON IN RIGHT WITH.
IT THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
SO DO CHECK MODERATE NECK US.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT TO A- AFTER OR
GOOD MORNING ERICA BEHALF
BECAUSE IT'S OF COLLEGES AND YOU
HOW FINANCIALLY GRATEFUL FOR ALL
THE WORK ALREADY DONE BUT BEING
YOU IF YOU MOVE FOR- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WORKING CARE OF OUR
LOWEST SHOULD AND ALSO IN THE
PIRATES BEFORE WE MOVE ON. IF
YOU HAVE THE ORDER. INCOMES
REGULARLY ON YOU SEE IF YOU.
WELL IT'S GOING THAT THE FEW FEW
HAS. UP PERCENT IN AND WE'RE TO
THAT AND BUDGET. WE WOULD.
ADDITIONAL OPEN. FOR BOTH KYLE
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP- AT THE CSU
AS WELL AS FACULTY DIVERSITY
ISSUES WERE BROKE FUNDED AT
BETWEEN COLLEGES. WOULD LOVE TO
SEE AT THE FOR SIX MONTHS WELL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COM WITH. HIM NEXT. BUT LINE
FORTY. FOUR ONE. THE MORNING
CARE LEARN BETTER THE JOB AND
THEN- MANY TARGET MINIMUM BY
SITTING YOU DAVIS AND I GOV
RELATIONS AND THE TRACK WORKERS
ARE PROJECTED YOU CAN A AND I'M
SURE WITH YOU CAN FINANCIAL INC
. I TRANSIENT SHAPING IN THE
WHAT IN THE EMPIRE DO NOT FOR
CAL GRANT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
REPORT YOU DAVIS IN ORDER TO CAL
HOW IT HAD YOU LEAVE MY COUNTRY
AND MORE TIME IN COLLEGES IN THE
MONEY TO A THE FINANCE BURDEN OF
TAKE IN THE. SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. THE
MODERATOR NEXT SPEAKER. THAT'S
FROM LINE EIGHTEEN. GOOD MORNING
I'M DAVID THE BATTLE FALSE AND
DIRECTOR OF HIGHER EDUCATION A
PUBLIC ADVOCATE PUBLIC ADVOCATE
TO PUT THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE CALTRAIN EQUITY FRAMEWORK
THAT STILL EXISTS A LARGE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS FROM LOW INCOME
BACKGROUNDS WE DON'T HAVE ACTIVE
FIFTY EIGHT EIGHT ADOPTING THE
FULL FRAMEWORK WOULD ALSO BRING
CALIFORNIANS ALIGNMENT WITH
FEDERAL FNANCIAL AID
SIMPLIFICATION PROCESS. WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND AND
SIMPLIFY ACCESS TO STUDENTS WHO
WOULD OTHERWISE NOT BE ABLE TO
ATTEND COLLEGE IF NOT FOR THE
POKOK CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND MAKING HIGHER EDUCATION
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE COMMENTS MODERATOR
NEXT- THE METAL COME FROM MY-
NINETY. GOOD MORNING CAROLINE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WITH A
NORTHERN CAL COLLEGE PROMISE
COALITION OVER FIFTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS ACROSS TWELVE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTY SUPPORTED BY
THE THIRTY PLUS MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS AN ADVOCATE FROM
THE COALITION THEY RELY ON
ACCESS TO EQUITABLE AGED WORLD
PROTECT AND GRADUATE FROM
COLLEGE OUR MEMBERS ARE GRATEFUL
FOR THE PRODUCT MEETS POPE ARE
IN AGREED THERE'S MUCH MORE TO
DO TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS.
ESPECIALLY THE BATTERY DRIVE NOT
TUITION COSTS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THE SENATE
SUBCOMMITTEE MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION OF THE CAL GRANT
EQUITY FRAMEWORK IN EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX BY THREE
MINING THE CONTRACT PROGRAMS IN
Q. THREE SIMPLE PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO REMOTE ACCESS
BARRIERS NEED AND PRIORITIZE
THEIR STATE INVESTMENT TOWARDS.
THE LINCOLN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOU FOR SOME- NEXT. MEDLINE. FOR TWO FORTY. MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE SUPPORT- FIRST WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
PROPOSED 5% INCREASE IN UNREST
UNRESTRICTED BASE FUNDING
HOWEVER WE WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
THAT THIS AMOUNT BE INCREASED IN
ORDER FOR THE CSU THE BALI
ADDRESS FACULTY AND STAFF
COMPENSATION. SECONDLY WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FORCED PROPOSAL TO CONTINUE THE
INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING IN ADDITION TO THIS
PROPOSAL WE WOUD LIKE TO SEE
RESOURCES ALLOCATED TO
AFFORDABLE FACULTY HOUSING MANY
OF OUR MEMBERS CONTINUE TO
STRUGGLE WITH FINDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NEAR THEIR CAMPUSES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS- MODERATOR
NEXT SPEAKER. LINE. FORTY THREE
FOUR THREE. THE MORNING CARE
LAYERED AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MERRY WASHINGTON AND I'M
WITH THE CALIPHATE UNIFICATION
FOR CALLING TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES BUDGET
REQUESTS TAXATION ABOUT THE
INVESTMENT PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR THAT ARE PARTICULARLY
FUNDING THAT SUPPORTS ACADEMIC
SUCCESS IN OVERALL WELL BEING OF
STUDENTS THIS INCLUDES THE
FUNDING TO. BASIC NEEDS TECHNO
AND- SUPPORT AND TWELVE MILLION
- ON FOR COST YOU PROGRAM. YES
THE SAME PROUD MEMBER OF EXTENT
COALITION FOR CALM. FINANCIAL
AID REFORMS AND I YOU TO WORK
WITH US ON AN ACTING GRANT. FOR
MARKET THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS. IDENTICALLY ASKING HIM
BY TO. PROCESS I'M NOT TOO SURE
BECAUSE THE DRUG. INTO THE
REMOVAL OF OUR BARRIERS FOR
STATE. THE YOU. THANK YOU VERY.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR- MODERATOR
AND NEXT SPEAKER. THANK YOU LINE
FOR SEVEN. GOOD MORNING JERRY
MANY MEMBERS MY NAME IS ADAM
GOTTLIEB ADELAIDE PERSONALLY
ADDITIONAL FOR THE CAR COSTA
WILL NOT ONLY A OUT LIKE AFTER
COLLEGE TEN DAUGAARD ABOUT
STUDENTS FOR YEAR. WE ARE
WORKFORCE PARTNER OFFICE EFFORT
MODERNIZE CAL GRANT. WHICH BE
ENTITLED. LITTLE PRESIDENTIAL IS
TRAINING KEEPING OUR- FOR GOING
- MORE TO DOUBLE THE CAL GRANT
WHAT BELIEVE DOLLARS REVENUE.
CALIFORNIA ABOUT THE WORST THERE
. AND THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF
A MODERATOR NEXT CALL. BLIND.
FORTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING SURE
LARA AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHELLE ANDREWS AND I AM A
THIRD YEAR STUDENT AT UC DAVIS
AND THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE ASSOCIATED STUDENTS OF UC
DAVIS I'M CALLING TODAY AS A
PART OF AFFECT FINANCIAL AID
COALITION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED THE CORE OF ALL OF
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENT YOUR
COMMITMENT TO A ROBUST AND
MEANINGFUL CAL GRANT
MODERNIZATION EFFORT I'M ONE OF
THE OVER TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE LEFT OUT OF RECEIVING
THE PELL GRANT. BECAUSE OF AN
OUTDATED AND COMPLICATED BUT-
EVEN AFTER MY SINGLE MOTHER LOST
HER JOB DURING THE PANDEMIC I
WAS STILL UNABLE TO QUALIFY FOR
CAL GRANT- THIS APPLIED TO MY
FAMILY HAVING TO TAKE OUT OVER
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
STUDENT LOANS TO FUND MY FIRST
THREE YEARS OF COLLEGE- SO WE
URGENTLY NEED OUR STATE TO
INVEST IN ALL THAT YOU DAM AS WE
ARE GOING TO BE THE ONE TO FEEL
CALIFORNIANS. ECONOMIC RECOVERY
FROM THIS PANDEMIC AND BEYOND
BUT WE CAN'T DO THAT WITHOUT A
MEANINGFUL INVESTMENT IN OUR
STATE FINANCIAL AID- ESPECIALLY
THE CAL GRANT- SO WE'RE ASKING
YOU TODAY TO TAKE STRONG STEPS
AND MAKING ONGOING INVESTMENT IN
OUR FINANCIAL AID AND SUPPORT
THE CAL GRANT MODERNIZATION
EFFORTS THAT ARE BEING
UNDERTAKEN THROUGH EIGHTY
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX AND OF
OUTLINED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION IT'S TIME
TO FIX FINANCIAL AID AND MAKE
THE CAL GRANT ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
OF CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENTS
WHO NEED IT MOST. AND WE WANT
YOU ON BOARD WITH THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. OUR
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. FIND.
NINE THREE NINE YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALEXANDER AND I AM A STUDENT AT
UCLA AND A MEMBER OF GENERATION.
I THINK MY EDUCATION ON THE
ORGANIZATION AND I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT AND
CONSIDERATION OF THE BUDGET THE
CALIFORNIA GETTING A COMMISSION
ACT THAT YOU PRIORITIZE FINDING
IN THE CONTRACT WOULD BE PRETTY
MUCH. GOOD I. THEY MIGHT WORD
GAP PLAN SYSTEM TO STUDENTS
JUGGLING MY HIGHER COSTS
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING HOW THE
PANDEMIC HAS HIT LOWER INCOME
FAMILIES ACTUALLY QUITE. IN THE
PAST HI EDUCATION AT THE OF THE
FOR HER EDUCATION AND
INSTITUTIONS INCREASE AND COULD
NOT BE FOUND THE PROPERTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR COMMENTS. MODERATOR NICK
SPEAKER. LINE FOURTEEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNIFER CHAN AND I'M A
CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL IN THE
GARDEN GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND A MEMBER OF
GENERATION I DIDN'T LET
EDUCATION ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
CONSIDERATION OF THE BUDGET FOR
THE CALIFORNIA IN EIGHT
COMMISSION I HAPPY PRIORITIZE
THE CAL GRANT EQUITY FRANK MARK
I'M A LOW INCOME MINORITY AND
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS IN
ATTENDING COLLEGE A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION IN THE FALL I WOULD
HAVE QUALIFIED FOR THE PROGRAM
AND THE CAL GRANT HOWEVER IN
CALCULATION FOR MY FINANCIAL AID
I FEEL LIKE. I WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE OUT THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
STUDENT LOANS IT DOES NOT WORK-
SOPHISTIC AROUND FORTY THOUSAND
THE INCREASE THE CALGARY AND THE
ADDITIONS THE LOW INCOME UNITS
FRAMEWORK ONE BE ABLE TO SEE A
MY AGE AND. EVEN IF THE- AMOUNT
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER FOR THEM BE
ABLE TO INTO HIGHER EIGHT
EDUCATION HI HOW THAT YOU
CONSIDERED PILOTS TO THE PUBLIC
. OUTSIDE EQUITY FRAMEWORK. AND
HELP HIGHER EDUCATION EVERYWHERE
I EQUITY WITH A CALL. HERNANDEZ
COLLEGE I HIGHLY ENCOURAGE YOU
TO SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX WHICH WILL HELP MAKE
LANDMARK REFORMS TO THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAMS THIS WILL HELP
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO ARE CAL GRANT ELIGIBLE
PARTICULARLY ARE WORKING
STUDENTS MANY OF WHICH ARE
SUPPORTING FAMILIES WE NEED TO
AND THAT NONE SO WE CAN GET
THESE WORKING FAMILIES FIGHTING
CHANCE TO ACHIEVE THE CALIFORNIA
GREAT. YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
SEVEN FORTY SIX. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND CENTER ROADSHOW
BOGOR TO YOU AFTER DE FIGHT YOU
FROM KA YOU PROBABLY COULDN'T
SEE THAT A SO MONTEREY- NEXT
SPEAKER. LINE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JORDAN
SAYS THE CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION THE
STATEWIDE MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION OF CURRENT AND
FORMER FOX YOU THE POWER TO
TRANSFORM SYSTEM THERE
LEGISLATIVE AND POLICY CHANGE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS I'M GOING ON
GOING FOR FOSSEY'S CAMPUSES
SUPPORT PROGRAM AT THE ISSUES
AND STREAMLINING THE GPA
REQUIREMENTS. WHICH WILL HELP
MANY FOSTER YOUTH ACTIVITIES
RESOURCES WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S SUPPORT INCLUDING
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION IN THE
STATE BUDGET TO SUPPORT FOR
SHE'S PURSUING AND HIGHER
EDUCATION WE'RE ALSO IN SUPPORT
OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL CAL GRANT
SUPPORT FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
STUDENT. AT THE FORMER BOSS SHE
IS AN ALUMNI CATHOLIC FULLER TEN
GUARDIANS COLLEGE. I THE TAKE
THE NEW BY CHANGING THAT NOW OF
YOUTH AND FOSTER CARE PURSUING
HIGHER AND- TO EMPOWERING ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR MONTHS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. LINE
FIFTY PER GO AHEAD. HELLO
SENATORS- IN IN- YOU VERY MUCH
STORE- STUDENT MCKENNA COLLEGE
MEMBER OF GENERATION- JOINING MY
STUDENTS AND ASKING THAT WE
THINKING ABOUT THE BUDGET THAT
YOU'RE YOU PRIORITIZE FUNDING TO
CALPERS EQUITY FRAMEWORK- WHEN
GOING THROUGH THE COLLEGE
APPLICATION PROCESS BY FAR THE
MOST INTIMIDATING AND DIFFICULT
ASPECT ITS FINANCIAL AID- AND I
WAS LUCKY THAT MY PARENTS HAD
THE SPARE TIME TO HELP ME
NAVIGATE IT BUT THAT IS NOT THE
CASE FOR MANY MANY OF MY FRIENDS
AND CLASSMATES. AT LEAST IT
DIDN'T LINGER OPTIONS BECAUSE
THEY DON'T REALIZE THAT THEY MAY
BE ELIGIBLE FOR CERTAIN EIGHT
LIKE THE CAL GRANT- LIKE LEADERS
A STRAIGHTFORWARD COMMONSENSE
TAKEN FORM OF THE CALGARY
FRAMEWORK- I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE CHANGES IN INVESTMENT
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNMENT LAST
YEAR I HOPE THAT THIS YEAR WILL
BE A CONTINUATION THAT ATTENTION
TO STUDENTS NEEDS IN THE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PRIMARK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
COMMENTS MODERATOR. NEXT CALL.
FIND TWO PLEASE GO. THIS IS
ENOUGH ON WITH THE ANSWER BURKE
ARE AND SUCCESS WE ARE JUST TO
FILL THE LAST YEAR MONEY MENTAL
AND IN BECOMING COLLEGE CALTRAIN
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS BUT
STRENGTHENING THE COMING PROGRAM
. SPECIFICALLY MUST CHIEF THANK
YOU ORDERS TO OR OTHERWISE KALRA
ELEGY FROM ACTIVE NO DOLLARS
BACK CALL. AS WELL AND A WELL AS
THAT BURKE HOW GREAT THE WAY HE
BUT ANYONE PLACE. BUT THERE WE
MUST REMIND COGNOS CRITERIA WITH
SIMPLIFIED CALL GRANT COUNTY TO
LABEL EFFECT COMMUNITY THAT THEY
- AFTER COMPLETION COLLEGE FEE
TO. ADDITIONAL COVER
REQUIREMENTS WATER THAN EVER
KEEP UP I THINK FONG. OKAY AND
WILL BE THANK YOU FOR THE NEED
TO BE IN ADDRESS FLUENTLY COVER
INEQUITABLE NOW BUT HE COULD BE
NINETEEN INCREASE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATE NEXT. ON ISSUE ONE OF
YOUR GENDER WE ASK THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THIS
MOVEMENT TOWARDS EQUITY IN OUR
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM BY ADOPTING
THE CAL GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK.
BUCKLEY LEAST SIMPLIFYING CAL
GRANT INGRID GRANTING GREATER
ACCESS TO ALL STUDENTS WILL HELP
US ATTAIN EDUCATIONAL EQUITY FOR
ALL- AS PART OF OUR WORK IS THE
CAMPAIGN FOR CALIFORNIA BAR
RIGHT THE STATE IN RECENT YEARS
HAS MADE GREAT STRIDES TO REIN
IN THE PREDATORY DILUTES
EVERYTHING INDUSTRY. BUT ON THE
OTHER END OF THE CALL TO
PORTABILITY BACTRIM ENSURING AS
MANY STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
FINANCIAL AID WILL HELP TO FIND
ANYTHING THAT CRISIS. OUR
IMPACTED BY LOANS SIMILAR. CAL
GRANT EQUITY FRAMEWORK WILL
SUPPORT MORE THE STUDENTS AND
THOSE FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES
ATTAIN HIGHER EDUCATION WITHOUT
CRIPPLING STUDENT THAT. WE
SUPPORT THE FULL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE CALDERON EQUITY FRAMEWORK
AND THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION
OF THE TIME. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MIND
YOU'RE LEARNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MANAGE THE WALL FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM AND GUARDIAN
SCHOLARS PROGRAM AT UC
BAKERSFIELD I WANT TO CALL IN
SUPPORT AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
WITH THE TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS
BOND ONE BUDGET ALLOCATIONS AND
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR FOSTER
YOUTH SUPPORT PROGRAM. FOR ABOUT
TWELVE YEARS WE'VE WRITTEN
PRIVATE GRANTS PRIVATE
FOUNDATIONS AND PHILANTHROPY TO
SUPPORT ARAFAT YOU CANNOT TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS OF CONTINUING
FUNDING WILL GO A LONG WAY TO
EXPAND OUR PROGRAMS AND- BRING
CONSISTENCY THE SERVICES THAT WE
OFFER I CAN MORNING AND THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR. THIS CALL. SPECIALIZE
SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS EVEN MORRIS- AND I'M A
STUDENT AT PORT YOUR
TRANSMISSION THAT YOU SEE DAVID
I'M HERE TODAY A PART OF THE BIG
FINANCE AID BECAUSE COULD YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT FOR
OUR STUDENTS AND OUR COMMITMENT
TO OUR ABOUT THE MEANINGFUL CAL
GRANDMOTHERLY MODERNIZATION
EFFORT. I AM A H. CAL GRANT
RECIPIENT AND I DIDN'T RECEIVE
THE PELL GRANT UNTIL MY THIRD
YEAR WHEN I TRANSFERRED TO UC
DAVIS I WENT TO ACNE COLLEGE
FIRST BECAUSE I WAS ON HOLD FOR
THE CAL GRANT THE TIME TO DO
THAT THE I'M NOT A HIGH SCHOOL
GPA REQUIREMENTS. WELL I THINK
THAT WE CONTINUE TO MODERNIZE
THE CAL GRANT AND THE WAY THAT
WE DISTRIBUTE IT AND MAKE
ONGOING INVESTMENT TO FINANCIAL
AID AND SUPPORTING THE EFFORTS
AND EIGHTY SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX
AND OUTLINED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION THANK YOU CAN WATCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR
HOW MANY MORE CALLERS. DO WE
HAVE IN THE QUEUE. WE HAVE A
MORE IN THE QUEUE TEN TAKE THAT
MORE. AND CALLED DAY MARCH- THE
NEXT CALLER GETS THE LAST WORD.
MY NUMBER SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I NEVER SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY NUMBER SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE NEED
TO GO. HI GOOD MORNING SENATORS
MONEY WITH MODERATES NOT SHOW
AND THEN THE STUDENTS- A THIRD
YEAR STUDENT AT UCSD I'M HERE
TODAY AS PART OF THE BIG
FINANCIAL AID COALITION- OUT OF
THE CAL GRANT RECIPIENT WE ASK
TODAY TO TAKE STRONG STEPS MAKE
ONGOING INVESTMENT IN OUR
FINANCIAL AID CAL GRANT AND
NAVAL ME TO PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION ISSUE HIGHER EDUCATION
HE SAYS. ABOUT IT HI I DON'T
KNOW HOW I COULD HAVE PAID. OFF
MY WAY HERE- I CAN GET WE ASK
YOU. TO AFFECTED BY NOW AID
CONTINUE THE- I'LL GO. SIX THAT
MANY OF THE HERE ARE AND THAT IS
A FOR TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MUCH PUSH YOUR COMMENTS
MODERATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR WORK- FOR HELPING US TODAY.
THAT MOVE- COMPLETES OUR HEARING
I'M IN JUST A CENTER CHAU BUGS
CENTER MEN ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
ARE WE HAD TWENTY EIGHT OF
PEOPLE THAT TESTIFIED WERE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND WE WANT TO
THANK THEM ALL IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFIED TODAY OR FOR
SOME REASON YOU DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO COMPLETE YOUR
STATEMENT PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE ARE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANKS EVERYBODY
ELSE FOR THEIR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION TODAY THIS INCLUDES
OUR AGENDA WE WILL SEE MANY OF
YOU HERE. A TOMORROW MORNING AT
NINE O'CLOCK FOR NEXT HEARING
RANA CONGRATULATE MISTER FRANCIS
FOR SUCCESSFULLY NAVIGATING HIS
FIRST HEARING IS AS CONSULTANT
ARE WE WILL STAND ADJOURNED.